In these first few videos, I want to lay the
foundation of some core concepts you will
need throughout these video tutorials. Let's
get started with the basics. So what is a
data structure? one definition that I really
like is a data structure is a way of organizing
data so that it can be used efficiently. And
that's all data structure really is it is
a way of organizing data in some fashion so
that later on it can be accessed, queried,
or perhaps even updated quickly and easily.
So why data structures? Why are they important?
Well, they are essential ingredients in creating
fast and powerful algorithms. Another good
reason might be that they help us manage and
organize our data in a very natural way. And
this last point, is more of my own making.
And it's that it makes code cleaner and easier
to understand. As a side note, one of the
major distinctions that I have noticed from
bad mediocre to excellent programmers is that
the ones who really excel are the ones who
fundamentally understand how and when to use
the appropriate data structure for the task
they're trying to finish. data structures
can make the difference between having an
okay product and an outstanding one. It's
no wonder that every computer science undergraduate
student is required to take a course in data
structures. It is strange that before we even
begin talking about data structures that we
need to talk about the abstraction of data
structures. What I'm talking about is the
concept of an abstract data type. What is
an abstracted type and how does it differ
from a data structure? Well, the answer is
that an abstract data type is an abstraction
of a data structure, which provides only the
interface to which that data structure must
adhere to. The interface does not give any
specific details on how
a specific data structure should be implemented,
or in what programming language. One particular
example I like to give is to suppose that
your abstract data type is for a mode of transportation
to get from point A to point B. Well, as we
both know, there are many modes of transportation
to get from one place to another. So which
one do you choose? some specific modes of
transportation might be walking or biking,
perhaps even taking a train and so on, these
specific modes of transportation would be
analogous to the data structures themselves.
We want to get from one place to another through
some mode of transportation, that was our
abstract data type. How did we do that? Exactly?
Well, that is the data structure. Here are
some examples of abstract data types on the
left, and some possible underlying implementation
on the right hand side. As you can see, a
list can be implemented in two ways. You can
have a dynamic array or a linked list. They
both provide ways of adding, removing and
indexing elements in the list. Next, we have
a queue and the map abstract data types, which
themselves can be implemented in a variety
of ways. Notice that under the implementation
for a queue, I put a stack based queue because
yes, you can have a queue, which is implemented
using only stacks. This may not be the most
efficient way of implementing a queue. But
it does work and it is possible. The point
here is that the abstract data type only defines
how a data structure should behave, and what
methods it should have, but not the details
surrounding how those methods are implemented.
Alright, now that we were done with abstract
data types, we need to have a quick look at
the wild world of computational complexity,
to understand the performance that our data
structures are providing. So as programmers,
we often find ourselves asking the same two
questions over and over and over again. That
is, how much time does this algorithm need
to finish and also how much space Does this
algorithm need for my computation. So, if
your program takes a lifetime of the universe
to finish, then it's no good. Similarly, if
your program runs in constant time, but requires
a space equal to the sum of all the bytes
of all the files on the internet, internet,
your algorithm is also useless. So just standardize
a way of talking about how much time and how
much space is required for an algorithm to
run. theoretical computer scientists have
invented big O notation, amongst other things
like big theta, big omega, and so on. But
we're interested in Big O because it tells
us about the worst case. Big O notation only
cares about the worst case. So if your algorithm
sorts numbers, imagine the input is the worst
possible arrangement of numbers for your particular
sorting algorithm. Or, as a concrete example,
suppose you have an unordered list of unique
numbers, and you're searching for the number
seven, or the position where seven occurs
in your list. And the worst case isn't one
seven, that is at the beginning. Or in the
middle of the list, it's one seven is the
very last element of the list. for that particular
example, the time complexity would be linear
with respect to the number of elements in
the size view list. Because you have to traverse
every single element until you find seven.
The same concept applies to space, you can
just consider the worst possible amount of
space your algorithm is going to need for
that particular input. There's also the fact
that big O really only cares about what happens
when your input becomes arbitrarily large.
We're not interested in what happens when
the input is small. For this reason, you'll
see that we ignore things like constants and
multiplicative factors. So in our big O notation,
you'll often see these coming up. Again, again,
again. So to clarify one thing,
when I say n, n is usually always want to
be the input size coming into your algorithm,
there's always going to be some limitation
of size n. So constant time referred to as
a one wrapped around a big O. If your algorithm
case in logarithmic amount of time to finish,
we say that's big O of a log event. If it's
linear, then we just say n, if it takes like
quadratic time or cubic time, then we say
that's n raised to that power, it's exponential.
Usually, this is going to be something like
two to the n three, the N, N number be greater
than one to the n. And then we also have n
factorial. But we also have things in between
these like square root of n log log of n,
n to the fifth and so on. Actually, almost
any mathematical expression containing n can
be wrapped around a big O. And is big O notation
valid. Now, we want to talk about some properties
of Big O. So to reiterate what we just saw
in the last two slides, Big O only really
cares about what happens when input becomes
really big. So we're not interested when n
is small, only
what happens when n goes to infinity. So this
is how and why we get the first two properties.
The first that we can simply remove constant
values added to our big O notation. Because
if you're adding a constant to infinity, well,
let's just infinity, or if you're multiplying
a constant by infinity, yeah, that's still
infinity. So we can ignore constants. But
of course, this is all theoretical. In the
real world. If your constant is of size, 2
billion, probably, that's going to have a
substantial impact on the running time of
your algorithm.
However, let us look at a function f, which
I've defined over some input size. And if
f of n is seven log of n cubed plus 15 n squared
plus two n q plus eight. Well, big O of f
of n is just n cubed, because n cubed is the
biggest, most dominant term in This function.
All right, now let's
look at some concrete examples of how big
O is used. So both of the following run in
constant time with respect to the input size,
and because they don't depend on n
at all.
So on the left, when we're just adding or
doing some mathematical formula, yes, that's
constant time. And on the right, okay, we're
doing a loop, but the loop itself doesn't
depend on n. So it runs also in a constant
amount of time. So as our input size gets
arbitrarily large, well, that loop is still
going to run in the same amount of time regardless.
Now let's look at a linear example. So both
the following actually run in
linear time with respect to the input size,
and because we do a constant amount of work,
and times.
So on the left, we're incrementing, the counter
AI by one each time. So f of n is and, and
clearly, when we wrap this in a big go get
a big O of n. On the right, a little bit more
complicated, we're not incrementing by one,
we're incrementing by three, so we're going
to finish that loop three times faster. So
f of n is n over three. So our second example
is two algorithms that run in quadratic time.
So the first one seems obvious, we do n work
at times. So n times as big O of n squared.
But observe the second one, I changed the
zero with an eye. So pause the video and try
to figure out maybe why that's big O of n
squared. Okay, let's go over the solution.
So first, just focus on the second loop. The
first loop isn't as important. So since I
go from zero to n, the amount of looping done
is going to be directly related to what AI
is, and remember is changing from the outer
loop. So if we fix AI to be zero, we do n
work. We fix it one, we do n minus one work.
If we fix it, too, we do n minus two work
and excetera. So the question then becomes
what is n plus n minus one plus n minus two
plus n minus three and so on? Well, this is
a well known identity, and turns out to be
n times n plus one divided by two. So if we
wrap this in a big O, we split our equation,
we can see that this is big O of n squared.
Now let's look at perhaps a more complicated
example. Earlier, you may have wondering,
how do we ever get these log Eurythmics or
linear rhythmic time complexities? So here's
a classic algorithm of doing a binary search,
which yields actually a logarithmic time complexity.
So what this algorithm does is it starts by
making two pointers, one at the very start
in one at the very end of the array, then
it selects a midpoint between two and checks
if the value we're looking for was found at
the midpoint, and then has either found it
or not, if it has found it, it stops. Otherwise,
it discards one half of the array, and adjusts
either the high or the low pointer. remark
that even in the worst case, we're still discarding
half of the array, each iteration. So very,
very quickly, we're going to run out of a
range check. So if you do the math, the worst
case is you will do exactly log base two of
N iterations, meaning that the binary search
will runs in logarithmic time. Very cool algorithm,
a very powerful algorithm. Here's a slightly
different example worth going over. So first,
notice that there is an outer loop with a
counter I that does and work, then notice
that there are two inner loops, one that does
three n work another one that does, too, one
work. So the rule we use to determine the
complexity of this algorithm is to multiply
loops on different levels and add those that
aren't the same, generally speaking. So, so
using the rule above, we can see that it takes
n work to do the outer loop, multiply by three
n plus two n for both inner loop Which gives
us five n squared, which is big O of n squared.
All right, so this next one looks very similar,
but it's actually quite different. So on the
outer loop with AI, we have AI going from
zero to three n. So there's three n work done
on the outside. But we have to multiply that
but what's going on on the inside,
so the inside
j goes from 10, to 50. So that does 40 loops
exactly every loop. So that's a constant for
the amount of work. Plus however, the second
loop, so j is less than and cubed, but j is
J equals j plus two, so it's accelerated a
little, so we're going to finish that loop
a little faster. So we're gonna get on the
inside 14, plus n cubed divided by two, but
we have to multiply that by three n. So we
wrap that in a big O. So big O of f of n,
is going to give us big of enter the force,
because And the fourth is the dominant term
in our function, f of n. For some other classic
examples of Big O. So if we have to find all
the subsets of a set, that takes an exponential
amount of time, because there are two the
N subsets, finding all permutations of a string
takes big O of n factorial. Another classic
one is merge sort. So we have n times log
in for your merge sort. And if we have to
iterate over all the cells of an array of
size n by n, we have big O of n m. Time. All
right, let's talk about arrays, probably the
most used data structure. This is part one
of two in the array videos. The reason the
array is used so much is because it forms
a fundamental building block for all other
data structures. So we end up seeing everywhere.
with arrays and pointers alone, I'm pretty
sure we can construct just about any data
structure. So an outline for today's video.
First, we're going to begin by having a discussion
about arrays and answer some fundamental questions
such as what where and how are arrays used?
Next, I will explain the basic structure of
an array and the common operations we are
able to perform on them. Lastly, we will go
over some complexity complexity analysis and
look at some source code on how to construct
a dynamic array using only static arrays,
discussion and examples. So what is a static
array? So static array is a fixed length container
containing elements, which are indexable,
usually on the range of zero, inclusive to
n minus one also inclusive. So a follow up
question is what is meant by being indexable?
So answer this is this means that each slot
or index in the array can be referenced with
a number. Furthermore, I would like to add
that static arrays are given as contiguous
chunks of memory. Meaning that your chunk
of memory doesn't look like a piece of Swiss
cheese with a bunch of holes and gaps. It's
continuous, all the addresses are adjacent
in your static array. Okay, so when and where
is a static array used? Well, they're used
everywhere, absolutely everywhere. It's hard
to make a program that doesn't use them. In
fact, here are a few places you may or may
not know that do use arrays. So of course,
the first simple example is to temporarily
store objects most common use of arrays that
you're probably familiar with. Next is that
we use arrays as buffers to store information
from an input or an output stream. Suppose
you have a really large file, for instance,
that you need to process but that file is
so big, it doesn't fit in all in memory. So
we use a buffer to read small chunks of the
file into The buffer or the array, one at
a time. And so eventually we're able to read
the entire file. I also like to use arrays
as lookup tables because of their indexing
property. So this is a really easy way to
retrieve data from the lookup table if you
know where everything is at supposed to be
and at what offset. Next, we also use arrays
as a workaround in a programming language
that only allows one return value.
So the hack we use then is to return a pointer
or a reference to an array, which then contains
all the return values that we want. This last
example is a bit more advanced, but arrays
are heavily used the programming technique
called dynamic programming, with tabulation
to cache already computed subproblems. So
a classic example of this might be the knapsack
problem, or the coin change problem. All right,
I'm talking about some complexity. So the
access time for static array and a dynamic
array is constant because of a property that
arrays are indexable. Searching, however,
it can take up to the linear time because
we potentially have to traverse all the elements
in the array in the worst case, such as if
the element you're looking for does not exist.
Inserting appending. And deletion from a static
array doesn't really make sense. The static
array is a fixed size container, it cannot
grow larger or smaller. When inserting with
a dynamic array, this operation can cost up
linear time, because you potentially have
to shift all the elements to the right, and
recopy all the elements into the new static
array. This is assuming we're implementing
a dynamic array using static arrays. However,
appending though, is constant, Doesn't that
seem a little strange? Well, when we append
elements to a dynamic array, we have to resize
the internal static array containing all those
elements. But this happens so rarely, that
appending becomes constant time. deletions
are linear, for the same reasons that insertions
are linear, you have to shift all of the elements
over and re potentially recopy everything
into your static array. Okay, so we have a
static array A I've defined at the top. So
a contains the values 4412 minus 517 6039
100. Currently, all the elements are distinct,
but this is not a requirement of an array.
Also remark that the very first element 44
has index position zero in the array, not
one. This confuses many, many intro computer
science students, you have no idea. The confusing
part is that most, if not all, mathematics
is one base to work computer science is one.
Now, if we look at a you can see that it contains
the values 4412 minus 517 6039, and 100. Currently,
all the elements are distinct. However, this
is not at all a requirement of the array.
Also remark that the very first element 44
is indexed, or positioned at index of zero
in the array, not one, zero. This confuses
a lot of intro computer science students.
The confusing part is that most if not all,
mathematics is one based while computer science
is zero based. This is what causes the confusion.
But Worst of all, is quantum computing. I
did research one summer in quantum computing
during my undergrad, and the field is a mess.
It tries to please mathematicians, computer
scientists and physicists all at the same
time. And indexing just doesn't work well.
Anyways, back to arrays. I should also note
that elements can be iterated over using a
for each loop something that's offered in
some programming languages. It doesn't require
you to explicitly reference the indices of
your array. Although the indexing is done
internally, behind the scenes, the notation
of the square brackets denotes indexing. So
array A square bracket zero, close square
bracket is equal to 44, meaning a at position
zero
is equal to the value 44. Similarly, a position
one is 12, a, four, six and seven is nine.
But a index nine is out of bounds. And our
program will throw an exception. Unless you're
in C, it doesn't always throw an exception,
unfortunately, okay. Now if we assign positions
zero to B minus one that happens if we assign
index five B to and if we assign index x to
be 25, let's look at operations on dynamic
arrays. So dynamic arrays can grow and shrink
in size as needed. So the dynamic array can
do all similar get set operation static arrays
can do but unlike the static array, it grows
inside as dynamically as needed. So if we
have a containing 34, and four, there, if
we add minus seven, it gets appended to the
end. If we add 34, again, then it will add
it to the end. And we can also remove elements.
So you see here, our dynamic array shrink
in size. Pretty cool, right? Okay, so we already
talked about this a little bit. But how do
we formally implement a dynamic array? Well,
the answer is typically this is done with
a static array. But this is not the only way,
of course. So first, we create a stack if
you're a with some initial capacity, usually
nine zero. So as we add elements, we add elements
to the underlying static array, keeping track
of the number of elements added. Once, we
have to add an element with exceeds the capacity
of our internal static array, what we can
do it again, double the size, copy all the
elements into this new static array, and add
the new element we need to add, let's see
an example. So suppose we create a dynamic
array with an initial capacity of two, then
we begin adding elements to it. So the little
circle with the slash through it is a placeholder
for an empty position. Okay, so we add seven,
everything's fine, we are nine, everything's
fine. But once we add three, it doesn't fit
in our internal static array. So we doubled
the size of the array, copy all the elements
in, and now we can add three. Now, if we add
12, everything's still okay, we're doing good.
And if we add five, okay, we have to do a
resize again. So double the size of the container,
copy all the LLM elements into this new, larger
array, and then finish off by adding five.
And similarly, we can add six without any
issues. All right, time to look at the dynamic
array source code. This is part two of two
in the array series. So the source code for
this video can be found at the following link
github.com, slash my username slash data dash
structures. Also make sure you saw the last
video so you know what's going on with this
array implementation. Alright, here we are
in the array class. So I've designed an array
class to support generics of type T. So whatever
type of data we want put in this array, that's
fine. So here are three instance variables
that we care about our, which is our internal
static array.
Len,
which is the length the user thinks the array
is. And capacity is the length of the actual
array, because sometimes our array might have
more free slots. And we don't want to tell
the user that there's extra free slots that
are available. That's just our internal knowledge.
So there's two constructors. The first one
will initialize the array to be of size 16.
The other one you give it a capacity, the
capacity of course, has to be greater than
or equal to zero. And then we finish Why's
our array and cast it to a type T also noticed
I put this suppress warnings and unchecked
just because of annoying generics in Java.
So here are two simple methods size, get the
size of the array and check if the array is
empty, pretty self explanatory. Similarly
forget inset, we just index into the array
if we want the value or set it if we want
to set the value, technically, I shouldn't
be doing a bounds check for both of these,
but I'm not apparently. Okay, clear. So here,
we just remove all the data in our array and
reset the length. Simple. This next one is
the Add method where things actually get a
little bit more complicated. So this condition
says, Hey, if the length
plus one is greater than or equal to the capacity,
then it's time to resize my right. The way
I'm resizing is I'm doubling the size of the
static array. You don't have to double the
size, but I've decided that doubling the size
is convenient. So when I double the size,
I have to create a new array with the new
capacity. copy everything in this is what
this line or these lines are doing, it's copying
the old values back into this new array, and
then it sets the old array to be the new array.
And lastly, here, we just copy the new value
into our right. So this remove AZ method will
remove a particular value at a given index.
First, we check if the index is valid. If
it's not through index out of bounds exception,
otherwise, grab the data at the Remove index.
initialize a new array of size length minus
one. Now copy everything into the new array,
except
for when it's at that remove index. Now I'm
sure there's easier ways to do this. But I
decided to do the following maintain two indices
i and j. increment i and j as you go. But
when i is equal to the Remove index, then
we skip over the Remove index by fixing j
temporarily and using j to lag behind, if
you will while is still in the original array.
So I guess pretty clever overall. And then
set the array to be the new array we just
generated. Reset the capacity and return the
data we have just removed. So this next one
remove, we scan through the array. If we find
the object we're looking for, remove it at
the index and return true otherwise return
false. Index of is very similar. If you find
it return I otherwise return minus one. Contains
just checks if index of is not equal to minus
one. All right, this next one, I return an
iterator for the array. So an iterator allows
us to iterate over the array providing an
abstraction for it. So I need to override
two methods. And this is has next. So there
exists an x element in our array, if the index
is less than the length of the array. I should
also be checking for concurrent modification
here, just in case someone decides to change
the array for some reason why we're modifying
it might add that later might not.
Also,
there's the next method, which just returns
the next element in the array relative to
the iterator. Okay, and lastly is the to string
to get a string representation of this array.
Nothing too complicated. Alright, so this
is a very simple data structure. It's just
a dynamic array. If you look at Java's ArrayList
It looks very Very similar to this. Today
we're going to talk about singly and doubly
linked lists one of the most useful data structures
out there. This is part one of two and the
second part we will be looking at some source
code on how to implement a doubly linked list.
So for today's outline, in the first section,
we're going to answer some basic questions
concerning singly and doubly linked lists,
namely, what are they and where are they used.
Next, we'll cover some terminology concerning
linked lists, so everyone knows what I mean
when I say the head of linked lists versus
the tail of the weight class. Then last in
the discussion, we'll talk about the pros
and cons of using singly and doubly linked
lists, then how to insert and remove elements
from both singly and doubly linked lists as
well as some source code. So stay tuned. Alright,
discussion. So what is the link list linked
lists is a sequential list of nodes that hold
data which point to other nodes also containing
data. So below is an example of a singly linked
list containing some arbitrary data. Notice
that every node has a pointer to the next
node. Also notice that the last node points
to no meaning that there are no more nodes
at this point.
The last node
always has a null reference to the next note,
for simplicity, I will omit this in the following
slides. Okay, so where are linked lists use.
One of the places they get used the most is
actually in the abstract data type implementation
of lists, stacks and queues because of their
great time complexity for adding and removing
elements. You also see linked lists and things
like circular lists, making the pointer of
the last node points the first node. So circular
linked lists are used to model repeating events
cycles, maybe like having a round robin ordering
on a bunch of elements or representing corners
with polygon. So definitely allow use as they're
linked lists can also be used to model real
world objects such as a line of train carts
that could be useful. And moving on some more
advanced examples. We also heavily use linked
lists and hash table separate chaining, and
for adjacency, lists and graph so we'll get
to those in a later video. Okay, a bit of
terminology surrounding link lists. First
thing you need to know when creating a linked
list is that we always maintain a reference
to the head of the link lists. This is because
we need somewhere to start when traversing
our list. We give a name to the last element
of the linked list. Also this is called a
tail of the list. Then there are also the
nodes themselves, which contain pointers.
pointers are also sometimes called references.
And these pointers always point the next node.
You should also know that the nodes themselves
are usually represented as structs, or classes
when actually implemented. We'll get to this
when we look at the source code. Okay, singly
versus doubly linked lists, sort of concerning
the kinds of linked lists that there are there
are two types, singly linked and doubly length.
singly linked lists only contain a pointer
to the next node, while doubly linked lists
not only contain a pointer, the next node,
but also to the previous node, which makes
it quite useful sometimes. This is not to
say we cannot have triple or quadruple the
length lists, I just wouldn't know where to
place additional pointers, pros and cons of
doubly linked lists. So there are trade offs.
Between picking a singly and a doubly linked
list. What are they? If we look at the singly
linked lists we observed that uses less memory.
Why? Well, pointers to nose can actually take
up a lot of memory. If you're running on a
64 bit machine references use eight bytes
on a 32 bit machine four bytes each. So having
a singly linked list means you only need one
pointer for each node, hence, twice as much
memory is saved. a downside however, is that
you cannot access previous elements because
you don't have access to them. You would need
to traverse from the head of a linked lists
all the way up to the previous node defined
it. Now concerning doubly linked lists with
a grid Pro is that having access to the tail
we can easily traverse the list backwards,
something we can't do with a singly linked
list. Also having a reference to know Do you
want to remove, you can remove it in constant
time and patch the hole you just created.
Because you have again access to both the
previous and an ex notes, this is something
you cannot do with a singly linked list, you
would leave the list severed into a downside
however, to the doubly linked list is it does
use twice as much memory. Okay, let's go into
some implementation details on how we can
create linked lists and remove elements from
linked lists. Starting with a singly linked
list. So here is a singly linked list. I've
outlined where the head and the tail is. Now
we want to insert 11. At the third position
where seven is currently, let's walk through
an example. So the first thing we do is we
create a new pointer which points to the head.
This is almost always the first step in all
linkless operations. Now what we're going
to do is seek up to but not including the
node we want to remove. So if we seek ahead,
and we advanced our traverser pointers, setting
it equal to fives next node, which is now
23. And now we're actually ready already where
we need to be to insert the next node. So
we create the next node, that's the green
node 11.
And we make 11 elevens. Next pointer, point
to seven. And the next steps that change 23
is next pointer to be 11. Remember, we have
access to 23 is next pointer, because we have
a reference to it with the traverser. Okay,
and now we flatten out the list, we can see
that we've correctly inserted 11 at the right
position. And we're done. Okay, all right
time to insert with a doubly linked list.
This is much trickier because of all the pointers
flying around. But it's the exact same concept.
Notice that the dump doubly linked list not
only has pointers to the next node, but also
to the previous node, we also have to change
those in the insertion phase. Okay, create
a traversal pointer, which points to where
the head is, and advance it until you are
just before the insertion position. So we
advanced the traversal by one and now we're
just before the node so we start traversing
let's create the new node which is node 11.
Point elevens, next pointer to equal seven.
Also point leptons previous pointer to be
23. Which we have a handle on because of the
traverser. How we make sevens previous pointer
equal to 11. So we can go backwards from seven
to 11. And the last step, make 20 threes next
pointer equal to 11. This is so that we can
go forwards from 23 to 11. So in total remarked
that we changed exactly four pointers. So
we've flattened out the list, you can see
that 11 has been inserted in the correct position.
All right now how to remove elements from
a singly linked list. So suppose we want to
remove the node with a value nine. How do
we do this? Well, the trick we're going to
use is not to use one pointer but two, you
can use one but for visual effects, it's easier
to show you how it is done by using two. So
we create pointers, travel one and track two
for traverser one in Traverse e two respectively.
So traverser one points to the head, traverse
or two points to the heads. next node. Now
we're going to do is advanced traffic to until
we find the node we want to remove while also
advancing draft one. Okay, we have found node
nine. So this is the stopping point. I'm going
to create another pointer to the node we wish
to remove so we can deallocate its memory
later. Okay, so now I had to have advanced
traffic to to the next node Note nine has
turned red. I've done this to indicate that
this will that at this point, node nine is
ready to be removed. I'm just keeping it around
for the visual effect. Okay, so now set trav
once next pointer to be equal to trap two.
And now is an appropriate time to remove the
temporary pointer because doing nothing with
it and their temp has been deallocated. Make
sure you always clean up your memory to avoid
memory leaks. This is especially important
in C and c++ and other programming languages
where you manage your memory. Now you can
see that nine is gone, and our singly linked
list is shorter. Okay, now for the last bit
of implementation, let's look at how to remove
nodes from a doubly linked list, which is
actually easier in my opinion to removing
from singly linked lists. The idea is the
same, we seek up to the node we wish to remove.
But this time, we only need one pointer. I
mean one traverse or pointer. Because each
node is singly linked list has a reference
to the last node, so we don't need to manually
maintain it like we did with the singly linked
list.
So let's start travel at the very beginning
and seek until we hit nine. Okay, we have
reached nine. And we want to remove it from
the list. To do this set for us pointer to
be equal to 15 with access to four and 15
because they are traves, previous and next
pointer respectively. Similarly set 15 previous
pointer to equal four. Notice that drive is
now read, meaning it is ready to be removed.
So we get rid of travel. And now if we flatten
out the doubly linked lists, we see that it
no longer contains nine. Let's do a bit of
complexity analysis on linked lists how good
actually are linked lists. On the left column,
we have singly linked lists. And on the right
doubly linked lists. The complexity for searching
in a linked list is linear in the worst case,
because if the element we're looking for is
not there, we have to traverse all of the
n elements. inserting it the head, though,
is constant time, because we always maintain
a pointer to the head for a length list, and
hence we can add it in constant time. Similarly
for the tail. To remove the head of a singly
linked lists, and a doubly linked list is
also constant time. Again, because we have
a reference to it, so we can just move it
at and advanced the head by one. However,
removing from the tail is another story. It
takes linear time to remove elements from
a singly linked list. Can you think of Why?
Well, even if we do have a reference to the
tail in a singly linked lists, we can remove
it but only once. Because we can't reset the
value of what the tail is. So we had to seek
to the end of the list and find out what the
new tail is equal to. W linked list however,
do not have this problem, since they have
a pointer to the previous node. So we can
continually remove nodes from the tail. And
finally, removing somewhere in the middle
is also linear time because in the worst case,
we would need to seek through n minus one
elements, which is linear.
Alright, time
to look at some double e linked list source
code. This is part two of two in the linked
list series. So the link for the source code
can be found on GitHub and github.com slash
Williams he's a slash data dash structures.
Please start this repository if you find the
source code helpful so that others may also
find it. And also make sure you watch the
first part of the linkless series before continuing.
Here we are in the source code. We're looking
at the implementation of a doubly linked list
in Java. So first, notice that I have declared
a Few instance variables. So we are keeping
track of the size of the link list, as well
as what the head and the tail currently are.
To begin with the head and the tail are no
meaning link list is empty. Furthermore, we
will be using this internal node class quite
excessively, because it contains the data
for our nodes. And it also contains the previous
and next pointers for each node since this
is a doubly linked list. So we have one constructor
for the node, namely the data and the previous
and the next pointers themselves, we need
both otherwise, we can't do much. So his first
method I have declared here is to clear the
list, it does so in linear time by going through
all the elements and deallocating them last
time deallocates them by setting them equal
to No. So we started to reverse or at the
head, we loop while the traverser is likely
to no meaning there are still elements less
and then we do our deallocation business.
And at the end, we set the size equal to zero
and reset the head and tail. Perfect. These
size and empty methods are pretty self explanatory,
get the size and check if the size of our
linked list is empty. Okay, so here I have
a public method to add an element by default,
we're going to append to the end of the linked
list or at the tail. But I also support adding
to the beginning of the linked list. So how
do we do this, if this is the first element,
make a list is empty, then we set the head
and the tail to be equal to the new node,
which has, you can see here both previous
and next pointers set to No. Otherwise, if
the list is not empty, then we say the heads
previous pointer is equal to this new node.
And then we set the head, the head pointer
to be whatever hands previous is. So we backup
the pointer in a sense. And we also don't
forget to increment the size. A very similar
thing is done when we want to add to the tail
length list, except we're moving the tail
pointer around.
OK, let's
move to peak. So peaking is just looking at
either the element at the beginning of the
linked list or at the end of the linked list.
And we throw a runtime exception if the list
is empty, because doesn't make sense to peek
an empty list. Okay, now we get to the first
more complex method, which is remove first.
So this is if we want to remove the head of
the linked list. So we can't do much if the
list is empty. Otherwise, we'd get the data,
we extract the data at the head, and then
move the head pointer forward, we decrease
the size by one. So if the list is empty,
we set the tail to be known as well. So both
the head and the tail are now No. Otherwise,
we deallocate the memory of the previous node
that we just removed. This is especially important
if you're in C or c++, make sure to free or
delete pointers, then at the end, we return
the data. Very similar thing is done for last
except we're using the tail this time to remove
from the tail the linked list and not the
head. Okay, and here's a generic method to
remove an arbitrary node remark that I set
this to private because the node class itself
is private so the user shouldn't have access
to the node. That's just something we're using
internally inside the linked list data structure
to manage the list. So if the node that we're
removing is either at the head or the tail,
detect that and call our methods either remove
first or remove last. Otherwise, we know we're
somewhere in the middle of linked list. And
if we are we make the pointers adjacent to
the to our current node equal to each other.
So we're effectively skipping over the current
node and And of course, don't forget to clean
up your memory and return the data. So we
have to temporarily store the data. Of course,
before we delete the node, otherwise, we've
deleted the node and the data is already gone.
Now, suppose we want to remove a node of a
particular index and our linked list. Yes,
we can do this. Even though our nodes are
not explicitly indexed, we can pretend that
they are. So first check that the index is
valid, otherwise throw an illegal argument
exception. So here, we are trying to be a
bit smarter than just naively going through
a linked list either when we start searching
from the front of the linked list to find
our index or from the back depending on if
the index is closer to the front or to the
back, although this method remains linear.
So for the Remove method, we want to be able
to remove an arbitrary value from my linked
list, which is object. So we're going to also
support searching for null values in case
someone decided that the value of the node
should be no, that's fine. So we checked that
special case. Otherwise, we traverse through
the length list until we find a null element
and then remove that node and return true
we return true if we actually found the element
we want to remove. Otherwise, we return false
down here. In this else statement, we search
for the element we want to remove, we use
the dot equals method to check if we found
the element. If so, remove that node and return
true.
Okay,
here we have a related method which is index
of. So this is not remove at an index, or
remove value, but get whatever index this
object is at. Again, sports searching for
null. So even if our values No, we'll just
return the first place we find no element.
So again, first link list. Otherwise, search
for a non null element and also increment
the index as we go. We can use the index of
four our method contains to check if an element
is contained within a linked list because
we return minus one if the element is not
found. Something that's useful sometimes is
to have an iterator for the link list. This
is also trivial to implement, just start a
pointer, traverse at the head and traverse
until you reach the end. Notice I'm not checking
for concurrent modification error, but if
you want to, it's pretty easy to do that.
And lastly, at the very bottom, we have to
the to string method to print a string or
to get rather a string representation of our
linked list. May I begin by saying that the
stack is a remarkable, absolutely remarkable
data structure, one of my favorites. In fact,
this is part one of three in the stack videos.
Part Two will consist of looking at a stack
implementation, and part three will be some
source code for how a stack is implemented
using a linked list. So here are the topics
that we'll be covering in this video as well
as the others. First we will answer the question
about what is a stack and where is it used?
Then we will see some really really cool examples
of how to solve problems using stacks. Afterwards,
we will briefly look at how stacks are implemented
internally and the time complexity associated
the stacks operation. And lastly, of course,
some source code. Moving on to the discussion
about stacks. So what is a stack? A stack
is a one ended linear data structure which
models the real world stack by having two
primary operations, namely, push and pop.
Below you can see an image of a stack I have
constructed. There is one data member again
popped off the top of the stack and another
data member getting added to the stack. Notice
that there is a top pointer pointing to the
block at the top The stack. This is because
elements in a stack always get removed and
added to the top of the pile. This behavior
is commonly known as LIF o, or last in first
out. Let's look at a more detailed example
on how a stack works and how things are added
and removed from a stack. So let's walk through
an example on the left side, I have some instructions
on what we need to add and remove to the stack.
So the first operation is a pop. So we remove
the top element from the stack, which is Apple.
So boom, Apple is gone. Now we push onion
onto the stack. So we add onion to the top
of the stack. Next x instruction says to push
celery onto the stack. Next is watermelon,
which we put on top of the stack. Next operation
says to pop so we remove the element at the
top of the stack. This is the watermelon we
just added. The next operation also a pop.
So we removed from the top of the stack. This
is celery. And last operation push lettuce
onto the stack. So we add lettuce on the very
top of the stack. So as you can see, everything
operates on the top of the stack, we don't
have access to anything else but the top of
the stack. This is critical in our understanding
of how
a stack works. So when in Where is a stack
used, stacks are surprisingly used absolutely
everywhere. They're using text editors to
enter tags you've written in browsers to navigate
backwards or forwards. They use some compilers
to make sure you have the correct number of
matching braces, and in the right order. stacks
are used to model real world stacks such as
books, plates, and even games like the Tower
of Hanoi, which we'll get to
shortly.
stacks are also used behind the scenes to
support recursion by keeping track of previous
function calls. When a function returns it
pops the current stack frame off the stack
and rewinds to the next function that is on
stack. It's rather remarkable that we use
stacks all the time in programming and never
even notice it. Something else you can use
stacks for us to perform a depth first search
on a graph. A depth first search can be done
manually by maintaining your own stack, or
by using recursion. Well guess what both use
stacks as we have just discussed complexity
analysis. So the following complexity table
assumes that you implemented a stack using
a linked list. Pushing takes constant time
because we have a reference at the top of
the stack at all times. Well the same argument
goes for popping and peeking. Searching however,
still takes linear time, the element we're
searching for isn't necessarily at the top
of the stack. So we may need to scan all the
elements in the stack, hence require a linear
amount of work. Now here's the cool example
of a problem using stacks problem. So given
a string made up of the following brackets,
round brackets square brackets curly brackets
determine whether the brackets properly match.
So analyzing examples below to understand
what type of bracket sequences valid and which
ones are invalid. So before I show you the
solution, try and come up with a solution
yourself. Hint use a stack
Okay,
in this first example, consider the following
bracket sequence. As we are processing the
string from left to right, I will be displaying
the current bracket and the associated reversed
bracket. So let's begin. For every left bracket
we encounter we simply push those on the stack.
So this is the left square bracket that I
have highlighted in light blue. So we push
this one on the stack. Same goes for the next
left square bracket and for this left curly
bracket
Okay,
this is a right square bracket. So we encountered
a right square bracket. We need to do two
checks. First we check if the stack is empty.
If so the bracket sequence is invalid. But
if there are still things in the stack that
we pop the top element and check if its value
is equal to the reversed current bracket.
Right now the top element is equal to the
reversed bracket. So we are good. Next is
a right square bracket again. So is the stack
empty. No, it isn't. So we're good. Is the
top element of the stack equal to the reversed
bracket? Yes, it is. So let's keep going around
a left bracket. Let's push it onto the stack.
A right bracket. Is the stack empty? No. Okay,
so we're good. Is the top element of the stack
equal to the reverse bracket? Yes. Okay. So
we're good. And other right bracket? Is the
stack empty? No. Okay, good. And there's the
top element of the stack equal to the reverse
bracket. Yes. Okay, good. And now we're done
processing the string, we need to make sure
the stack is empty. Now. Why is that? Well,
in case the last few characters and the bracket
sequence were left brackets, they would still
be in the stack, right? But our stack is empty.
So we can conclude that this bracket sequence
is indeed valid. All right, let's do another
example with another bracket sequence. So
trying to work this one out. So the first
bracket is a left bracket, so we push onto
the stack. The second bracket is also a left
bracket. So we push onto the stack. This next
bracket is a right bracket. So let's check
if the stack is empty. No, it's good. And
is the top element of the stack equal to the
reverse bracket? Yes, it is. This next bracket
is a right bracket. Is the stack empty? No.
So we're good. And is the reverse bracket
equal to the bracket at the top of the stack?
No, it isn't. So this bracket sequence is
invalid. So here's the pseudocode of the algorithm
we just ran through. So if we let us be a
stack, and for every bracket in our bracket
string, we can get the reverse bracket for
that current bracket easily. So if our bracket
is a left bracket, push it on to the stack.
Otherwise, we check if the stack is empty.
And if the element at the top of the stack
is not equal to the reversed. If either of
those conditions are true, then we return
false otherwise, we return whether the stack
is empty or not. And if it is empty, then
we have a valid bracket sequence otherwise
we do not. I want to take a moment and look
at the Tower of Hanoi, a very popular game
amongst mathematicians and computer scientists.
To see how it relates with stacks. The game
is played as follows. You start with a pile
of discs on the first peg on the left. And
the objective of the game is to move all the
disks to the right most
this pile, and each move, you can move the
top desk of a pile to any other pile with
a restriction that no disk be placed on top
of
a smaller desk. So we can think of each peg
as a stack, because we're always moving the
top element in a peg and placing it on another
peg. So shall we play, I will let the animation
run. And you will see how each peg acts like
a stack. It's pretty cool.
So you just saw how transferring elements
from one page to another is exactly the same
as popping a disk from one stack and pushing
that same disk onto another stack, given that
the disk you're placing on top is smaller.
So that's really cool. Welcome to part two
of three in the stack series. This is going
to be a short video on one way to implement
a stack. So those stacks are often implemented
as either arrays singly linked lists or even
sometimes double linked lists here We'll cover
how to push nodes onto a stack with a singly
linked list. Later on, and we will look at
the source code, which is actually written
using a doubly linked list. Okay, to begin
with, we need somewhere to start to be in
our link place, so we're going to point the
head to a null note. This means that the stack
is initially empty. Then the trick to creating
a stack using a singly linked list is to insert
the new elements before the head and not at
the tail of the list. This way, we have pointers
pointing in the correct direction when we
need to pop elements off of the stack. As
we will soon see, the next element however,
we need to push onto the stack is a two. So
let's do that. To create a new node, adjust
the head pointer to be the newest node and
then hook on the nodes next pointer to where
the head was before. And we use the same idea
for five and also 13. Now let's have a look
at popping elements. This isn't too hard either,
just move the head pointer to the next node
and deallocate the last note. So here we pop
the first node off the stack and set the nodes
reference to be null. So they will be picked
up by the garbage collector if you're coding
in Java. And it will since there are no other
references pointing to it. If you're in another
programming language that requires you to
explicitly deallocate free memory yourself
like C or c++, now is the time to do that.
Or you will get memory leaks. Getting a memory
leak in a data structure is one of the worst
kinds of memory leaks, especially if it's
a custom data structure that you intend on
reusing. So keep watching out for that not
only in this video, but in all the data structures
that we will be covering. If you see in an
implementation and not correctly cleaning
up my memory, please please point out to me,
or send a pull request to the GitHub repository
so we can patch that. Okay, so we keep proceeding
by removing the head and bouncing the head
pointer down to the next node. Pop again,
and pop again. There we go. We've stopped
popping we've reached last note and the stack
is now empty. Welcome to part three of three
in the stack series videos. Today we'll be
looking at some source code for a very simple
stack. So the source code can be found on
github.com slash William fiza slash data dash
structures. Make sure you understood part
one and two of the stack series before continuing.
So you actually know how we implement a stack
using a linked list. Also, if you like this
video series, and the implementation of the
stack data structure I'm about to present
to you then please start this repository on
GitHub so that others can have an easier time
finding it as well. Here we are in the stack
source code the senate implementation in the
Java programming language. So the first thing
you may notice is here I have an instance
variable of a length list. This is the linked
list provided by Java. In fact, it's a doubly
linked list provided by Java. This is a little
lengthy list they provide in their package
Java dot util that I will be using today,
instead of the one that I created, and the
link list
videos, this is just for portability, in case
you want to use this stack for whatever reason.
So we have two constructors, we can create
an empty stack, or we can create a stack with
one initial element. This is occasionally
useful. First method we can get the size of
the stack. So to get to do that, we return
the size of the internal links list with all
the elements of our stack easy. We also check
if the stack is empty by checking if the size
is zero. So this next one is just push so
to push an element onto the stack, we just
append that element as the last element in
our internal linked list. Easy enough we can
also pull element of the stack. So to do this,
we check if the stack is empty. If it is,
then we throw an empty stack exception because
we can't pop an element off of an empty stack.
That doesn't make sense. Similarly, the same
thing with peak, we can't observe what the
top element of the stack is, if the stack
is empty. And if it's not there, we can pick
the last element of our list. And lastly,
we can return an iterator to allow the user
to iterate through our stack. This iterator
returns an iterator for our linked list, which
supports concurrent modification errors. So
this was a really, really quick implementation
that was static. It's only like 50 lines of
code. Let's talk about queues are probably
one of the most useful data structures in
computer science. So this is going to be part
one of three in the Q series. So the outline
of things we'll be looking at. First, we're
going to begin by talking about queues and
what they are. Then we're going to go into
some complexity analysis concerning queues.
Then we'll discuss the implementation details
of n queuing and D queuing elements from a
queue followed by some source code at the
very end in the last video. So a discussion
about queues. So what exactly is a queue?
So below you can see an image of a queue.
But a queue is just a linear data structure
that models a real world queue. Having two
primary operations we can do which are enqueuing,
and D queuing. So ever queue has a front and
a back end, we insert elements through the
back and remove through the front. Adding
elements to the back of the queue is called
n queuing. and removing elements from the
front of the queue is called D queuing. However,
there's a bit of terminology surrounding queues
because there's not really any consistency
or when we refer to as queuing D queuing,
many people will use multiple different terms.
So and queuing is also called adding but also
offering a similar type of thing happens when
we're talking about D queuing. So this is
when we remove things from the front of the
queue. This is also called polling elements.
However, some people will also refer to this
as removing an element from the queue. But
the problem with saying that is that can cause
some ambiguity, did they mean removing from
the front of the queue specifically, or from
the entire queue? Make note that if I say
removing I'm going to be referring to removing
from the front of the queue unless I say otherwise.
So let's look at an example of how queue works
in detail. However, first, notice I have labeled
the queues front and back ends, so you know
where I'm going to be in queueing and D queuing
from respectively to avoid confusion. first
instruction says in queue 12, so we add 12
to the end of the queue, then dq, so we remove
the first element from the front of the queue,
which is 55. Another dq operation, this time
we removed minus one from the front of the
queue. Next, and Q seven, so add seven to
the back of the queue.
dq, so remove the front element being 33.
And lastly, and Q minus six, so at the back
of the queue, just like that.
So now that we know where a queue is, where
does this data structure actually get used?
Well, a classic example of where cuneus gets
us is to model a real world queue where you're
waiting in line at a movie theater or in the
line at a restaurant. For instance, have you
ever been to say McDonald's, where all the
caches are full. As soon as one of them gets
fried, the next person in line gets to order
food? Well, that's a cue. So queues are can
also be really useful if you have a sequence
of elements coming in, but you only keep track
of say, the x most recent elements, while
you can add those elements to queue, and once
your queue gets larger than x elements, just
dq essentially queues are also often used
in server management. So, suppose for a moment
that you have a web server, that's idly waiting
for requests from people to use your website,
that at any given moment, you can simultaneously
serve up to five people. But no more. If 12
requests come in, in a short amount of time,
you're not going to be able to process all
of them as new ones come in. So what you do
is you process the five that you're able to,
and the remaining seven gets a chill and a
queue waiting to be served. And whenever you
finish processing a request, you dq and the
next request, and then you start processing
it, and you do this until the queue is empty.
While you're doing this, more requests come
in to access your web page, while you just
add them to the end of the cube. queues are
also using graph theory. To perform a breadth
first search traversal on a graph, which is
actually really useful. We're going to see
this example in the next video. All right
now concerning complexity analysis of a queue.
So as we're seeing, it's pretty obvious that
n queuing and D queuing operations are constant
time. There's also another operation on a
queue I have not mentioned yet, and this is
peaking. peaking means that we're looking
at the value at the front of the queue without
removing it, the source or cost and time.
However, checky if an element is contained
within the queue, is linear time since we
would potentially need to scan through all
the elements. There's also element removal
In this sense, not in the sense of D queuing
or polling, but in actually removing an element
from the queue internally. This also requires
linear time, since we would have to scan through
all unknown elements in the worst case. In
this video, we're going to have a look at
how queues are used to do a breadth first
search. And then we're going to look at the
actual implementation details of how n queuing
and D queuing elements works. Okay, onto the
breadth first search example. So breadth first
search is an operation we can do on the graph
to do a graph traversal. If you don't know
what I mean, when I say graph, I mean a network
not a bar graph or a line graph or anything
like that. But first, I should explain the
breadth first search in the breadth first
search. The objective is to start a node and
traverse the entire graph, first by visiting
all the neighbors of the starting node, and
then visiting all the neighbors of the first
node you visited and then all the neighbors
of the second node you visited and so on,
so forth, expanding through all the neighbors
as you go. So you can think of each iteration
of the breadth first search as expanding the
frontier from one node outwards at each iteration
as you go on. So let's begin our breadth first
search at node zero. So I'm going to label
node zero as yellow and put it in the frontier
or the visiting group. And now I'm going to
visit all the neighbors of zero being one
and nine and add those to the frontier. And
then we resolve the neighbors of one and nine
being only eight. Similarly, for eight, so
seven, and visit all the neighbors of seven.
So I added a bunch of elements, my friend
here, and now visit all the neighbors of the
yellow nodes.
And now we're done our breadth first search
because we no longer have any elements on
frontier. Notice that there's 12 that is the
unvisited because 12 is a lunar node on an
island all by itself. So we are not able to
reach it for the breadth first search, which
is fine. Suppose you want to actually code
a breadth first search, how would that be
done? Well, the idea is to use a cube. So
first, we add the starting node to our queue.
And then we mark the starting node as visited.
And while our queue is not empty, we pull
an element from our queue or D queuing. And
then for every neighbor of this node, we just
D queued if the neighbor has not been visited
yet mark the neighbor is visited and added
to the queue. So now we have a way of processing
all the nodes in our graph in a breadth first
search order. Really, really useful, very,
very popular graph traversal algorithm. So
now let's look at implementation of queues.
So let's begin with an queueing. So it turns
out that you can implement the queue abstract
data type in multiple different ways. But
the most popular methods are to either use
arrays, singly linked lists, or doubly linked
lists. If you're using an array, you have
to make sure your arrays are going to be big
enough. If it's a static
array, if it's a dynamic array, then you'll
be fine. Right here, I'm going to show you
how to do it with
a singly linked list and the source code,
we're using a doubly linked list. So stay
tuned for that. In a singly linked list, we're
going to have a head pointer and a tail pointer.
So initially, they're both No. But as we n
q, we add, well, we just add the first note,
so nothing really interesting is going on
right now. But as we add more elements, you
can see that we're pushing the tail pointer
forward. So we're adding a node and then getting
the tail pointer point to the next node. Now
dq is a bit of the opposite. And so pushing
the tail forward, we're going to be pushing
the head forward. So push the head forward
one, and then the element that was left over
was the one we want to dq and return to the
user. So why don't we push the head pointer
forward, we said in the last note to know
so that it can be picked up by the garbage
collector if you're in Java. And if you're
in another programming language, which requires
you to explicitly deallocate or free memory,
yourself like C or c++, now's the time to
do that. So you see, as we keep D queuing,
we're just pushing the head forward and forward
again. And at the very end, if we add a bunch
of elements, then remove them all then the
head and the tail again, point to know which
is where we started. All right, now it's time
to have a look at some source code for Q.
So I implemented a queue and you can find
the source code at the following link on github.com
slash my user name slash data dash structures.
Also make sure you have watched and understood
parts one and two from the Q series before
continuing. Alright, here we are looking at
some source code for a queue. So this source
code is in the Java programming language,
although you can probably translate it into
any programming language that you need. So
the first thing to remark is I have an instance
variable here of a linked list. So this is
a Java's implementation of a doubly linked
list. We also use this in the stack implementation,
as you'll see the queue and the stack implementations
are very, very similar. So here I have two
constructors, one create just an empty queue.
And another optional one, which will create
a queue but with a first element. In fact,
I should probably check if this is no, but
we we might want to allow no elements. So
let's just leave it like that. So the next
method is the size, it just gets the size
of the link list. And similarly, this checks
if the length list is empty. Those are both
pretty self explanatory. Okay, next interesting
method is the peak method, the peak method
returns the element that's at the front of
the queue, but it will throw an error if your
queue is empty because you can't peek anything
when your queue is empty. Similarly, for poll,
this will pull the element to the front of
the queue, but unlike peak will actually remove
the element from the queue. So next, we scroll
down a little bit, I have offer which adds
an element to the back of the queue. I guess
I am allowing for no elements. So if you don't
want elements, just put an if statement and
throw an error or something. So the poll removed
from the front. And you can see offer ads
to the back. So remove first and add last.
And the last method. And here is an iterator
in case you want to be able to iterate through
all the elements in your queue. Very short
and very simple implementation just under
50 lines of code, you can create a queue.
Although there are faster ways of creating
queues, especially with arrays.
The idea with arrays, especially static arrays,
if you know the maximum amount of elements
that will be in your queue at any given time,
then you can create an array of that maximum
size and have pointers to the front and the
back positions in your queue. And add and
remove elements based on the relative position
of those pointers. If you ever get to a position
where you're running off the edge of your
array, then you can loop around to the front
of the array and keep processing elements
like that this a lot faster than having to
maintain references to the next node, such
as in a linked list. So I guess I'll say that's
your homework is to create a static array
based queue. Today, we're going to talk about
everything to do with priority queues from
where they're used to how they're implemented.
And towards the end, we'll also have a look
at some source code. Along with all the priority
queue stuff. We're also going to talk about
heaps since both topics are closely related,
although not the same. So the outline for
the priority queue series is we're going to
start with the basics talking about what are
priority queues and why they're useful. And
then we'll move on to some common operations
we do on priority queues and also discuss
how we can turn min priority queues into max
priority queues followed by some complexity
analysis. And we'll talk about common ways
we have implemented priority queues. Most
people think heaps are the only way we can
implement a priority queue, or that priority
queues somehow are heaps, I want to dispel
that confusion. Next, we're going to go into
some great detail about how to implement the
priority queue using a binary heap. there
we'll look at methods of sinking and swimming
nodes up and down our heap. These terms are
used to get and shuffle around elements in
a binary heap. As part of the implementation
explanation, I also go over how to pull and
add elements. So there's a lot to cover. So
let's get started. discussion and examples.
This is going to be part one of five in the
priority queue series. So what is a priority
queue? a priority queue is an abstract data
type that operates similar to a normal queue
except for the fact that every element has
a certain priority. So elements with a higher
priority come out of the priority queue first.
As a side note, I'd like to remark that priority
queues only support elements that are comparable,
meaning that the data we insert into the priority
queue must be ordered in some way, either
from least to greatest or raised lease. This
is so we can assign relative priorities between
elements. Okay, let's go into an example.
So suppose we have all these values that we
inserted into a priority queue on the right,
and that we impose an ordering on the numbers
such that we want to order them from least
to greatest. So the smaller numbers have a
higher priority than the bigger ones. So they
will be removed from the priority queue first.
Suppose we have now a list of instructions.
So what the poll operation means is remove
the element that has the highest priority
in our priority queue. So let's see how this
works. So if I say Paul, then I remove the
element with the highest priority, which happened
to be one. Now I say add two, so we add two
to our priority queue. And Paul, so next report
of smallest elements in our priority queue,
and that happened to be the two we just added.
Next, we add for all this smallest, this is
three, add five, oh, also add nine and then
pull the rest. So as I pull the rest, I'm
continuously grabbing the smallest element
in the
priority queue. So it turns out that as we
added, and Paul numbers, we got an ordered
sequence. This is a coincidence. Actually,
as we added the pull numbers from the priority
queue, we do not necessarily end up getting
an ordered sequence, we are only guaranteed
that the next number that is removed from
the priority queue is the smallest number
that was currently in the priority queue.
So how does the priority queue know, which
is the next smallest number to remove? As
humans, we could see the numbers visually
inside the priority queue and look and know
what one was the smallest the whole operation
was going to return. But fundamentally, how
does the machine know this? Does it resort
all the elements inside a priority queue before
each pull operation? No, in fact, that would
be highly ineffective. Instead, it uses what
is called a heap. So the next big question
then is what is a heap? Usually I make up
my own definitions, but I really liked this
one from wiki. A heap is a tree based data
structure that satisfies the heap invariant
also called the heap property. If a is a parent
node of B, then A is ordered with respect
to B for all nodes A and B in the heap. What
this means is the value of the parent node
is always greater than or equal to the value
of the child node for all nodes. Or the other
way around that the value of the parent node
is less than or equal to the value of the
child node for all nodes. This means we end
up getting two types of heaps, Max heaps,
and min heaps. So max heaps are the one with
where the parent node is always greater than
its children. And the min heap is the opposite.
So both of the following are actually binary
heaps binary because every node has exactly
two children. And the children cannot see
or no values I have not drawn in. So why are
we interested in heaps? heaps form the canonical
underlying data structure for priority queues?
So much so that priority queues are sometimes
called heaps, although this isn't technically
correct, since the priority queue, again,
is an abstract data type, meaning it can be
implemented with other data structures also.
Okay, we're going to play a little game, I'm
going to give you some structures. And you
need to tell me whether it is a heap or not.
So inspect the following structure and try
to determine whether it's a heap or not, you
can pause the video if you'd like. But I'm
just going to give you a short moment here.
No, we have a violation of the heap invariant
and this tree. So it's not a heap. Is this
structure a heap? Yes, it is a heap because
it satisfies a heap invariant, and it is a
tree. So we often see heaps like these and
why we're called binomial heaps. Note that
heaps aren't necessarily binary heaps. They
can have any number of branches. On to our
next one. So is this a valid heap? Yeah, it's
a valid heap. Because even though this one
is strangely, strangely structured, we're
free to move around the visual representation
of the nodes as we please. So yeah, it's a
valid heap. How about this one? No, this structure
is actually not even a tree because it contains
the cycles. All heaps must be trees. What
about this one? Yeah, so heap. What about
this one? Also heap because it satisfies the
heap invariant that all all nodes are less
than or equal to or greater than or equal
to its parent. How about this one? No, it's
not onto the heap and because it does not
satisfy that heap invariant. However, if we
do change the root to be 10, then we can satisfy
the heap invariant via a min heap.
Or rather sorry, a max heap. So when and where
is a priority queue and he used probably one
of the most popular places we see priority
queues is in Dykstra shortest path algorithm
to fetch the next nodes we explore. priority
queues are really handy anytime you also need
a behavior in which you need to dynamically
fetch the next best or the next worst element.
They're also used in Huffman encoding, which
is often use for lossless data compression.
Many best first search algorithms use priority
queues in their implementation to continuously
gain grab the next most promising node in
the graph as it's being traversed. And finally,
we also see priority queues in prims minimum
spanning tree algorithm on directed graphs.
So it seems priority queues are really important,
especially for graph theory algorithms, which
is where we see them often. Okay, on to some
complexity with priority queues implemented
as a binary heap. To begin with, there exists
a method to construct a binary heap from an
unordered array in linear time, we're not
going to cover this algorithm, but it's pretty
cool. And it forms the basis for the sorting
algorithm heapsort. Next is pulling and, or
rather removing pulling or removing an element
from the root of the heap. This takes logarithmic
time, because you need to restore the heap
invariant, which can take up to logarithmic
time. So peaking or seeing the value at the
top of our heap can take constant time, which
is really nice. Adding an element to our heap
takes logarithmic time, again part because
we possibly have to reshuffled heap by bubbling
up the value as we will see in a later video.
Then there are a few more operations we can
do on priority queues. So removing a an element,
which is not the root element. So the naive
way of removing an element in a heap is to
do a linear scan to find the items position
and then remove it. The problem with this
is it can be extremely slow in some situations,
especially if you're removing a lot. But generally
don't do this. And it's not a problem, which
is why most implementations are just Yes,
lazy and do the linear scan solution. However,
there does exist a way to reduce the removing
time complexity, which I will go over later
in a later video in great detail in this video
series. So stay tuned for that this method
uses a hash table to reduce the removing time
complexity to be logarithmic, which is super
critical, actually, if you're removing as
much as you are adding. Now the naive method
to check containment within a heap. binary
heap is linear. Again, you just scan through
all the elements. But with the help of a hash
table, we can reduce this to be a constant
time, which is super neat. Especially if we
use the hash table implementation for the
removing speed up we get as a free bonus.
The downside however, to using hash table
implementation is that it does require an
extra linear space factor. And it does add
some constant overhead because you're accessing
your table a lot during swaps. Today, we're
going to talk about turning min priority queues
into max priority queues. This is part two,
a five in the priority queue series. So you
may already be asking yourself, why is it
important that I know how to convert a main
priority queue into a max priority queue?
Well, here's the problem. Often in the standard
library, most programming languages, they
will only provide you with either a max priority
queue or a min priority queue. Usually it's
a main priority queue, which sorts elements
by the smallest element first, but sometimes
we need the max priority queue depending on
what we're programming. So how do we do this?
How do we convert one part one type of priority
queue To another type. Well, a hack we can
use is to abuse the fact that all elements
in a priority queue must implement some sort
of comparable interface, which we can simply
negate, or invert. To get the other type of
heap. Let's look at some examples. Suppose
for a moment that we have a priority queue
consisting of elements that are on the right
side of this screen, and that these are in
that min priority queue. So if x and y are
numbers in the priority queue, and x is less
than or equal to y, then x will come out of
the priority queue before y. the negation
of this is x is greater than or equal to y.
And so y then comes out before x, because
all these elements are still in the priority
queue. Wait a moment you say, isn't the negation
of x is less than or equal to y, just x greater
than y, and not x is greater than or equal
to y? Well, not for competitors. You see if
x is equal to y, whether or not the competitor
is negated, x should still equal y. So now
let's see what happens when we pull all these
elements out of priority queue with our negated
comparateur. So first, we will get 13 because
it's the greatest. Next comes 11 753. And
two. An alternative method for numbers is
to negate the number before you insert it
and negate it. Again, when it comes out. This
is a hack specific to numbers, but it's pretty
nice. So let's see how that works. So let's
negate all the numbers inside a priority queue.
And now we can see that definitely minus 13
is the smallest so should come out first.
So minus 13, and indeed comes up first. But
now we have to remake the data and we 13.
Everything is good so far. Next is minus 11.
So really positive 11. And so on my seven,
seven, and so I'm just so keep polling and
then arena, get the value to get it out of
the priority queue. It's a pretty neat hack.
Okay, now let's look at my other examples
using strings. So suppose Lex is a competitor
for strings, which sorts strings in lexicographic.
Order, this is the default for most programming
languages, then, let's call n Lex be the negation
of Lex. And also let's assign s one and s
two to be some non null strings. So below,
you can see that our comparateur assigns minus
one if s one is less than s two Lexa graphically
zero. So equal x so graphically, and plus
one if s one is greater than s two lexicographically.
And then n lacks is just the negation of that.
So just to break it down, ALEKS sorts strings,
like so graphically, but we're interested
in gaining legs so that longer strings appear
before sort of shorter strings and also that
strings with letters at the end of the alphabet
appear before those containing letters. At
the beginning of the alphabet, I think I said
that right. This was in effect turn a man
he into a maxi beep. Let's look at a concrete
example. So by adding all the numbers on the
right to a prayer queue with the lexicographic
comparateur, here's the ordering we should
expect. First we get a because it's the shortest
string that has characters appearing closer
closest to the start of the alphabet, then
it comes at B, then f Zed, then x then x R
and x x. So now let's do the same thing with
n Lex. And we should hopefully obtain the
opposite sequence in reverse order.
And then we get x x x r x f, Zed mi N A. So
it did exactly what we intended to do. Today
we're going to talk about adding elements
to a binary heap. This is part three of five
The priority queue series, we'll get to adding
elements to our binary heap shortly. But first,
there are some important terminology and concepts
leading to that, which we need to go over
prior to add elements effectively to our priority
queue. Okay, so a very popular way to implement
a priority queue is to use some kind of heap.
This is because heaps are the data structure,
which give us the best possible time complexity
for the operations we need to perform with
a priority queue. However, I want to make
this clear, a priority queue is not a heap.
A priority queue is an abstract data type
that defines the behavior a priority queue
should have. The heap just lets us actually
implement that behavior. As an example, we
could use an unordered list to achieve the
same behavior we want for a priority queue.
But this would not give us the best possible
time complexity. So concerning heaps, there
are many different types of heaps including
binary heaps, Fibonacci heaps, binomial heap,
pairing heaps, and so on, so on. But for simplicity,
we're just going to use the binary heap. binary
heap is a binary tree that supports the heap
invariant. In a binary tree, every node has
exactly two children. So the following structure
is a binary heap, which satisfies the heap
property that every parent's value is greater
than or equal to the child that every node
has exactly two children. Well, no, you may
be thinking the bottom nodes, also known as
leafs don't have children. Well, actually,
Yes, they do. Here they are. They're the knowledge
children in gray. But for simplicity, I won't
draw those because they're annoying to draw.
Okay. The next important bit of terminology,
we need to understand is the complete binary
tree property. The complete binary tree property
means that at every level, except possibly
the last is completely filled, and that all
the nodes are as far left as possible in the
binary tree. As you will see, when we insert
nodes, we always insert them at the bottom
row. As far left to meet this complete binary
tree property. Maintaining the complete binary
tree property is very, very important, because
it gives us an insertion point, no matter
what the heap looks like, or what values are
in it. The next note, we insert will go into
the hollow circle that and the next one will
go to the right of it, and so on until eventually
we fill up the row, at which point we need
to start a new row. So the insertion point
is a very important. One last thing before
we actually get into how to add values into
a binary heap, is we need to understand how
to represent one of these binary heaps. And
there is a canonical way of doing this, which
is to use an array actually. So using an array
is a very convenient actually, because when
we're maintaining this complete tree property,
the insertion position is just the last position
in our array. However, this isn't the only
way we can represent the heap, we can also
represent the heap using objects and pointers
and recursively add and remove nodes as needed.
But the array construction is very elegant,
and also very, very fast. So on the left is
the index tree just to help you visualize
the position of each node in the array. And
on the right is the actual tree remark that
as you read elements in the array from left
to right, it's as though you're pacing through
the heap, one layer at a time.
So if we're at no nine, which is index zero,
we're at the top for node eight. We're at
position one. And as I keep moving along,
you can see that we're just pacing through
the array going from left to right. So it's
very convenient, that way When not also another
interesting property of story, I'm binary
heap in array is that you can easily access
all the children and parent nodes. So suppose
I is the index of a parent node, then the
left child is going to be at index two times
i plus one, and the right child of that node
is going to be at two i plus two, this is
zero base. If it's one base, then you would
just subtract one. So suppose we have a node
seven, which is highlighted in purple. Well,
its index is two. So by our formula, the left
child of seven should be located at two times
two, plus one, or, or five. If we look at
index five, we expect to get one and if we
look at the right child, we should expect
to get two times two plus two or six. If we
look in our array, this gives us the value
of two. So using this technique, we have all
we need to manipulate the knowns now array
in the source code I will be presenting in
Part Five for the series, we will see that
I use this representation for simplicity.
All right. So now we want to know, how do
I add nodes to a binary heap and to maintain
the heap invariant, because if we I noticed
our binary tree and we don't maintain the
heap property? Well, the binary heap is useless.
We'll do some examples. On the left, I have
some instructions, which tell us what values
we need to insert into the heap. The first
value is a one, which we can see, which should
actually appear at the root, since we're dealing
with a min heap. But instead of inserting
wire the route directly, what we do is we
put one at the bottom left of the tree in
the insertion position I was talking about
and performance call bubbling up as my undergrad
prof loves to say, this is sometimes called
swimming or even sifting up all really cool
names for a really neat operation. So we answered
one and the insertion position. But now we're
in violation of the heap invariant since one
is less than seven, but one is found below
seven. So what do we do, what we do is we
swap one and seven, like so. But now we're
still in violation of the heap property, since
one is a child of six, but one is less than
six. So what do we do we swap them, but yet
again, violation the property. So we swap,
and now one is at the root where it should
be. And now the heap invariant to satisfy
and we can stop swimming or bubbling up or
whatever you want to call it. So the next
one is 13. So as usual, begin by putting it
in the insertion position. And now, we need
to satisfy the heap invariant, so bubble up
13. Notice that we're no longer in violation
of the heap property since 14 is less than
13, and 13 is less than 12. So 13 is actually
in its correct position. Sometimes we don't
have to bubble up our elements that much.
The next values we need to insert are for
zero and 10. Try seeing where these end up,
pause the video if you need. It's a good little
exercise. But I will keep going for now. So
forgoes in the insertion spot left of all
the nodes, it's there, and we bubble it up
until we can't anymore. And we start with
the property is satisfied. Next zero, my favorite
number. Of course, I've arranged that zero
be at the top of the tree as you will see
right now in violation of the heap invariant.
So let us bubble up and like magic zeros at
the top of the tree. Next is insert 10. Next
numbers 10. So we put out an insertion position.
And however this does not violate the heap
invariant, so we do nothing.
Today we're going to look at how to remove
elements from a binary heap. This is Part
Four or five in the priority queue series.
Make sure you watch the last video so we understand
the underlying structure of the binary heap.
So let's get started.
In general, with heaps we always want to remove
the root value because it's the node of interest.
It's the one of the highest priority is the
smallest or the largest value when we remove
Route, we call it polling, a special thing
about removing the route that we don't need
to search for its index. Because in an array
implementation, it has position, or index
zero. So when I say pull in red, we have the
node we want to remove, and in purple is the
one we're going to swap it with. So the note
in purple is always going to be the one at
the end of our array, which we also have its
index. So we swapped them, we get rid of the
one. And now, since 10 is at the top, well,
we're not satisfying the heap invariant. So
we need to make sure that the heap invariant
is satisfied. So we need to do what's called
bubbling down now instead of bubbling up.
So what we do is we look at 10s, children,
five and one, and we select the smallest,
and we swap with the smallest. So 10 would
go to one. So make sure you default, selecting
the left node in case there was a tie. So
as you can see, 1010s children are two and
two, they're both equal. So we're going to
select the left node to break tight. And now
we bubble down 10 again. And now the heap
invariant is satisfied. Now we want to remove
the value 12. So pulling was removing the
element at the root. But 12 is not at the
root. However, we still want to be able to
remove 12. So what we do is we have to search
for 12 in our tree, even though we don't know
its position yet. So we start at one, and
we do a linear scan through all our elements
until we find 12. So five is not 12, two is
not 12, and so on until find 12. And now we
found 12. And now we know where its position
is. So we can mark it as the node we want
to remove, and also swap it with the purple
node being the last node in our tree, swap
them remove the 12. And now we're in violation
of the heap invariant. So now we want to bubble
up three, until the heap invariant is satisfied.
And now we've satisfied the heap invariant
so we can start. Now we want to remove three,
same thing as last time search for three in
the tree. Three wasn't far it was just two
nodes away. So now to remove an element, again,
swap it with the last node in the tree. Drop
it. But now the question is, do we bubble
up or bubble down the value because you don't
really know what the value of the node and
last position is when you're swapping it in.
So this is we bubble up a bubble down Well,
we already satisfy that heap invariant from
above. So we need to bubble down 15. So So
five was smaller, so we swapped it with five,
now eight are smaller, so we swap it with
eight. And again, the heap invariants are
satisfied. Now we want to pull So Mark, the
root node, red swap it, remove the one. And
now we want to buckle down. And the heap invariant
is satisfied. Now we want to remove six. So
search for six in our tree.
Okay, we have found six and do the swap. Remove
six. Now do we bubble up a bubble down? The
answer is neither the heap invariant is already
satisfied. So we don't need to touch our node.
We got lucky. So from all this polling and
removing we can conclude the following that
polling takes logarithmic time since we're
removing the root and we already know where
to find it. And also that removing a random
node can take up to linear time. So We have
to actually find the index of that node we
want to remove before removing it. However,
if you're as dissatisfied with this linear
removal as I am, you'd figure out that there
has to be a better way. And indeed there is.
And I'm about to show you a hack to improve
this complexity to be logarithmic in the general
case. So stay tuned. Okay, so now we're looking
at how to remove nodes on my heap with the
improved time complexity. To do this, we'll
need to make use of a hash table, a data structure
I have not yet covered. So buckle up, things
are about to get a little wild. I promise
I'll cover the hash table thoroughly in a
later video. But right now, it's going to
look like magic. Back to the central issue,
we have a bunch of nodes scatter across our
heap at some positions, and instead of doing
a linear scan to find out where the node we
want to remove is, we just want to be able
to do a lookup and figure that out. The way
we're going to do this is that every node
is going to be mapped to the indexes found
that. So when we want to remove a particular
node, just look up its index and started doing
it. Linear scan. Sounds good, right? That
sounds great, except for one caveat. What
about if the heap has multiple nodes with
the same value? What problems will that cause?
Well, just a few but nothing we can't handle.
To begin with, let's talk about how we can
deal with the multiple value problem. Instead
of mapping one value to one position, we will
map one value to multiple positions. And we
can do this by maintaining a set or tree set
of indices for which a particular node value
or key if you want maps to. So can I example.
Okay, so observe the blue heap remark that
has repeated values. Namely, we can see that
the two is there, three times seven is there
twice, 11 and 13. Once the low I have drawn
the index tree, a tree, which can help us
determine the index position of a node in
the tree 11, for example, is that index 313
at index five, and the first to index zero.
On the left is the hash table. With the key
value pairs. Notice that two is found in three
positions 02, and six, while seven is found
two positions, one and four, and so on. So
this is how we're going to keep track of the
positions of the values in the tree. If notes
start moving in the tree, we also need to
keep track of that. For example, if a bubble
up or a bubble down cursory to track all those
movements, and where the swabs go to so we
can update the index position in our map,
we swap 13. And the last seven, for example,
the following should happen. So we look at
where seven and 13 are in our table. And then
I've mapped those respective positions as
red for the seven and yellow for the 13. And
this is what happens when we do a swap, we
do a swap in the tree but also in the table.
And that's it. Okay, so this all sounds great.
We keep track of repeated values by maintaining
a set of indices apart to the node, the particular
value was found out. But now let's ask a further
question. If we want to remove a repeated
node in our heap, which node do we remove
and doesn't matter? Because if we look in
our heap right here, there's three possible
two values we can remove doesn't matter which
one we remove.
The answer is no, it does not matter. As long
as in the end, we satisfy the heap invariant
and that's the most important thing. So let's
look at an example. Not just for removing
but also of adding and pulling elements with
this new scheme I just proposed. It's not
that hard, trust me. So first one, we want
to insert three. Sweet place three at the
bottom of the heap in the insertion position.
We also need To track where the new node is,
so we add three to our table long with its
position, which happens to be at index seven.
Look at the index, tree and grade confirm
this. Now that three is has been inserted,
we need to make sure the heap invariant satisfied,
currently it is not. So what we do is we bubble
up three, the parent of three is 11, which
is greater than three, so we need to swap
those two notes, I have highlighted the seven
and the index three because it maps to three
in the heap and three in the index three,
because it maps to the value 11. Now swap
those both in the tree and in the table. Awesome.
Now the heap variants still not satisfied.
So do a similar thing. For the note above,
we grab the parent and do a swap in the tree
on the table. And now the bat invariants are
satisfied. So three has been inserted successfully.
The next instruction is to remove to from
the heap. So which tool should we remove?
Well, as I said, it doesn't matter as long
as we satisfy the heap invariant in the end.
If we remove the last two, we can immediately
satisfy the heap invariant with one swamp.
But for learning purposes, I will simply remove
the first one found in our set, which happens
to be located at index zero. So we want to
remove the two at position zero. So how do
we remove a note again, so we did a look up.
So we didn't have to do that linear scan,
which was nice. And now we swap it with the
end, the last node, which happens to be 11,
we remove the last node. Now we need to satisfy
the heap invariant. So we need to bubble down
11. So we look at 11 children, which happens
to be three and two, two is smaller. So it's
the one we're going to swap with. So swap
it in the table and, and the tree. Now, we
are still not in satisfaction of the human
variant. So look at 11th children being 13
into two smaller, so swap it with two. And
that's it, we're done. The last instruction
says the poll, so we get the value of the
route, just two and swap it with 11. Get rid
of the two and bubble down 11. So as you can
see, we're constantly updating our table and
but still doing the same operations. This
is part five of five and the priority queue
series. And we're going to have a look at
some source code for the priority queue today.
So if you want the source code, here's the
GitHub link. With all the data structures
in the series, the priority queue is one of
them. Also make sure you've watched parts
124, so you can actually understand what's
going on. Alright, let's dive into the code.
Alright, here we are inside the source code.
So notice that inside my priority queue, the
types of elements I'm allowing inside my priority
queue have to be comparable elements as we
talked about. So if they implement the comparable
interface, then we are going to allow them
inside our queue. So this is anything like
strings, integers, anything with a comparable
interface. So let's have a look at some of
the instance variables. So I have the heap
size. So this is the number of elements currently
inside the heap. But then I also have another
instance variable, which is the heat capacity.
So this is going to be the size of the list.
That we have four elements which may be larger
than the heap size is. And this is the actual
heap. And we're going to be maintaining it
as a dynamic list of elements using Java's
list.
Next, for our logging of and removals, I'm
also going to keep track of this map as you
want to map an element to a tree set of integers.
So these won't be all the positions inside
our heap, which we can find this element T.
All right. Next, I've got a few different
constructors for our priority queue. We can
just Create a brighter queue. And by default,
I'm creating and initially empty priority
queue with a capacity of one. But I also allow
you to create a priority queue with a defined
initial capacity, which actually is more useful,
because then we don't have to keep expanding
our dynamic list every time. So I would recommend
this. But also, even better, is if you know
all the elements that are going to be inside
your heap, you can actually construct the
priority queue in linear time, using an operation
called heapify, which I didn't talk about
in the slides. But both can be very, very
useful. So So this just has all the usual
setup stuff. Here, I'm adding all the elements
to the math and but also to the heap. And
then here's the heapify process. So we start
at halfway through the heap size, and then
we start decreasing, and then we sync all
the elements. And you're like, Wait a second,
isn't the seek sink? a logarithmic removal?
Well, yes, it is in the general case, but
not if we're doing it in this fashion. I put
a link to this paper appear just because the
heapify operation isn't quite intuitive why
it has this linear complexity. And if you
look at the analysis in the paper, you will
end up seeing that the complexity boils down
to a convergent series. And that's why we
constantly say it's linear time. But in general,
this isn't what you might be tempted to do.
If you're given a collection of elements,
you would initialize the heap, and then you
would just use our add method to add the elements
one at a time. And this will give you an N
log N bound. But definitely use the heapify
whenever possible. Okay, now some pretty simple
methods we have is empty, just returns true
or false if the heap is empty or not, then
clear. So when we clear the heap, we remove
all the elements inside our heap array, but
also inside our map. So that's why he called
map dotclear. Size returns a size, it's pretty
simple. peek, the first really useful method
just looks at the top of our primary priority
queue. And if it's empty returns No. Otherwise,
we do a look up at the first index inside
our heap and return it because it's the root
node
poll.
Similar to pique, except that we're going
to remove, remove the very first element.
And we're also going to return it because
you want that information. x contains. So
because we have a map with our elements, we
can do a map lookup to see if our elements
inside heap. And this reduces our complexity
from linear, in which case, we have to scan
through a linear scan through all elements
to check containment to constant time, which
is remarkable. But you have a job in case
people don't usually maintain this map. I
just wanted to do it. Just to show you guys
that is possible. Although the map does add
a lot of constant overhead and you may or
may not want. I personally find that the overhead
is quite a lot. And I usually don't really
remove things very frequently for maps. So
it might not be entirely worth it. But it's
up to you. If you're doing as many additions
as you are removals then definitely worth
it. Alright, now let's have a look at the
Add method. So, so this element, sorry, this
method adds an element to the prayer queue.
And that element cannot be no. So what we
do is, first we check if our heap size is
less than capacity. Otherwise we have to expand
our capacity of the heap. Next, we make sure
we add it to the map. So we keep track of
it. And then we swim it up. Remember that
we have to swim. I know Rob because we add
it to the very end of our list. And so we
had to, like adjust where it goes inside our
heap by swimming upwards. This next method
called less is is a helper method, which helps
me check if node i is less than or equal to
node j. And this uses the fact that both elements
node one and node two are comparable. So we
can invoke the Compare to method. If we go
back up that comes from this interface, the
comparable interface, which we needed. So,
let's go back down. Alright, so returns true
if i is less than or equal to J. Awesome.
So next, this is the bottom up notes. So we
are going to try to swim node k. So first,
who grabbed the parent of node k, we can do
that by solving for the parent. So remember
that I'm working in. I'm starting at zero,
some people like to start the heaps index,
that one, I like everything's zero based.
So I get the parent, which is that this position
k minus one divided by two, because we're
going upwards. And while K is still greater
than zero, so we're not at the root, and we're
less than our parent, then we want to swim
upwards. So we're going to swap the nodes
parent and K. And then K is when we can become
the new parent. And then we have to get the
parent of K once more. And then we'll keep
doing this going up our heap and swapping
notes. So that's how you do the swim. So the
sink is similar, but a little different. So
top down node sink. And here, we want to sync
node k. And what we do is I grab the left
node, but I also grab the right node. Remember,
we're working zero based, so plus one plus
two instead of a plus zero plus one. And then
I need to figure out, which is less either
is going to be the left one or the right one.
And I assumed to start with that the left
one is going to be smaller than the right
one. And here I correct that hypothesis, in
case it was false. So I checked that the right
notice within the size of the heap. And if
the right node is less than the left node,
then the smallest ones are going to be the
right node.
And our stopping condition is that we are
outside the bounds of the tree, or we can't
sink any more. And we can do a similar thing,
we swap and then case the next smallest here
like like we did in the last method also.
So the swap method, I made a an explicit method
to swap because I also have to swap things
inside the map and then set the values also.
And this is really what adds a lot of overhead
for the math is the fact that every time we
call the swap method, we also have to swap
things inside the map, which, which can be
a lot of overhead really, it technically maps
our constant lookup times but the fact that
you're doing all this internal hashing and
collisions and whatnot, it can get costly.
So remove. So if the element is now returned
false, we know we don't have any no elements
inside our heap. So this is how you would
do a linear removal and linear time, I commented
out in case you want to revert back and remove
the map and whatnot, is with scan through
all the elements. And once you find the element
you were looking for, just remove it at that
index and return true. Otherwise, we're going
to use our map. So get the index so wherever
the element one of the elements are. And if
it exists, then remove it at that index. Okay,
now let's have a look at the Remove add method.
So this is what I covered in the last video.
So if our heap is empty, well, can't really
remove anything. Otherwise, we're going to
swap the index Why remove with the last element,
which is going to be at heap size. And then
we're going to kill off that node and also
remove it from our map. So if it so happened
that I was equal to the heap size, meaning
we just removed the very last element in our
heap, just remove, return the removed data.
Otherwise, when we did the swap, we have to
either sink that node up or down. And I'm
caring too lazy to check whether I need to
sink or swim. So I just tried both. So first
I try sinking and then if nothing happened,
then I try swimming downwards. And in either
case, return the Remove data. Perfect. So
this just readjusts where, where the swap
node position goes, either bubble up or bubble
down. This method is just a method I use in
my testing framework to make sure everything
is good. So it checks essentially the integrity
of the minimum heap. So initially, you call
this method with K equals zero, and that starts
at the root as you want to recursively go
down the tree and check are we maintaining
the heap invariant property which we need.
So our basis, you want to be that k is outside
the heap size. And if so, we're just going
to return true. Otherwise, get our children
left and right. And now, we're going to make
sure that k is less than both our children.
And if that's not the case, return false.
And if we ever returned false, because we
have an and statement when we're recursing,
right here, that
that gets propagated throughout the recursion,
and this whole method will return false. Otherwise,
if everything returns true and hits the base
case, then we know for sure it's in the minimum
heap. Okay, these last few methods are just
map helper methods. So things to add things
into the map, things, how to remove elements
from the map, and so on. And what I'm doing
here, as I'm using a tree set to add and remove
elements, because I know the tree set implementation,
Java has a Balanced Binary Search Tree. So
all operations on tree sets are logarithmic,
which is really nice. So you guys can have
a look at those in more detail. It just gets
values removes values. And lastly, do a map
swap. So yeah, it swaps values in the heap,
or in the map rather. So yes, have a look
at those in more detail. But I pretty much
covered everything about the priority queue.
All right, time to talk about the union find
also sometimes called the disjoint set, this
is my favorite data structure. So let's get
started. So an outline of things we'll be
covering about the union fight. First, I'll
be going over a motivating example, magnets.
Just to illustrate how useful the union find
be. Then we'll go over a classic example of
an algorithm which uses the union find specifically
crucibles a minimum spanning tree algorithm,
which is very elegant, and you'll see why
it needs the union find to get the complexity
it has. Then we're going to go into some detail
concerning the find in the Union operations,
the two core operations, the union find users.
And finally, we'll have a look at path compression.
What gives us the really nice amortized constant
time the unifying provides? Ok, let's dive
into some discussion examples concerning the
union find. So what what is the union fine.
So, the unifier is a data structure that tracks
elements which are split into one or more
disjoint sets. And the union find has two
primary operations. Find an union. A word
find does is given an element, the union find
will tell you what group that element belongs
to and you Onion merges two groups together.
So if we have this example with magnets, suppose
all these gray rectangles you see on the screen
are magnets. And also suppose that the magnets
have a very high attraction to each other,
meaning they want to merge together to form
some sort of configuration. So, if I label
all the magnets and give them numbers, and
we start merging, the magnets have the highest
attraction, first, we're going to merge six
and eight together since the closest. So in
our union find, we would say union six, and
eight. And when we do a lookup on to find
out which groups six and eight belong to,
they will belong to the blue group. Now, perhaps
two, three, and three and four are highly
attracted to each other, so they would form
a group. So they would form the yellow group.
And perhaps 10 1314, would also form a group.
And this keeps on going, and we unify magnets
into groups. And perhaps we merge some magnets
onto already existing groups. So we unify
grey magnets, which is just a magnet in its
own group, and add to an already existing
group. But also we can unify groups of Magnus,
which are different colors, and we assign
it an arbitrary color. So blue, so suddenly,
everything in the yellow group went into the
blue group. And now when we would do a lookup
in our union find to determine which group
say two, three or four. Now we'd say you're
in the blue group, and the union fine, does
all this merging and finding in a very efficient
manner, which is why it's so handy to have
around.
Now explaining currently how that works. We'll
get into that in the later video. This is
just a motivating example. So where are other
places that the union find is used? Well,
we will. Well, we see the unifying again in
carousels, minimum spanning tree algorithm.
In another problem called grid percolation,
where there's a bunch of dots on a grid, and
we're trying to see if there's a path from
the bottom of the grid to the top of the grid,
or vice versa, then the union find lets us
do that efficiently by merging together paths.
Also, similar kind of problem in network activity
are two vertices in the graph connected to
each other through a series of edges. And
also perhaps in some more advanced examples,
like the least common ancestor in a tree,
and also image processing. So what kind of
complexity can we attribute to the union fight?
The complexity is excellent. So it's construction
is linear time, which isn't actually bad at
all, then the union find getcomponent. And
check if connected operations all happened
in what's called amortized constant time.
So almost constant time, although not quite
constant time. And finally, count components
where we can determine how many components
are in our magnetic examples, how many different
groups of nine that's we have. And we can
do that in constant time, which is really,
really great. Okay, let's talk about a really
neat application of the Union find, which
is crew skills, minimum spanning tree algorithm.
So you might be asking yourself, what is a
minimum spanning tree? So if we're given some
graph with some vertices and some edges, the
minimum spanning tree is a subset of the edges
which connects to all the vertices and does
so at a minimal cost. So, if this is our graph,
with some edges and vertices, then a possible
minimum spanning tree is the following and
has edge weight 14 or total edge weight 14.
Note that the minimum spanning tree is not
necessarily unique. So if there is another
minimum spanning tree, it will also have a
total weight of 14. So how does it work? So
we can break it up into three steps essentially.
So the Step is easy. Just take our edges and
sort them by ascending edge edge weight. Next
thing we want to do is we want to walk through
the sorted edges and compare the two nodes
that the edge belongs to. And if the nodes
already belong to the same group, then we
want to ignore it because it will create a
cycle in our minimum spanning tree, which
we don't want. Otherwise, we want to unify
the, the two groups those nodes belong to.
And keep going. I will keep doing this process
until either we run out of edges, or all the
vertices have been unified into one big group.
And you'll soon see what I mean by a group,
which is when our union find the structure
is going to come into play. So if this is
our graph, then to run crystals algorithm
on it, first, let's scale the edges and sort
them. So on the left side, you see I have
all the edges and their edge weights sort
in ascending order. So next, we're gonna start
processing the edges one at a time, started
starting with the top, so I two J. So I've
highlighted the edge, it Jane, orange. And
you can see that a connects nodes, i and j,
i and j currently don't belong to any group.
So I'm going to unify them together into group,
orange. Next is edge eight, he, so he don't
belong to any group. So I'm going to unify
them together into group purple. Next is CGI.
So I belongs to group, orange. But see doesn't
have a group yet. So see can go into group
orange. All right, E to F, F doesn't belong
to a group. So F can go to group purple.
Next, H and G, knee, neither age nor g belong
to a group. So I'm going to say you guys belong
to the red group. And next we have the Ruby.
They also don't belong to a group. So give
them their own group, let's say group green.
Alright, and now, I believe this is when things
get interesting. Now, we're trying to connect
C to J. But notice that C and j are a both
belong to group orange. So we don't want to
include that edge, because it's going to create
a cycle, so ignore it. And to check that they
belong to the same group, we would use the
find operation in our union fine to check
what group they belong to. So this one, the
unifying really comes into play. Next is edge
did he So know that he belongs to purple,
and D belongs to group green. So now we want
to merge them together because they don't
belong to the same group. So either the purple
groups wanted to become the green group, the
green groups and the purple group. And it
doesn't really matter, so that we would merge
them. And this is when the union operation
in our union find becomes useful. It allows
us to merge groups of colors together very
efficiently. And that's the important note.
Next edge would be d, h, h belongs to group
red, and the purple. So merge the groups together,
let's say they both become group purple. Next
up, we want to add edge, add, but add already
belong to the same group. So that would create
a cycle. So we don't want to include that
edge. So skip. next rounds include edge BTC
BTC belong to different groups. So merge the
two groups into one larger group. So we have
found the minimum spanning tree using crystals
minimum spanning tree algorithm. Pretty neat,
right? So the underlying data structure, which
allows us to do this is the union find it
allows us to merge groups of colors together
efficiently, but also to find out which groups
nodes belong to so that we don't create a
cycle. So so that's crystals algorithm. It's
super simple. Given that you know how the
union find works. So I'm going to go into
some detail in next video, explaining how
the Find and the union operations work internally,
and how We can actually implement it in some
useful way. Okay, so now we're going to talk
about the union and find operations we can
do on the union find, or the disjoint. Set.
This is the video where I demystify how those
actually work internally. So to create our
union find, the first thing we're going to
do is we're going to construct a by ejection,
or simply a mapping between our objects and
the integers in the range zero inclusive to
N non inclusive, assuming we have n elements.
So this step in general is actually not necessary.
But it's going to allow us to create an array
based unit find, which is very efficient,
and also very easy to work with. So if we
have some random objects, and we want to assign
a mapping to them, then we can do so arbitrarily,
as long as each element maps to exactly one
number. So that is my random by ejection.
And we want to store these mappings perhaps
in the hash table, so we can do a lookup on
them and determine what everything is mapped
to. Next, we're going to construct an array.
And each index is going to have an associated
object. And this is possible through our mapping.
So for instance, in the last slide, a was
mapped to five, so slot five, or index five
is going to be a slot.
So what you see in this picture is at the
top is that array we just created, which contains
our mapping. And in the center is just a visual
representation of what's going on. The value
in the array for each position is currently
the index, which it is at. This is because
originally, every node is a root node, meaning
it maps to itself. But as we perform the instructions
on the left of unifying groups together, or
objects together into groups, we're going
to find that we're going to change the values
in our array to map to other letters. And
specifically, the way we're going to do it
is first some index i, in our array, index
eyes parent is going to be whatever index
is at position I. So for instance, if we want
to unify C and K, we look at C and K. And
we discover that C has a root node of four,
and K as of nine. So either C's won't come
case parent, or K is going to see its parent.
And I chose that case parent is going to be
seat. So now at index nine, which is case
position, I'm going to put a four, because
I know that C is a four. So next, F and E
are going to do a similar type of thing. And
I'm going to say that f is going to F parent
is going to be E. So at F position, which
is one I'm going to put a zero because he
is zero. Similar thing for a and J. But here's
where things get a bit more interesting. So
now we want to unify A and B. So if I look
ay ay has a six in itself, but six is J. So
I know that A's root node for group greens
j and B is a single node because it's a self
loop. And in general, I'm going to merge smaller
components into the larger ones. So now, bees
are point to J, because the green groups root
node was J. So I write mode C and D. So I
find the root node of D which is the and find
the root note of C which is C and I'm going
to merge the smartcompany into the into the
larger component, which is the orange group.
Now these want to be part of the orange group.
Now I want to merge D and I. So similar thing
happens. And I now points that C. Now, I want
to merge L and F. So F's parent is E. So I'm
going to merge L and B into the red group.
Now I want to merge C and A. So this is an
interesting example. So I find a C's root
node, which happens to be C, I find a root
node which is J. Now, component, orange has
four elements, big component, green only has
three. So I'm going to merge the green component
into the orange component. So now j is going
to point to C. So I want to unify A and B.
So I do. So if I go up and follow the parent
nodes until I reach a root node, as parents
as Jay Jays, parents see, so I know that a
belongs to the orange group. And if I do a
similar thing with B, I also discovered that
B's parent is also C, which is the orange
group. So I don't need to unify them, they're
already unified together. So H and J, G, they
currently don't have a group, so I'm going
to arbitrarily merge them into a new group.
So it'd be the blue group. So H and F. So
if I look, h is parent ID, G, and s parent
is he
the right component is larger, so I'm going
to merge the blue group into it. And now since
g was the root node, I make it point to E,
which was also the root node. Now I want to
merge H and B. So H is root node is E, if
we follow up the chain from H to G, D, and
B's root node is C, because we go from B to
J to C. So now since the orange component
is larger than the red component, we're going
to point the root of the red component to
the root of the orange component. So he now
points to see. Okay, and note that in this
example, I'm not using a technique called
path compression. This is something we're
going to look at in the next video, which
is an optimization on the union find. To summarize,
if we want to find out which component a particular
element maps to, what we have to do is find
the root of that component by following all
the parent nodes until we reach self loop
or a node whose parent is itself and that
will uniquely determine which component that
element belongs to. And to unify two components
together, what we do is we find the root nodes
of each component. And then if the root nodes
are different, because if they're the same,
then they belong to the same component already.
So if they're different, make one of the root
nodes point to the become the parent of the
other room. So just some remarks about this
union find data structure. So in general,
we don't really aren't union elements. Just
because this would be inefficient as we'd
have to update other children which point
to that note, we don't have access to those.
But we could probably in theory, keep track
of that. I just don't see any application
currently. But there there might be also remarked
that the number of components in our union
find is going to be equal to the number of
root nodes remaining. Because each root node
is responsible for a component and also remark
that the number of root nodes never increases,
that always decreases because all we do is
unify components, so components only get bigger
and bigger and bigger. Now we want to talk
about the complexity of the Union find. So
I said in the first video that the US plane
has an amortized time complexity. However,
the implementation of this show you does not
have an amortized time complexity. Not yet
Not without the path compression, which is
something we're going to look at in the next
video, which is what makes the human fine
an absolute beast of it. structure, you must
watch the next video. But just as an example,
if we need to check, if H and B belong to
the same group or a different group, it's
going to take five hops in the worst case,
and while potentially much more, so H, we
find the root node, which is C, and then we
go from B, and then find the root node is
also C. So this takes quite a few hops. Let's
talk about path compression. Now, this operation
is really what makes the union find one of
the most remarkable data structures, because
it's how the union find gets to boast in its
efficiency. So let's dive right in. But before
we get started, it's critical that you watch
the last video so that you understand how
the find in the Union operation work. Otherwise,
you want to understand what's going on and
what's up with path compression, and how we're
going to get that really nice, amortized constant
time.
Alright, suppose we have this hypothetical
union find, I say hypothetical, because with
path compression, I'm almost certain it's
impossible to achieve a data structure, or
a structure that looks like this. Nonetheless,
it's a good example. So now suppose we want
to unify nodes, E and L. Or just unify groups,
orange, and blue, but we have access to E
and L. And that's what we're calling the unify
operation on? Well, we would have two pointers
that start on E and L. And where we would
want to do is find the root node of e and
find the root node of L, and then get one
of them to point to the other. But with path
compression, we do that, but we're also going
to do something else. So let's start by finding
the parent note of E. So E's parent is D,
and D is C, C to B, and B, A, and then eight
F. So we found the root node of E. But with
path compression, here's what we're going
to do. Now that we have a reference to the
root node, we're going to make e point to
the root node. And similarly DS are important
to the root node and C and B, and a. So now
everything along the path got compressed,
and now points to that root node. And in doing
so, at every time we do a lookup, on either
A, B, C, D, or E in constant time, we will
be able to find out what the parent or the
root node is for that component. Because we
immediately point to it, we don't have to
traverse a sequence of other nodes. And we
can do this because in a union find, we're
always unifying things together and making
them more and more compressed. We're never
unusual unifying things, if you will. So if
we do the same thing for L, we find LS parent.
So we traverse up all the parents until we
find the root. And then we compress the path.
So j points to G, I points to G, H points
to G. And so we compress that path. But we
also have found the parents now. So make one
point to the other. And we've unified both
groups. So now the group that was once with
E, and once with l have now been merged into
one single group. But the only difference
is we've compressed along the way as we've
done this, and now it's so much more efficient.
Now let's have a look at another example.
And this one, I want to compare and contrast,
the regular union find operations where we're
doing the last video to the last compression
version, we now know. So if I run all those
union instructions, this is what happened.
So it's the beginning all these pairs of components,
and then executing the instructions on the
right. And this is the final state of our
union find and know that if I'm trying to
determine what groups say a and j or n, then
I have to traverse a whole bunch of different
nodes. So j goes, I use h h goes to eat. But
now if I include path compression, let's see
what happens. So I still have all those components.
But now I as I execute the instruction on
the right hand side, this is what happens.
So I get the green group. But then, because
of path compression, that j merged into the
H, so already that path is a little shorter.
And then I keep executing more instructions.
But as I'm doing it, the path gets compressed
dynamically. So so I'm getting more and more
compression. And even up to the very end.
So on the last example, we haven't even finish
all the instructions, and we have reached
the final state. But with path compression,
as long as there's something compressed along
our path, we get to compress the path along
the way, pointing it to the root. So right
now, we only have one, root, B, E, and
almost everything in constant time, points
to E. So we do a lookup on any of our nodes.
And we know that the route is easy. So we
know the last component. And this structure
becomes very stable eventually, because of
this path compression. This is why the union
find with path compression is so efficient.
Let's have a look at some of the Union find
source code. So here's the link to the source
code. And you can find it on my GitHub repository
github.com slash William fees, slash data
structures. I also have a bunch of other data
structures from past videos. And before we
dive into the code, and make sure you watch
the other videos pertaining to the union find,
as I will be making some references to them.
Okay, let's dig in. Here we are inside the
code. And I have a class called union find
and see a few instance variables. So let's
go over them. The first is size, just how
many elements we have in our union find. There
are at least two arrays, one called ID and
one called size. So the interest, while the
more interesting was ID, and idea eyes, that
array I talked about which at index i points
to the parent node of AI. And if Id add AI
is equal to AI, then we know that AI is a
root node. So we're essentially keeping track
of all these like tree like structures right
inside an array, which is practical. And also
because we create a by ejection between our
elements. And some numbers, this is how we're
able to access them through this ID array.
And just for convenience, I track the number
of components, that's sometimes some useful
information you might want. So if you create
a union find, well, you need to know how many
elements are going to be inside your union
find. And I make sure that we have a positive
number of elements, otherwise I throw an exception.
Now go ahead and initialize some instance
variables. And I initialize ID to equal i.
So initially, everyone is a root node, and
every component has a size of one. So find
is pretty simple. It's given a a node, it
finds which component it belongs to, and also
does path compression along the way. So if
we're at p and want to find the root node
of P, what we're going to do is we're going
to find the root node using this one while
loop. So we initialize a new variable called
root to P. And then we loop until the root
is not equal to ID at root. So aka This is
a root node or a self loop that we found and
so we can stop and the root is stored in the
variable called root. And then what we do
is we do the path compression. This is what
I talked about in the last video. So starting
back at p, we assign everything from idmp
to equal the root and this is what compresses
the path gives us that nice amortized time
complexity, you can also do this recursively.
But I don't like having the overhead and doing
things iteratively you can be slightly faster.
Okay, so now, we have these simple methods,
we can call. So if p and q are inside the
same component, this will return true, because
the root P and the root q will be equal. Otherwise,
this will return false. And just calling find
will do path compression. So even if we're
just checking if two components are connected,
and it calls the find method, and we're compressing
the path, same thing here, if we decide to
find the component size, relative to some
index p, then when we index into the size
and call find, we'll find Well, we'll find
the root but at the same time, we'll also
do path compression, which is nice.
And I would just like to note that the the
root nodes are the ones who will always contain
the size because they're the ones that are
found, well, she won't think about it like
at the end of the chain. Size just returns
a number of components and our you can find
disjoint, set components number components
is pretty self explanatory. And the unifying
method is the last interesting method. So
this is the one that will unifies two components
together. So so first of all we do is we find
what the root node for P is and what the root
node for Q is. And if the root nodes are equal,
then they're already in the same group, and
we don't do anything. Otherwise, by convention,
I just merge the smaller group into the larger
group. Although I know some people like to
keep the theoretical largest path in a component,
and then merge according to not and that may
be slightly more efficient, but it's more
work. So I just like to merge the smaller
group into the larger group. And also, since
the roots are different, and we're emerging,
we know that the number of components or sets
must have decreased by one. So that's why
at the bottom here, I, I say the number of
components, subtract that by one, because
we know we're gonna have one less component.
So this whole time, inside this class, I've
been treating being q as integers and not
as elements, like letters that I that we saw
in our in the slides. And this is because
by ejection, I would do a lookup to find out
what maps to the element P and that should
give me an integer, and what maps to the element
queue. And then I could use those with this
union find data structure created, and turn
everything into the realm of numbers instead
of dealing with objects and having all this
more complexity, it's much easier to have
an array based union find. You could also
have a pointer based union find with node
objects. But this is really nice, and it's
a really clean implementation. All right,
I want to start talking about a very exciting
topic, and that is trees. And you'll soon
start to realize that there are tons and tons
and tons of tree data structures. But today
I want to focus on a very popular country
and that is binary trees. And with binary
trees, we must talk about binary search trees
as well. So today's tutorial is going to focus
on binary trees and binary search trees where
they're used and what they are. And then later
tutorials, we're going to cover how to insert
nodes into binary search trees remove nodes,
and also do some of the more popular tree
traversals which can apply to other general
trees. Also, not just binary trees. Okay.
So I'm going to give you guys a quick crash
course on trees before we get started. So
we say a tree is an undirected graph, which
can satisfy either of the following definitions,
there are actually multiple definitions, but
these are the most popular ones. So trees
non directed graph, which is connected and
a cyclic, a cyclic means there are no cycles.
Another definition is we have n nodes, but
we have n minus one edges. And lastly, for
any two vertices, there's only one path between
those two vertices, you can have two different
paths, they would imply that we don't have
a tree because there's another route to get
to another node. And so we'd have a cycle.
Okay, and context is trees, we can have something
called a rooted tree, which is the topmost
node of our tree, you can think of it that
way. And if you're trying to route the tree,
and you don't have a route yet, it doesn't
matter which node you pick, to route the tree,
because any node you pick can become the root
node, think of it as picking up the tree by
that node. And suddenly, it's the new root.
We have something called are the concept of
child and parent nodes. So child node is a
node that extends from another node. Think
of it as going down or it's an A parent node
is the inverse of this. So you're going up
towards the root. So we have an interesting
question, and that is, what is the parent
of the root node? The answer is that the root
node has no parent, although sometimes it
may be useful to say that the parent of the
root node is itself. And we see this often
when programming, for instance, a file system,
tree has this property. So if I open up the
command line, I'm in some directory, so I
can say pwd at the current directory. So I'm
somewhere in the file system tree. And if
I want to go up to my parent, I can say CD
dot dot slash, and now I'm up in another directory,
or in to the parent directory. And I can keep
doing this and going up and up in the file
system tree directory system. But if I go
directly to the root node, which is slash,
I see that I'm in the folder slash, so the
very top at the root of the directory, and
I say CD dot, dot, then, if I check out where
I am, I'm again at the root. So in this context,
for a file system, the parent of the root
is the root. Pretty cool. So just as an example,
if we pick the node zero, and has two children,
three and two and a parent four, we also have
the concept of something called a leaf node,
this a node which has no children, and these
have been highlighted in orange. So they're
just at the very bottom of your tree. Think
of it that way. And there's also another term,
which is sub tree, this is the tree entirely
contained within an under tree. And we usually
use triangles to denote sub trees. It's possible
for a sub tree to consist of only a single
node, so that's fine. So if this so tree with
that circle node being the root, and we pick
particular sub tree and look what's inside
of it, then we get another tree, which contains
nodes and more sub trees. Then we pick another
sub tree, look with inside of it, and then
we get another tree. And eventually, we're
going to hit the bottom. So now we can pose
the question, what is a binary tree? And this
is this simple. This is a tree in which every
node has at most, two children. So both those
trees below are binary trees, because they
have at most two children. You can see that
the tree on the right, eight has one child,
and that's fine, because the criteria is at
most two. Now we're going to play a game.
I'm going to give you some various structures,
and you're going to have to guess whether
it is a binary tree or not. So is this a binary
tree? Yes. Yes, it is every node has at most
two children. How about this one? No, you
can see that seven has three children. So
it's not a binary tree. How about this one?
let you guys think about it a bit more.
Yes, this is a binary tree. It may be a degenerate
one, but it's still a binary tree. Alright,
let's move on to binary search trees. So what
is a binary search tree? Well, first of all,
it's a binary tree. But Furthermore, it also
satisfies what's called the binary search
tree invariant. And that is that the less
left subtree has smaller elements than the
value of the current node. And the right subtree
has larger elements than that of the current
node. So below are a few binary search trees.
We're going to play the same type of game,
and I'm going to give you some trees, and
you're going to have to guess whether they're
binary search trees or not. What about this
structure? And this one, we could say it depends
on whether you want to allow duplicate values
inside your tree. It so happens that binary
search tree operations allow for duplicate
values. There's nothing wrong with that. But
most of the time, we're only interested in
having unique values inside our tree. So this
particular tree depends on what your definition
of a binary search tree is. How about this?
tree? Yes, this is a binary search tree. How
about this tree? Notice I've only changed
the elements within the tree. Yes, this is
also a binary search tree. We're not limited
to only having numbers within our binary search
tree, we can place any type of data which
is comparable and can be ordered. How about
this tree? No, this is not a binary search
tree. And the reason is the the node nine
is in the wrong position. When we would be
inserting nine, we would have to place it
in the right subtree of eight because nine
is larger than eight so belongs in its right
subtree. How about this structure? This structure
isn't even a tree actually, because it contains
a cycle. And the requirement to be a binary
search tree is that you must be a tree. And
this last one, I'm going to give you a bit
more time to look at this one. Because it's
not a regular type of structure you might
think of as a binary search tree. And the
answer is yes, this structure does satisfy
the binary search tree invariant that every
right subtree contains larger elements. You
will you'll see that that is true. And also
every left subtree that contains smaller elements.
It doesn't look like a tree, but it satisfies
our definitions of a tree and a binary search
tree. Okay, so we've been talking about binary
trees, binary search trees, where are they
used? Why are they useful? So in particular,
binary search trees are used in many implementations
of abstract data types for sets, and maps
and so on. They're also used to implement
balanced binary search trees, which we'll
probably get to in a later video. Can you
see binary search, or sorry, binary trees
in binary heaps? We've already seen this in
priority queues when we're making a binary
heap. But we also see binary trees and things
like syntax trees, so you're parsing an arithmetic
expression, then you place it in an abstract
syntax tree. And then you can simplify expression.
compilers and calculators use this to evaluate
expressions. So wherever you punch in your
calculator gets person to binary tree and
evaluated. And lastly, I just threw in a trip,
which is another type of probabilistic data
structure. So now let's look at the complexity
of these binary search trees because they
looked very interesting and also very useful.
And indeed they are. So in the average case,
when you're just given some random data,
the time complexity is growing. Be logarithmic,
which is really good. So if you're inserting
nodes, deleting nodes, removing nodes searching
for a value tree, whatever, the average time
complexity is going to be the logarithmic.
And these binary trees, or binary search trees
are very easy to implement. So this is really
good. However, in the worst case, if your
tree and D generates to being a line, then
we can have some linear behavior going on,
which is really bad. So there's some trade
offs. If you want to use just a pure binary
search tree, that it's going to be easy to
implement. And on average, it's going to have
this logarithmic behavior. But in the worst
case, you might be looking at some linear
stuff, which is not so good. Okay, let's have
a look at how to insert some elements into
a binary search tree. So let's dive right
in. So first, to add elements to our binary
search tree, we need to make sure that the
elements we're adding are actually comparable,
meaning that we can order them in some way
inside the tree. Meaning at every step, we
know whether we need to place the element
in the left subtree or the right subtree.
And we're going to encounter essentially four
cases. So when inserting an element, we want
to compare the value to the value of the current
node we're considering to do one of the following
things. Either, we're going to recurse down
the left subtree, because our element is smaller
than the current element, or we're going to
recurse down the right subtree because our
element is greater than the current element.
Or it might be the case that the current element
has the same value as the one we're considering.
And so we need to handle duplicate values,
if we're deciding to add duplicate values
to a tree or just ignoring that. And lastly,
we have the case that we've hit a null node,
in which case it's time to create a new node
and insert it in our tree. Let's look at some
animation now. So on the left, I have a bunch
of insert instructions. So we have all these
values we want to insert into our binary search
tree. And currently the search tree or the
binary search tree is empty. So first, we
want to insert seven. So seven becomes the
root of the tree, because it's the first note.
Next, we want to insert 20. So 20 is greater
than seven, so insert it to the right. Next
we want insert five. So we always start at
the root when we're inserting, and that's
an important point. So you start at the root,
and then you move your way down the tree to
figure out where you want to insert the node.
So we start at the root, and then we're like,
oh, five is less than seven. So we're going
to insert it to the left. Now 15, so the route
go to the right, because 15 is greater than
seven, then to the left ps 15 is less than
20 at 10. Now four, so four is less than seven,
move left, four is less than five, move left,
create the new node. Now we have four again.
So let's see what happens here. So seven moved
to the left and moved to the left. Now we've
encountered a value that already exists in
our tree. So as I said before, if your tree
supports duplicate values, now's the time
to add another node. And you would either
pick by convention if you want it on the left
or on the right. Otherwise, you'd do nothing.
And I'm going to choose to do nothing. Insert
33. So start at the root, go to the right,
because 33 is greater, go to the right again.
Now insert two, so two smaller than everything
in our tree, so it would go all the way to
the left. Now try and see where 25 would go.
So 25 simply go to the right, then we're going
to go to the right again, because it's greater
than 20. But we're going to go left now because
it's less than 33.
And finally sex so once left, once right,
and we've inserted everything into our binary
search tree. So on average, the insertion
time is going to be logarithmic. But in the
worst case, this behavior could degrade to
linear time. Let's have a look at that. So
if our instructions are the following insert
12345, and six. So we start at one, then go
and insert two sets to the right. Okay, now
let's insert three, well, three is greater
than everything. So I have to place the right
again, how about four, okay, four is also
greater than everything. Oh, looks like we're
creating this line now. And now six, six is
still greater than everything. So as you can
see, this type of linear behavior is really
bad. And we don't want to create lines like
this. Because if we want to query where six
is in the tree, or if we want to remove five,
or do anything, are buying your surgery, first
thing to find the node, that's going to take
linear time. And this is this is bad. It's
one of the reasons why people haven't invented
things like balanced binary search trees,
or self balancing trees, which balance themselves
as you insert nodes will begin to that later.
But that's it for insertion. It's really simple.
Don't overcomplicate it. Alright, now that
we know how to insert elements into a binary
search tree, we might also want to remove
elements from a binary search tree. And this
is slightly more complicated, but I'm going
to make it very simple for you guys. So when
we're moving elements around binary or substrate,
you can think of it as a two step process.
First, we have to find the element we wish
to remove within the binary search tree, if
it exists at all. And in the second stage,
we want to replace the node we're removing
with its successor, if one exists, in order
to maintain the binary search tree invariant,
let me remind you with a binary search tree
invariant is it's that the left subtree has
smaller elements than the current node and
the right subtree has larger elements than
the current node. Okay, so let's dive into
phase one the find phase. So if we're searching
for an element inside our binary search tree,
one of four things is going to happen. The
first thing is we hit a null node, meaning
we've went all the way down our binary search
tree and have not found the value we want.
So the value does not exist inside our binary
search tree. Another thing that can happen
is the competitor value is equal to zero.
And what I mean by a competitor is, it's a
function that will return minus one if it's
less than zero if it's equal to or wine if
it's greater than the current value. So it
tells us essentially, which subtree we need
to go down, or if we found value that we're
looking for. So if it's equal to zero, then
we found the value. If it's less than zero,
the value might exist. And if it does seem
to be the left subtree if I compared to returns
value greater than zero, then if the value
exists, it's going to be the right subtree.
Okay, let's have an example with some information.
So suppose we have four or five queries, find
1425 37, and 17. And that's our binary search
tree there on the right. So if we're trying
to find 14, as usual, we need to start at
the root and 14 is less than so go left. 14
is greater than 10. So go right, 14 is less
than 15. Go left. 14 is greater than 12. So
go right again. And now we have found the
value that we are looking for. Alright, and
move on to 2525 is greater than 20. Go right,
Wi Fi is less than 31. And now we found 25.
See if you can do 37 on your own. Pause the
video or something.
Okay, here's her go, go right, go right, your
left, go right. Alright, now let's have a
look at 17. So 17 should be on the left. Now
should go right. Maybe we should go right
again. And, oh, we've hit a point where we
know that 17 does not exist in our tree. So
that's another possibility the value simply
doesn't exist. Because we would go to the
Left of 90, and the left of 19 is a null node.
And null known means we haven't found the
value we're looking for. So now that we found
the value that we're looking for, we're at
the Remove phase. And in the Remove phase,
there are four cases, essentially. And the
first case is that the node we want to remove
is a leaf node, so it has no sub trees. Cases
two, and three, as I like to call them, is
there's only one subtree meaning there's a
right subtree, but no left subtree, or those
the left subtree and no, right subtree. Or
finally case for is that we have both a left
and a right subtree. So I'm going to show
you guys how to handle each of these cases,
it's really, really not that hard. So case,
one, we have a leaf node. So if you have a
leaf node and you want to remove it, then
you can do so with a side effect, which is
really nice. So suppose we have the binary
search tree on the right, and we want to remove
eight. So we do phase one, we find out where
eight is. Oh, and it is a case one, because
it's a leaf node. So we know we can remove
it without side effect. So we remove it. Perfect.
That wasn't hard. Now let's look at cases,
two and three. Meaning that either the left
or the right child is a subject. In this case,
the successor of the node we're trying to
remove is going to be the root node of that
left or right subtree. Let's look at an example.
Suppose we want to remove nine. So first,
let's find nine. Okay, we found nine. Now
we encounter a case two with a left subtree
is nine doesn't have a right subtree. So the
successor is going to be the root node of
that left subtree. So seven. So now I can
remove nine, and seven becomes the successor
of nine. Perfect. Now let's do another example
where we want to remove four. So first, let's
find four. So we find four. And this is our
other case where we only have a left subtree.
But no, right. subtree. So where do we do,
the successor of four is going to be the root
node of that left. subtree. So three, so we
can remove four and our three becomes the
successor. Alright, that wasn't so bad, was
it? Alright, so now for case four? Yeah, we
want to remove node which has both a left
subtree and a right. subtree now the question
is, in which subtree will the successor of
the node we're trying to remove? b?
And the answer is both the successor can either
be the largest value in the left subtree or
the smallest value in the right. subtree and
here's perhaps some justification for why
there can be two successors. So the largest
value that we can find in that left subtree
would satisfy the binary search tree invariant,
if it becomes a successor, because it would
be larger than everything in the left subtree
and this is immediate from being the largest
left subtree and also it would be smaller
than everything in the right subtree because
we had found it in the left. subtree similarly,
if we find the smallest value in the right,
subtree It would also satisfy the biosurgery
invariant for the following reason it will
be smaller than everything in the right subtree
and this is immediate from being the smallest
than the right subtree and also larger than
everything in the left subtree because it
was found in the right subtree and we know
things in the right subtree are well greater
than everything in the left subtree. So we
come to this conclusion that well there must
be two possible successors. So we can choose
either or fantastic. So if we have this tree,
and we want to remove seven, well seven is
a case four, because it has both a left subtree
and right subtree also seven, so find seven
vireo found it. And now we get to either pick
the successor in our left subtree or our right
subtree, I'm going to find the smallest value
in the right subtree what we do is we go into
the right subtree and then we dig as far left
as possible, go left and go left again. And
now we don't have a left child, so we could
stop. And this node is going to be the successor,
it is the smallest node in the right subtree.
And you can see that quite clearly 11 is smaller
than everything in that right subtree. So
now what we want to do is, we want to copy
the value from the node we found in that right
subtree 11 into the node we want to originally
remove, which is seven. So now I replaced
seven with 11. Now we have a problem, which
is we have 11 twice in our subtree. And we
want to now remove that element 11 which is
highlighted because it is the successor it
shouldn't no longer be inside the tree. And
luckily for us, the successor node we want
to remove is always going to be either a case
one two or three removal. So in this case,
it would be the case where there's a right
subtree But no, left subtree. And you would
just do this recursively. So so just call
itself and it would hit one of those three
cases. Okay, so it's right subtree. So I want
to do is swap it with the root node of that
right subtree and then remove it. So remove
1114 becomes a successor. And now just going
to rebalance the tree like that. Alright,
now let's have a look at another case. In
this example, let's remove 14. So first, let's
find 14, if it exists within our tree,
go right. Alright, we found 14. Now we either
want to find the smallest value in the right
subtree like we did last time, or the largest
value in the left subtree. Now let's do the
ladder this time and find the largest value
in the left subtree. To do this, what we do
is we would go into the left subtree and dig
as far right as possible this time going to
the left subtree in digges far right 913.
Now 13 is the largest value in the left subtree.
And now what we want to do as before is we
want to copy the value of the successor 13
into the node we want to remove which is 14.
So now 14 becomes 13. And now we want to remove
the remaining 13. So now just remove it and
replace it with its successor. Perfect. Okay,
I just want to go over some more examples.
So just these two short examples, because
removing is not quite so obvious. Alright,
let's start with the one of the left. So let's
see if we can remove 18 from this strange
looking binary search tree. So start at the
root find a teen so dig all the way down.
Okay, we found 18. And now we want to literally
be it's one of those case two or threes. It's
the one where there's a left subtree. So the
successor is just going to be the root node
of that left subtree or 17. So remove 18 and
replace it 17. So 17 is a new successor. Perfect.
Now let's look at the other case where we
want to remove minus two. So now first find
minus two so go to the left. Okay, we find
it found it. Now there's two subtrees pick
one of the two to become to find that successor
and we're going to go to the right. Alright,
copies value in now remove one, remove minus
one. And that's it. Okay, and that is removals
in a nutshell. All right, I want to finish
off binary trees and binary search trees with
some tree traversals in particular, pre order
in order post order and level order. You see
these traversals come up now and again, so
they're good to know. I want to focus on pre
order in order and post order to begin with,
because they're very similar. They're also
naturally defined recursively. And you can
sort of get a feel for why they have their
certain names that they do. So pre order prints
before the two recursive calls, in order will
print between recursive calls, and post order
will print after the recursive calls. So if
you look at the three functions on the left,
the only thing that's different between them
is where the print statement is. So let's
move on to some detail on how preorder works.
So on the right, I'm going to maintain a call
stack of what gets called. So when we're recursing
backup, we know what caused us to know what
node to go to. And what you need to know about
pre order is that we print the value of the
current node and then we traverse the left
subtree followed by the right subtree. So
for order where we're going to do is insert
a, print A, and then we go left, or B, and
we go down to D, go down to H. And now we
recurse back up, so we push node h off the
call stack and go to D and then we go to I
and then we explore AI. Now we're at the bottom,
so we recurse back up, so we push AI off the
call stack. We've already processed D
and
go back to B we also are a process B but now
we have to do B's right subtree. So we go
and explore II. Now we've explored ease. So
push frame off the stack explored B push that
off the stack. And now a now we need to explore
the right subtree of a. So we would print
C then F then j and then right at the bottom,
so recurse and then level K and our bottoms
are recursive push node k off the stack, push
node f off the stack, and now explore node
C's right subtree. So g now l and now we're
done. We curse all the way back up and we
would exit our function. And at the bottom,
you can see what the pre order traversal is.
Okay, now let's cover inorder traversal. So,
how inorder traversal works as we traverse
the left subtree that we print the value.
And then we traverse the right subtree. And
for this example, I'm going to be using a
binary search tree and not just a generic
binary tree. And you'll see something interesting
happens. We push node 11 on stack because
it's our route. Then we go left, then we go
left again and go left again. And notice as
I was going left, I would push those on to
the stack but I'm not printing the value yet
because when I call in order, the very first
instruction in the in order is to go left.
I only print once I've traversed the entire
left subtree if I'm a leaf node, like I am
now one is a leaf node, then I've already
explored the left subtree if you will, so
I can print the current value. Then I recurse
and then I print three because I've explored
threes left subtree now we go right now and
I've explored both sub trees I can print five
recurse. Now I can print six because I've
explored six is left subtree I can go to eight
then recurse then print 11. Now we need to
finish elevens are right subtree. So go Right,
left, go left may explore 12 recurs and we're
going to print 13, then go down to 14, print
14. Also, because 14 has no sub trees up.
So push 14 out the stack, push 13 out of the
stack, print 15, because we will explode 15th
left subtree go Right. Right. And now, the
last thing we need to do is finish our function
by just pushing everything off the stack.
So go back up. And now, did you notice something
interesting happened when we did our inorder
traversal? Well, what happened was we printed
the values of the nodes in increasing order,
which is why it's called an inorder traversal.
If you do it on a binary search tree, it prints
the values in increasing order, which is really
neat. That's quite a nice property of the
inorder traversal. Now, let's look at the
post order traversal. And the post order traversal
says, okay, traverse the left subtree, then
traverse the right subtree. And after you're
done doing both of those, only then print
the value of the node. So this means if you
look at our tree right now, the last value
we're going to print should be 11. Because
we need to process a lemon's entire left subtree
elevens, entire right subtree.
So let's start at 11 and explore its left
subtree. So go all the way down, then print
one, because we've explored both its left
and right subtree. Don't print three because
we haven't explored its right subtree yet,
print five, because we've explored both sub
trees which don't exist. Now we can print
three because we've explored both of its sub
trees. And then similarly, they go down to
eight, print eight recurse. And print six,
don't print 11, because we still need to do
it's right subtree, go 15 1312, print 12.
Go up to 13, print 14, go back up to 13. And
now we can print it. Don't print 15 yet, because
we haven't explored all of its right subtree
and go to 1719 and then pop everything off
the stack and print on the way back up. And
you can see that Levin is indeed the last
node we have visited. And that's pre order
in order and post order a nutshell. Now want
to look at level order traversal, which is
special, it's quite a bit different from the
other two, a level order traversal is we want
to print the nodes one layer at a time. So
start with 11. They want to print six and
15, then three 813 17 and one 512 14 and 19.
And you're like oh, how am I going to do that.
And the way we're going to obtain this ordering
is by doing something called a breadth first
search from the root node all the way down
to the leaf node. So she knows what a breadth
first search is, from graph theory. And this
the same thing, a tree is a type of graph,
it's no different. So what we're going to
do to do our breadth first search is we're
going to meet in a queue of the nodes we have
left to explore. And how it's going to work
is our queue is originally going to contain
only the root node. And we're going to keep
processing, I pulling out the first value
in our queue until our queue is over. A bit
more detail on that. So here you can see the
queue. On the right, I've inserted node 11.
And so I would pull out note 11. And I would
add elevens left child and right child to
the queue. So they would go at the end of
the queue. And I've also removed 11. So so
the next notes process would be six followed
by 15. And then I would keep adding children
to the queue so that I reach them eventually.
So let's have a look. So I've pulled 11 from
the queue. Now added six and 15 to the queue.
Now the next thing on the top of the queue
is six, so it removes six and add six as children
three and eight the queue, then 15. Next up,
add 15 children which are 13 and 17 to the
queue, and next up in the queues three. So
I would add threes children to the queue,
and then move on, explore eight, eight has
no children, so I can't add them. Next 13.
As you can see that as I'm exploring nodes,
I just add the children but keep pulling the
most recent thing in the queue. And this gives
us the level order traversal that we want.
And this is how you do a breadth first search
in general. So not too complicated, except
we had to use that special trick of using
a queue instead of using a stack. So we don't
do level order traversals recursively, we
need to do them iteratively with a queue.
Okay, finally time to look at some source
code for binary search tree.
So the source
code I'm about to show you can be found at
the following link. The link should also be
in the description at the bottom of this video,
please like the repository so that other people
can also find it more easily. And now let's
dive in. All right, here we are inside the
source code for the binary search tree. The
source code is written in Java. Okay, so first
thing you will notice is I have a class representing
a binary search tree. And it takes as a type
anything that is comparable, we need things
that are comparable, so we know how to insert
them accordingly within the binary search
tree. So to start us off, I have a few instance
variables, actually only two, in fact, one
to keep track of the number of nodes in the
binary search tree, and another one, which
is the root of this binary search tree because
this binary search tree is a rooted tree.
Next, I have a private node class, which contains
a left node and a right node, as well as some
data of type T and that type T comes from
here. So it's some comparable type T. Okay,
next I have a method to check if our binary
search tree is empty. It simply checks if
the size is zero. And size simply returns
the node count, which gets either incremented
or decremented as we add or remove elements.
Okay, here's the public method to add elements
to this binary search tree. I also have a
private method down here, as you will notice.
And I use the private methods to do the recursive
business and the public method to just check
if the element is already contained within
the binary search tree. This insertion method
will return true if we successfully insert
a new element into the binary search tree
and it will return false if there's already
something inside the binary search tree. So
elements have to be unique inside this binary
search tree, okay, so supposing this branch
doesn't get executed, meaning the element
does not already exist in the tree, then we're
looking at this branch. And I'm saying okay,
add this new element to the binary search
tree recursively and also up the node count
by one and return true because well, this
element doesn't yet exists. So let's look
at the recursive method now. So our base case
is that we found the null leaf we want to
insert our element at so we will create a
new node object with two null children. But
with the value of the element, we want insert
Otherwise, we're in this branch. And we choose
which sub tree we want to place our element
inside. So either it's going to be the left
subtree of the first branch, or the right
subtree. The second branch. Okay, now let's
look at removing. So here's the public method
for removing. Now, I'm only going to remove
the method if it exists within the tree. So
I check if it's within the tree before, otherwise,
it is going to return false, meaning we have
not removed anything from this binary search
string. And if it is contained, I'm also going
to decrement the node count. Now let's look
at this recursive method to remove the node.
So this recursive method simply has a normal
base case, it's now returned now. And in the
first step to removing a node, we first have
to find it. And we know it exists. Because
of this check, we know that our element is
within the tree so we can remove it. And that
is these two cases. So this is like the find
Phase I was talking about in the later video.
So I get a comparative value, and I check
if it's less than, so we're going in the left
subtree, or we're going inside the right subtree.
It's going to be one of these two cases, otherwise,
we found the node we want to remove. So this
finds the node. And here's where we do the
actual removal. So I talked about four cases
in my slides. But in fact, you can think of
it more or less as three cases even two cases,
because two the cases are very similar. So
the singleton case, where there's only one
node, it's really that that can also be thought
of as a left subtree right subtree case, this
case is the case where the left subtree is
no but the right subtree is not. And this
case, the right subtree is now but the left
subtree isn't. And this case down here, which
I'll get to later, we have both subsidiaries.
So let's go to the very top. So if we only
have a right subtree, then I'm going to say
that the successor node is just going to be
the root node of that right subtree. So node
dot right. And then I return that, I also
destroy the data within this node and the
node itself. So similarly, for the other case,
where I only have a left subtree. What I'm
going to do is, I'm going to reach into that
left subtree and grab the root node. And I'm
going to return that note. And I'm also going
to destroy this node because we know we don't
want it anymore. So those two cases are fairly
easy. Now let's look at the key. So we have
a left, a sorry, a left subtree and a right
subtree. So as I mentioned in my slides, we
can either find the largest node in the left
subtree, or the smallest node in the right
subtree. And here, I find the smallest node
in the right subtree. So I go down to the
right subtree. And I dig left. And this is
the node or the successor node if you will.
So we copy the data in it. And then we recurse
and call ourselves to remove the successor
node. If you wanted to find the largest value
in the left subtree then you can just uncomment
this code and it would do just that. So that's
removing a nutshell and they also had these
two helper methods to do a dig left and a
dig right. Moving on, I also have this method
that checks
contains an element. So given an element return
true or false, depending on if that element
is within this binary subtree. And this is
very simple. This is equivalent to the fine
phase, if we reach a null node, we would definitely
know that that element doesn't exist, otherwise
get our comparative value, which is either
going to be less than if we need to go to
the left subtree, meaning this case, or greater
than zero, we need to go and right subtree.
Or if we found the element, then that's zero
case. And we're in this case. So pretty simple.
Just as a bonus, I also threw in a height
function. So this will calculate the height
of the tree, it will do so in linear time,
height, we'll call the private recursive height
method. And all this does is it's fairly simple.
So if we reach a leaf node, we're going to
return zero. Otherwise, we're going to return
the maximum height of the left subtree or
the right subtree. Because one of our sub
trees might be greater than the other, and
that's going to be the one that we want the
height from. When every time we recurse, we
add plus one. So this corresponds to a depth.
So the biggest depth is going to be whatever
the height of the tree is, you want to go
that way. And now for our traversals, I have
created this method called traverse. And what
it does is it takes a a tree traversal order,
which is an enamel type, I'm going to show
you in a minute. And and that's an order and
then I pick whichever order you give me and
I return an iterator for that particular order
I want to traverse. So if you tell me I want
to traverse this binary search tree in a pre
order fashion that I'm going to return you
this iterator which is this method. If you
want to traverse the tree in order for it
to return you this inorder traversal iterator.
Let's have a look at what this tree traversal
order is. Let me open that up right here.
So that is simply an e&m type you can see
right here. So it's either one of these four
things, it's pre order in order post order.
So nothing too crazy. And I decided to do
these traversals iteratively. So that you
don't have to do them recursively, which would
be slightly slower, and perhaps less convenient,
this is more flexible. Although I don't really
want to dive into the code because it is fairly
nasty. If I just open up, say the inorder
traversal, then it does look pretty gross,
I have to maintain a stack manually. And I
have to check for concurrent modification
errors, etc, etc, etc. These are actually
great interview questions like how do i do
an inorder traversal iteratively? Or how do
I do a post order traversal, iteratively,
and so on and so on. So, so those are definitely
great to practice. If you want to actually
see what's hidden inside these methods, just
go on the GitHub repository and have a look.
But I, I showed you guys how to do treat reversals
in the last slides. So you should be good
to do that. Most of the time we do it recursively.
Anyways, I just want to be a bit more fancy
and go all out intuitively. So this is about
it for the binary search tree.
Today we're going to be talking about hash
tables, one of the most remarkable data structures
of all times, if I had a subtitle, it would
be one data structure to rule them all. So
let's get started. There's going to be a lot
of things to cover and the hash table series.
We're gonna start off with with a hash table
and what the heck is a hash function, and
why do we need one. Then we're going to talk
about some popular collision resolution methods.
In particular, separate chaining, open addressing
those are the two most popular ones, although
there's a ton more, there, we're going to
a separate chaining with linked lists. This
is a really popular implementation. And there's
a ton of stuff and open address in any state
covered. So we're going to be talking about
linear probing, and quadratic probing how
that's done. I'm not even giving lots and
lots of examples for those just because it's
not super obvious how they work. And to finish
off for me going over double hashing, and
finally removing elements from the open addressing
scheme, because that's not so obvious, either.
All right. So to begin with, what is a hash
table.
So the hash table is
a data structure that lets us construct a
mapping from some keys to some values, via
a technique called hashing, which we'll talk
about shortly. So the key could be any value,
as long as it's unique, which maps to a value.
So for instance, keys could be names to people
names, and the value could be someone's favorite
color. So William's favorite color is green.
Mike is this purple, Katherine's is yellow,
and so on. And we call these key value pairs,
so each key is associated with the value.
So all the keys have to be unique, the values
don't have to be unique. For example, Micah's
favorite color is purple, but also Leah's
favorite color is purple. We often use hash
tables to track at frequencies. For example,
Below is a frequency table of the number of
times a certain word appeared in Shakespeare's
Hamlet, which I Parson obtained this table.
So you can see Hamlet appeared 114 times the
word, Lord 223. But the word cabbage did not
appear. So hash tables are often used as do
track frequencies, which is really handy.
But you can really construct a mapping between
any key value pairs given that the keys are
hashable. This is something we're talking
about shortly. So to be able to understand
how we construct the mapping within the hash
table, we need to understand what a hash function
is. So simply put a hash function, which I
will denote from now on as h of x, for some
key x is a function that map's X to a whole
number in some fixed range. So that's pretty
simple. Let's have a look at an arbitrary
hash function. So if our hash function is
h of x equals some polynomial, x squared minus
6x, plus nine modulo 10, well, all integer
keys get mapped to the range zero to nine
inclusive. No matter what integer number I
plug into h of x. So below, I'm plugging in
certain values, or keys fuel into the hash
function and getting an output. So notice
that the output is not unique. In that there
could be two values that are plugged into
the hash function which yield the same value,
for instance, h four and H have to map to
the same thing, and that's completely fine.
So we can also define arbitrary hash functions,
not just on integers, but on arbitrary objects,
which makes this really powerful. For instance,
suppose we have a string s, and we're gonna
say H of s be the hash function that I ever
defined below. So this hash function, all
it does is it sums the ASCII values of the
characters within the string, and then at
the end, says, module 50. So that will for
any given string just output a number. And
that's a hash function. So, for example, some
simple inputs, so h of BB gets 66, or 66.
And then we mined that by 50. So we have 32.
The empty string gets zero because we don't
even execute the loop and so on. So we've
effectively converted a string to a number.
Great. Alright, here's a mini challenge for
you. Suppose we have a database of people
below. And each person has three fields. They
have an age, a name and a sex. I want you
to define a hash function h of a person We're
going to be given a person object as an argument.
And I want you to create a hash function that's
going to map a person to the set of values,
zero through five inclusive, you can pause
the video, just create any hash function that
does this given the three fields. Alright,
so here's my attempt at creating such a hash
function. Turns out, there's an infinite amount
of possible hash functions we could define
for the hash of the person.
And here's a simple one. So I'm gonna say,
Okay, first, let's start with the age. So
whatever there is, that's the starting value
hash, then I'm going to add on the length
of the person's name, again, an arbitrary
choice, I'm going to increment by one if they're
males, and then mod by six. So as you can
see, hash functions are a bit arbitrarily
defined. At this point, we're going to get
into some more sophisticated hash functions
later. So this particular hash function yields
those values. Alright, something very important,
very, very important that we need to talk
about our properties of hash functions. So
if we have a hash function, and two objects,
say x and y, and their hash values are equal,
then those two objects might be equal. We
don't know for sure. We have to explicitly
check x against y. Yes, the hash function
tells us that there was a collision right
there. But if the hash functions are not equal,
that x and y are certainly not equal. Here's
a good question. How can we use this to our
advantage to speed up object comparisons?
The answer is that instead of comparing X
and Y directly if we've already computed their
hash values, and first let's compare the hash
values of x and y, instead of comparing X
and Y explicitly, and in this next example,
you'll see why that's important. Consider
the problem of trying to determine if two
very large files have the same contents. This
is something you want to do in an operating
system context all the time. So if we've computed
the hash values for file one and file two,
first, we should compare the hash values together
to see if they match or don't match, because
this requires constant time work, which is
super fast. So if possible, we don't want
to open the files at all this would be comparing
X and Y directly or file one against file
two, but we will have to compare them byte
per byte if their hash values are equal. So
actually, hash functions for files are much
more sophisticated than those that we use
for hash tables. Instead, we use very sophisticated
hashing algorithms called cryptographic hash
functions and checksums. Alright, another
property of hash functions is that they must
absolutely be deterministic. This means that
if h of x produces a y, then h of x must always,
always always produce y and never another
value. This is super critical, because this
will screw up our hash table completely If
this happens, we do not want this. So an example
of a non deterministic hash function is something
that introduces say, a global variable or
some kind of randomness, you don't want that.
So in this particular hash function, the first
time I run it, the hash value for five is
six. But then if I call it again, we've incremented
the counter and now the hash values seven.
Oh, not good. Something else but hash functions
is we try very hard to make them uniform.
To minimize the number of hash collisions,
we'll get into why hash collisions are bad
shortly. But a hash collision is when two
objects X and Y hash to the same value that
is h of x equals h of y. And the reason why
to be uniform, so that all the values of our
hash function are hit, so that we can fill
the table uniformly. So for example, the Table
Table we generated earlier, William and key
they have a hash collision. Okay, so now we're
able to answer a central question about the
types of keys that we're allowed to put in
our hash table. So what makes a key of type
t hashable? Here's the answer. Since we're
going to implement our hash table using these
hash functions, we need those hash functions
to be deterministic.
And to enforce that behavior, you'll see a
lot of programming languages in force that
the keys you use, be immutable, meaning you
can't change them. They're fixed. They're
constants. So they're things like immutable
strings, integers, but not things like sets
or lists or things you can add or remove things
from, they're immutable. And if we have that
condition, and we have a hash function that
is defined for all keys of type t, then we
say that, that that type is hashable. Okay.
Alright, so now let's get into the interesting
details. How does the hash table work? Well,
ideally, we want our hash function to have
really quick insertion look up, and the removal
times. And, remarkably, we can achieve all
that using the hash function as a way to index
into a hash table. And a hash table is just
a fancy word for an array. Think of it like
that every time I say hash table think array.
So again, we use the hash function as a way
to index into the hash table. So the hash
function gives us an index to go look up inside
a table. And yes, we can do this in constant
time. Given that we have a uniform hash function,
super essential. Okay, think of the hash table
on the right as an indexable block of memory.
So as I said, an array, we can access these
entries with the hash function, h of x. So
suppose we're going to be inserting integer
string key value pairs into the table that
are going to represent rankings of users to
their usernames, say in an online programming
competition. And this is the arbitrary hash
function, I chose x squared plus three, Montana.
Alright, let's get started. So if I want to
insert the key value pair, three by eater,
so in the contest, the user whose username
is by eater got a rank of three, and we want
to insert that into the hash table, then what
we do is we hash the key, which is three,
and we get h of three being three squared
plus three montagner. Two, so in our hash
table, or array, index two, we're going to
put the key B three, and the value to be byte
either. Alright? Now, this next user will
say, which is usually what I call myself an
online programming competitions, he is rank
one. And if we hash one, then we get four.
So at index four,
then we're going to put the key in the value
for William, or will that fees. Next, if we
want to insert Lauren 425, we've got rank
32. Again, we hash 32, and we put her in the
table where she goes, then we can do the same
thing for ternary wizard has rank five. And
insert orange Knight, again began by hashing
the key finding out where it goes. So as we
keep doing this, you keep filling the table,
but eventually we're bound to have a collision.
Now, in the event that we want to do a lookup,
for a user that has a rank R, all we need
to do is compute the hash value for R and
then look inside your hash table see where
this user is. So say I want to find the user
with reign 10.
And I hash 10. Figure out its index is three
and then I get the value which is the orange
Knight has rank 10.
Great.
However, how do we handle hash collisions?
For examples, use Those who have ranks two
and eight have the same value. This is problematic.
Because we don't have another place to put
them inside our table, they would index into
the same position. Yeah. And the answer is
we use one of many hash collision resolution
techniques to handle this. There are many,
but the two most popular ones are separate
chaining and open addressing. The idea behind
separate chaining is that we deal with hash
collisions by maintaining a data structure,
usually a link lists to hold all the different
key value pairs, which hash to some particular
value. Open addressing is slightly different.
It deals with hash collisions by probing and
finding other places in the hash table offset
from the place where we originally hash to.
So an open addressing, everything is kept
inside one big array. And separate chaining,
you have multiple auxiliary data structures.
So the time complexity, the hash table is
actually pretty remarkable. In fact, it's
amazing. So on average, we can achieve constant
time insertion, removal and search. But if
you have a terrible hash function that's not
uniform, then you can get linear time, which
is really, really bad. Okay, let's talk about
something super, super cool. And that is hash
tables, and separate chaining. Alright, let's
dive right in what is separate chaining. Separate
chaining is just one of many, many hash collision
resolution techniques. And how it works is
when there's a hash collision, meaning two
keys hash of the same value, we need to have
some sort of way of handling that within our
hash table. So it's still functional. Or what
separate chaining does is it maintains an
auxilary data structure to essentially hold
all the collisions. And so we can go back
and look up inside that bucket or that data
structure of values for the item we're looking
for. And usually, we use the length list for
this. But it's not limited to only linked
lists, we can use arrays, binary trees, self
bouncing trees, or even a hybrid approach.
Okay, so suppose we have the following hash
table, it's just a fancy name for an array
of key value pairs of age and names. And we
associate an arbitrary hash value that has
been computed with some hash function. So
those are hash values, they don't really matter.
For now, we're just going to see how we can
use separate chaining to handle the collisions.
Okay, so on the left is our hash table. So
our array, and I'm going to be inserting all
of these key value pairs into this hash table
via separate chaining, and you'll see how
easy it is. Okay, so our first person is will
his ages 21 and he hashed to three. So we're
going to put in, in that slot three, Leah,
age 18, hash to four. Since she hash to four,
we're going to put her at index four. So the
hash is a way to index into the array. Okay,
rig age 61 hash two and put them there. And
re age 25 hash one. Okay, we're starting to
get a little bit full in our hash table here.
So you might get some collisions pretty soon.
Okay. Lera, age 34, hash to four, but we say
Oh, shoot, Leah is already there. What do
we do? Well, in separate chaining, we just
chain along. So essentially, each, each position
in the array is actually a linked list data
structure. So we're going to scan through
the link list and see if alera exists and
if Lera does not exist, then we're going to
add lira at the very end of the chain.
Okay,
so Ryan also hash to one but then we look
and Ryan is not equal to Ray so we need to
add a new entry at position one. alera age
34 hash to four. So Nope, an O layer already
exists. So in our hash table, so we're good.
And she says the same age, so we don't need
to update it. So fin age 21, hash to three.
So easier hash collision with will who also
hash to three. So what we're going to do is
are going to append a fin to the end of the
length list chain. So note that even though
that will and fin both hashed to the same
value, that is index three, and they have
the same age, we tell them apart, because
we store both the key and the value as an
entry in our linked list block. So that's
how we're able to tell them apart. Okay, now
I want insert mark, whose age is 10. And who
has to four. So scan through the linked list
at index for for Mark, and is not found. So
we have to append mark at the very end. All
right, now let's have a look at how we can
do lookups in this structure. So it's basically
the same thing. So we're going to do is given
a name, we want to find what the person's
age is. So suppose we have Ryan and Ryan,
when we hash him, we get one. So we suspect
that Ryan should be in bucket one. When I
say a bucket, I just mean, whatever data structure
we're using, at index one, in our case, the
link lists. So if you scan this linked list
for Ryan, so sorry, Ray, no. So here, we're
comparing the key. So we're comparing the
key Ryan to the key array. And there's not
a match. So keep going. Compare Ryan, Ryan,
there's a match. Okay, we found Ryan and then
inside in that entry, say, oh, his age is
56. So return 56. Let's do another one, find
the age of Mark hash mark. And since our hash
functions are deterministic, we know that
if there's a mark, then it's going to be found
in position four. Okay, so we look in the
bucket for scan through, oh, last one is a
mark. So returning age 10. So it might happen
that the value or the key looking forward
doesn't exist. And so it doesn't exist Your
turn now. Okay, so here's a good question.
How do we maintain a constant time insertion
and lookup time complexity? If the hash table
gets really full, and I have some long linked
list chains? Good question. And the answer
is that once there's a lot of elements within
your hash table, you'll actually want to create
a new hash table with a larger capacity and
rehash all your items and re insert them into
this new, larger table, because tables are
fixed size. Okay, and another good question,
how do I remove key value pairs from my hash
table with separate chaining? Well, the answer
is basically the same procedure, you hash
your key. And instead of doing a lookup while
you would remove a particular entry and the
length list, that's another question. How
do I use? Can I use another data structure
to model the bucket behavior? Yes, of course.
And common data structures are using several
linked lists include arrays, binary tree,
so by self balancing trees, Java uses a hybrid
approach and our hash map. So once they get
to a certain chain length, they switch to
a binary tree, or maybe a cell balance spanning
tree I'm not too sure. However, these alternative
methods are a bit more memory intensive and
complex to implement, which is why they may
be less popular, but they might be a lot faster
to hadn't actually implemented them myself.
All right, it's time to have a look at some
separate chaining source code for the hash
table. So here I am on my GitHub repository
with MCs slash data structures. And you can
find the source code here under the hash table
folder. I have multiple implementations of
the hash table. Today, we're going to be looking
at the hash table with separate chaining and
in the later videos, probably one of these
three, I haven't figured out which one yet.
So let's dive into the code. I have it here
on my computer. So let's get going. All right.
So first things first, I have two classes,
one called entry the other one just separate
chaining hash table. So let's have a look
at the entry class. First. These entries represent
individual items or key value pairs, you would
want to be inserting into the hash table.
So in Java, we have generics, so a generic
key, which has to be hashable, and some value.
So when I create an entry, I give it the key
value pairs. And I also compute the hash code.
So there's a built in method in Java to compute
the hash code for a particular object. And
you can override it to specify the hash code
for your particular object, which is really
convenient. So compute the hash code and cache
it, you absolutely want to cache it. So you
don't have to re compute this thing multiple
times, it should be cheap to compute. But
for something like a string, hash code can
take linear time to compute, which is not
good. So here, I have an equals method, which
doesn't override the object equals method
because I don't want to have to do any casting.
First, it checks if the hashes are not equal.
If the hashes are not equal, we know from
the first video that they are absolutely not
equal, so we can return false. Otherwise,
I compare the keys to each other. And that's
about it for the entry class. Very simple,
very basic. Now let's get into the meat of
thing. So the hash table itself. Okay, so
my default hash table capacities and v3, so
holds three, three items, and the load factor
by default if the user doesn't specify ones
or be 0.75. So that's the maximum capacity
I'm willing to tolerate, then I have a few
important instance variables, we need to go
over. So the maximum load factor, so once
the load factor goes above this value, then
I resize the table. So there's a capacity,
so the actual maximum number of items that
could or how big the table size is rather.
So the threshold. So this is computed to be
capacity times the max load factor, so tells
us, hey, you're above the threshold to resize
time to resize size, how many items are currently
in the table. And this is the table itself.
So it's an array of linked lists, which themselves
have entries, pretty simple. So there's a
few constructors, so you can construct a hash
table, just using the default settings with
initial capacity, or the capacity at a max
load factor. So this is a designated constructor,
let's have a look. So just save the max load
factor is compute default capacity. And make
sure you take the max of say the default capacity
and capacity just so that I know you don't
want the capacity be too low. There may be
weird things happening if the capacity is
set to one or something like that. Then calculate
threshold and then finally initialize the
table. Really simple. All right, let's have
a look at all these methods right here. So
size returns number of elements side hash
table empty, is the hash table empty. So this
is the first really interesting method. So
normalized index. And it's used when you want
to convert a hash value into an index. And
it says in the comments here, essentially,
this strips the negative sign and place the
hash value in a domain, zero to capacity.
Because the hash values are integers, they
can be anywhere in the domain of an integer,
which is about minus 32. To the 31, sorry,
to positive to the 31. around that. So what
this does is a mask, it strips off the negative
sign from the hash value, and then modified
by the capacity. So bring it into this domain,
so we can actually use it as a lookup index.
Next up is clear. So we just weren't clear
how the table that's straightforward. Contains
key and has here the same thing. So we're
going to do is compute given a key. So we
want to find out does this key exist within
the hash table. Right? So we're going to do
is compute the keys, hash, normalize it. And
then now give us the bucket index. So which
bucket should this key appear? Should it be
in a hash table? I'm just going to seek to
see if I'm going to seek the fire In the entry,
if the entry is not equal to no exists, if
it's equal to Now it doesn't exist simple
for add an insert are all common names for
just putting something into the hash table,
or updating a value inside of the hash table
two. So we don't want to allow no keys, that's
something we absolutely don't want. So just
throw an exception there. Otherwise, we're
going to create a new entry, find the bucket
it belongs to, and then insert it using this
method we'll get to. Okay, get. So given a
key, I want to find the value associated with
that key. Again, though, allow no keys. And
this will be pretty routine all the time always
don't want to find which bucket this particular
key belongs to get the bucket index. Okay,
find the entry. assuming it's not no, then
this is the entry you want every time its
value. If it is no, well, the key doesn't
exist. So return null. Okay, suppose we remove
the key now from the hash table. So he's not
no find the bucket index, and we're gonna
call his private remove entry method, which
is just down here. So given the bucket index,
so which, which bucket does this keyboard
to, what we're going to do is we're going
to seek for the entry inside the link list
structure. And if the entry is not now, then
we're going to extract the actual link list
and remove it. So this is a built in a datatype
in Java. So this removed from that link this
data structure decrement the size and return
the actual value, that's all we have to do.
Otherwise, it's not there. So return null.
So insert bucket insert entry is a given a
particular bucket, we want to place this entry
inside of it. Okay. So first, since we know
the bucket index, we can go in our table and
automatically get the linked list structure.
Check out bucket. So bucket is now well, we
have to create a new linked list. So we're
essentially lazy only allocating these linked
list data structures, which is good, because
we don't want to use more memory than we need
to. So next up, I find the entry that already
exists. So this is in case you want to do
an update, for instance. So if the existence
entry is now this means that we need to add
a new entry to the end of the blank last.
So add it to the end of the link list, increment
the size, and check if we're above the threshold,
and if so, resize the table. And yeah, use
now to indicate that there was no previous
entry otherwise need to update that entry.
So then just update the value in the existing
entry and return the value.
All right.
So seek entry this method we've been using
pretty much everywhere, it finds the returns
particular entry at a given bucket index,
if it exists, otherwise, just return now.
They probably know what's going on by now.
So extract the length list at the particular
bucket index. Otherwise return now if it doesn't
exist yet, otherwise, seek through each of
the entries in the linked list and compare
the keys to the key we're after. And if there
was a match, return that entry otherwise return
no date. Here's the last really complicated
method called resize table. So this resizes
the initial table doubling the capacity of
the table. First we double the capacity. We
recompute the new threshold because now we
have a higher threshold because we have increasing
capacity. Now create a new table with this
new capacity. So this new table is bigger
than the current table. Then go through the
current table. Look for linkless data structures
which are not know if you find one. We'll
loop through all these entries, calculate
the bucket index. Find the bucket and essentially
insert it into this new table and after that
completely remove the old data that was in
the old table at the end, set the table to
be equal to the new table. Okay. And then
these last two methods, so just return all
the keys and the values within a hash table.
fairly simple. And these last two methods
are iterators. And to string which we don't
need to go over. So that's essentially, separate
chaining and nutshell, fairly simple to implement
with the link lists much more difficult to
implement with, say, a balanced binary tree
or something like that. I'm pretty excited,
we're going to be talking about the open addressing
collision resolution technique for hash tables.
So let's get going. First, let's just do a
quick recap on hash tables so that everyone's
on the same page. So the goal of the hash
table is to construct a mapping from a set
of keys to a set of values, and the keys need
to be hashable. Now, what we do is we define
a hash function on the keys to convert them
into numbers, then we use the number obtained
through the hash function as a way to index
into the array or the hash table. However,
this isn't a foolproof method, because from
time to time, we're going to have hash collisions,
that is two keys that hash to the same value.
So we need a way to resolve this and open
addressing is a solution for that. Alright,
so what we're going to be using the open addressing
collision resolution technique, the one thing
to keep in mind is the actual key value pairs
themselves are going to be stored in the table
itself. So as opposed to say, an auxilary
data structure like in the separate chaining
method we saw in the last video. So this means
that we care a great deal about the size of
the hash tables, and how many elements are
currently in the hash table. Because once
there are too many elements inside of the
hash table, we're also going to be really
hard to find an open slot or a position to
place our elements. So just an important piece
of terminology, we say that the load factor
is the ratio between number of items in the
table and the size of the table. So this means
we need to keep tabs on the load factor.
Here's a neat chart from Wikipedia. So on
the chart, what you can see are two different
methods. One of them is chaining, that is
separate chaining, and linear probing and
open addressing technique. And we can see
from the linear probing, one is that once
it gets to a certain threshold, it gets exponentially
bad. So you don't want it to go anywhere near
that say point eight mark. In fact, we're
going to be keeping it a lot lower than that
usually. And what this says is, we always
need to keep the load factor which we denote
by the Greek letter alpha, below a certain
threshold. And we need to grow the size of
our table once that threshold is met. Right,
so when we want to insert a key value pair
into our hash table, here's what we do, we
take the key, we use our hash function defined
on our key and we hash the value and this
gives us an original position inside the hash
table for where the key should go. But suppose
there's a hash collision, and there's already
a key in that slot, well, we can't have two
keys in the same slot. That's not how arrays
work. So what we do is we use a probing sequence,
which I will define as p of x. So now on to
tell us where to go next. So we hashed to
the value, H of K, the original position.
And now we're going to probe along using this
probing function in such a way that we're
going to eventually find an open spots along
the way. So as it turns out, there are actually
an infinite amount of probing sequences to
choose from. So here are a few of them. We
have linear probing, which probes via a linear
function. So given an input parameter x, so
when we're probing we start, usually x at
zero or one and as When unable to find free
slot, then we just increment x by one. And
it works the same for all of these probing
functions. for linear probing, we use a linear
function for quadratic probing, we use a quadratic
function. And then there's double hashing,
which is super neat, actually, what we do
is we define a secondary hash function on
our key, find its value, and then use that
inside the probing function. And the last
one is the pseudo random number generator
probing function that we can use. So given
a random number generator, we're going to
seed it using the hash value of our key, which
we know is deterministic. So it's always going
to be the same thing. And then we can use
that inside our probing function, which is
pretty neat, and increment by x each time
and we know x increments by one, so we're
just getting the next number in the random
number generator, and then the next one after
that. Alright, so here's a general insertion
method for open addressing, suppose we have
a table of size n. And here's how the algorithm
goes, first, we initialize x to be one. So
x is a constant, or sorry, a variable that
we're going to use for the probing, and we're
going to increment x each time we fail to
hit a free position, then we get the key hash
just by hashing our key. And that is actually
going to be the index where we're going to
look in a table first. So while the table
index is occupied, meaning it's not equal
to No, we're going to say our new index is
the key hash, or the original position, we
hash to plus the probing function, mod n,
so that we always land back inside the table,
and then we're going to increment x, so that
the next time we run this loop, well, we probe
at a different position. And then eventually,
we're going to find a free position, we always
set up our probing function in such a way
that we will always find a probe, a sorry,
we will always find a free slot, because we
know that the load factor is being kept below
a certain amount. Alright,
so here's the big issue with open addressing.
And it's that most probing sequences that
we choose modulo n, are going to end up producing
some sort of cycle shorter than the table
size itself. So imagine your probing sequence
just hops between three different values and
cycles. And your table is of size 10. But
you're only ever able to hit three slots,
because it's stuck in a cycle. And all of
those three slots are full. Well, you're stuck
in an infinite loop. So this is very problematic,
and something we absolutely absolutely need
to handle. Right, so let's have a look at
an example. So right here, I have a hash table.
And using open addressing, it's got some key
value pairs already inserted. And assume that
the circle with a bar through it is the no
token. Further assume that we're using the
probing sequence p of x equals 4x. And suppose
we insert a new key value pair into the table
and that the key hashes to eight. So that
means we want to insert that key value pair
at position eight, but Oh, it's already occupied,
because there's key five value five already
there. So what we do well, we probe, so we
compute P of one, which is 4x. At one, so
we get eight plus for my 12. Well, that's
zero. So then we go slot zero, and we see
Oh, that is also occupied, because the key
one and value one is already there. So now
we compute P of two, and then they gives us
16 moto just for and then, oh, that cell is
already occupied, and then we keep probing.
And as you see right now we've entered a cycle.
So we'll keep probing and probing and probing,
and we always be getting back to the same
position. So although we have a proving function,
it does not work. In this particular situation.
The probing function is flawed. So that's
good. Quite concerning, because not all probing
functions are viable. They produce cycles
are shorter than the table size. How do we
handle this? And in general, the consensus
is that we don't handle this issue. Instead,
we try to avoid it all together by restricting
the domain of probing functions that we choose
to be those which produce a cycle of exactly
like n. And those probing functions do exist.
I have a little Asterix here and says there
are a few exceptions. And this is true. There
are some probing functions we can use, which
don't produce a full cycle, but still work.
And we're going to have a look at I think,
one of those in the quadratic probing video.
Alright, so just to recap, techniques such
as linear probing, and quadratic probing,
and double hashing, they're all subject to
this issue of the cycles. And what we need
to do is redefine probing functions, which
are very specific that produce a cycle of
length and to avoid not being able to insert
an element and being stuck in an infinite
loop. So this is a bit of an issue with the
open addressing scheme, but it's something
we can handle. Although notice that this isn't
something you have to worry about. If you're
in the separate chaining world, just because
we have that auxilary data structure that
just captures all our collisions. Okay, this
is going to be a fun one, we're going to be
talking about hash tables, and the linear
probing technique. To get started, let's recap
how open addressing works.
So in general, if we have a table of size
n, here's how we do open addressing, no matter
what your probing function is. So we start
our constant,
or sorry, variable x at one, the key hash
is just going to be wherever our hash function
gives us four key. And our first index we're
going to check is going to be the original
hash position. And while the table at the
index now equal to null, meaning that position
is already occupied, then we're going to offset
the index by where the key hash is plus the
probing function mode. And every time we do
this, we increment the variable x so that
our probing function pushes us along one extra
position. And then once we found a position,
then we can insert the key value pair into
the table
at that position.
Alright, so what is linear probing? So linear
probing is simply a probing method which probes
according to some linear formula, specifically,
the linear function, p of x equals mx plus
b. And we have to make sure that a is not
equal to zero, otherwise, we're just adding
a constant which does nothing. Now have a
small note right here, which says that the
constant b is obsolete. And if you know why,
post in the comments and have a discussion
with the others. And as we saw in the last
video, there's a slight problem with this
currently, and it's that some linear functions
are unable to produce a full cycle of order
n. And we might end up getting stuck in a
cycle. Here's an example of that. If we picked
our linear function to be p of x equals 3x,
and say our key k hashed to four, and for
some reason our table size was nine, then
we would end up with the following cycle occurring.
Assuming that positions, four, seven and one
are already taken by other key value pairs.
So the fact that we're only probing at those
three locations means we're unable to reach
all the other buckets, which is really bad.
And hence, we're again stuck in an infinite
loop, we cannot get stuck in this situation
ever. So how do we avoid it? So that's the
question which values of the constant A and
P of x equals x produce a full cycle modulo
M. It turns out that this happens when the
constant a and n the table size are relatively
prime to each other. The two numbers are relatively
prime, if their greatest common denominator
is equal to one So that is a an N have a GCD
of one. And when that happens, the probing
function will always be able to generate a
complete cycle. And we will always be able
to find an empty bucket. Awesome. Alright,
here's an example, with linear probing. So
suppose we have an originally empty hash table,
and we want to insert some key value pairs.
And we selected our probing function to be
p of x equals 6x. And our table size be n
equals nine. And then we also selected a max
load factor of alpha equals about two thirds,
and the threshold will then be six. So we
resize once we hit six elements. Okay, so
based on the probing function we chose at
a table size, are we likely to run into an
infinite loop while inserting? Based on what
I told you in the last few slides? And the
answer is, yes, the greatest common denominator
of nine and six is equal to three, which is
not one. So let's go ahead and attempt to
insert some elements regardless, we may or
may not hit any problems. Okay. So first,
let's insert. So I guess on the left, I have
some key value pairs, I want to insert, and
we're going to insert k one first. So suppose
that the hash value for K one is equal to
two, then we would say, Alright, the hash
of K one plus the probing sequence, add zero,
my nine is equal to two. So we're going to
insert that key value pair at position two.
Alright, next one. So now suppose k of two
is equal to two again. So we're going to try
to insert this key value pair at position
two. But oh snap, we have a hash collision.
So we're going to increment x, and now try
to offset the probing function at one and
so forming function at zero. So that is, instead
of inserting it now at two, we're going to
insert it at eight. All right, so that went
in because that slot was free. Now, let's
try inserting key three. So key three, suppose
that hashes the three, then we can insert
position three, and there's no issue.
Now, notice that we're trying to re insert
k two, which already exists within our hash
table. So instead of inserting it, we're actually
going to be updating its value because it
exists in the hash table. Alright, so from
before, we know that the hash value for K
two is two. So So then we look at position
two, and K two is not there, and it was hash
collision.
So we increment x offset by P of one. And
now we're able to find k two and now we can
update valuate there. Let's go to K five.
Okay, so suppose k five has a hash value of
eight. So eight is taken. So we're going to
probe and that leads us to index five. So
we're going to insert the key value pair there.
Now sorry, insert case six. Suppose case,
six hashes the five, then let's probe ones
now that, so five plus 699 gives us two. Okay,
a hash collision, let's keep probing. So now,
five plus 12 mod nine is equal to eight. All
right, another hash collision, so we have
to increment x and keep probing, and now we're
back to five. So we've hit a cycle. Alright,
so we're trapped in a cycle. But we kind of
expected this to happen because we knew that
we picked two numbers whose GCD was equal
to three and not one. So if we look at all
the possible AE values we could have selected
instead of six, we see that the ones that
give a greatest common denominator of one
with and the table size are 12457 and eight,
while any multiple of three would give us
something else. So this comes to the realization
that for our choice of P of x, if we choose
p of x to be one times x, then the greatest
common denominator of n, and one is always
going to be one no matter what our choice
of the table sizes, which is why p of x equals
one times x is a very popular probing function
choice. All right, now suppose we have another
hash table, and we wish in certain more key
value pairs, but this time, we're actually
going to pick a probing function that works,
so that we don't ever have any issues. So
I'm going to pick the table size to be 12
and our probing function to be 5x. So no cycle
should occur. All right, so let's go with
inserting the first guy. So suppose that k
one has a hash value of 10, then at index
10, we'd put k one v one. Suppose k two has
a hash value of eight, then slot eight is
free. So let's pop those right in there. So
now, suppose k three is equal to 10, hash
collision with K, one in there, so we need
to keep probing. Alright, so if we use our
probing function, which is p of x equals 5x.
So they'll give us three module and when we
add it to the hash value, moving on insert
k four. Now suppose the hash value for K four
is 10, then we have to keep probing. So then
we hit k three, which inserted last time.
And then oh, we also hit k two. But we're
able to pull out eventually when we hit the
third probing value, however, now notice that
we've actually reached the threshold of our
table, if I go back a few slides, we can see
that I picked alpha to be 0.35. So n, which
is the table size times alpha gave us four.
And we just finished inserting the fourth
element. So it's time that we resize the table.
So how we usually resize the table is VSM,
exponential fashion, such as doubling or tripling,
or so on. But we need to double in such a
way that the GCD of N A still holds. So after
a doubling, and is equal to 24, and the GCD
properties is still good. Alpha is a constant,
so it's still 3.5. So our new threshold is
just going to be eight and we don't change
the programming function. Alright,
so let's allocate a new chunk of memory for
this new table. And now we need to place all
the old elements in our old table into this
new table using the new table size for n,
right. So we scan across all these elements,
we start at zero and nothing there and move
along. So from before we knew that hash value
for K four was 10. So inside the new table
is going to go at position 10. Scan along
nothing here. from before, we know that k
three was 10. So it should go in position
10 in this new table, but we have a hash collision,
so we have to keep probing. So if we add our
probing function at one, which is 5x, then
we get 10 plus five, which is 15. So we're
going to insert our position 15 and the new
table, keep probing nothing here and nothing
here, nothing here. So eventually, we hit
k two. So we know from before k two is equal
to eight. So we're going to insert position
eight. Now we know k one is equal to 10. So
we're going to try and insert position 10.
that's taken so to probe so the next position
is also taken. So at five again, that gives
us 20. So insert k one v one at 20.
Alright,
so now we throw away the old table and we
keep this new table and this the new hash
table we're working with and we were at inserting
k five. Now suppose K phi is equal to two.
And that spot is free. So we are good. So
here's a frequently asked question. Sweet
I know how insertion works. Now how do I remove
key value pairs from the hash table using
open addressing? And my answer this is that
this topic is going to merit its own video.
And we're going to do it after we see all
the other open addressing techniques, because
it's actually non trivial. All right, let's
talk about hash tables and how quadratic probing
works. Let's dive right in. So let's recall
how we insert key value pairs into a table
of size and using the open addressing collision
resolution schema. So first, we initialize
a variable called x to be one, which we're
going to increment every time we're unable
to find a free slot, then we compute the key
hash. And that's going to be our first index
going to check and we're going to the loop.
While we're unable to find a free slot, meaning
the table at that index is not equal to null,
so it's already occupied. Every time that
happens, we're going to offset the key hash
using our probing function, our probing function
in our case is going to be a quadratic function.
And then we also increment x and eventually
we will find an open slot to insert our key
value pair. So what is the idea behind quadratic
probing? So quadratic probing is simply probing
according to a quadratic formula, or specifically
when our probing function looks something
like p of x equals A x squared plus bx plus
c, and a, b, and c are all constants. And
we don't want a equal to zero, otherwise,
we degrade to linear probing. But as we saw
in the previous videos, not all quadratic
functions are viable because they don't produce
a cycle of order, and we might get stuck in
an infinite loop. So as it turns out, most
randomly selected quadratic probing functions
will end up producing a cycle. Here's an example.
Suppose that we chose our probing function
to be p of x equals 2x squared plus two, the
key we wanted to insert hash two, four, and
the current table size was nine, then we would
end up with a two cycle. So first time around,
we would probe at position zero, we would
get four probe at position one, get seven,
suppose those two entries are full, and then
we would end up in a cycle again. So our probing
function is only ever able to hit the buckets,
four and seven. So it makes it impossible
to reach all the other buckets, 012356, and
eight. So we're stuck in an infinite loop
when four and seven are already occupied.
This is really, really bad. So so the question
then is, how do we pick a probing function,
which always works? The answer is there are
numerous ways. But here are the three most
popular ways I have found. So the first way
is to select the probing function to be p
of x equals x squared. And to keep the table
size a prime number greater than three, and
make sure our load factors always kept below
one half or less than or equal to one half.
The other one is to say our probing function
equals x squared plus x divided by two, and
make sure the table size is a power of two.
And the last and final one says that p of
x should be the alternating sign of x squared,
and keep the table size a prime number where
n is congruent to three mod four. For example,
we can say that I were table size was 23,
because that's a prime number as congruent
to three mod four. So any of these will work.
But as you see, they're very specific and
how they work and whether table size should
be and that's a common theme in quadratic
probing.
So we're going to focus on the second one
where p of x equals x squared plus x divided
by two and the table size is a power of two.
Alright, suppose we have an initially empty
hash table, and we want to insert some key
value pair and we're using the following quadratic
probing function, p of x equals x squared
plus x divided by two, and the table size
is a power of two, so it's eight. And that's
like the load factor to be point four, therefore,
the table threshold is going to be three.
So just to emphasize that the table size must
absolutely be a power of two, otherwise, this
will not work. Okay, so let's insert the first
guy. So suppose that k one hashes six, then
we're going to insert k one at position six.
Right, next k two, suppose k two is equal
to five, then we're going to insert it at
five, no collision there. Suppose k threes
equal to five, then we have a collision, so
need to handle that. So we're going to try
probing and offset one. So that brings us
to six. So we probe again, and that brings
us to index zero, which is free. So we're
going cert, k three, and V three key value
pairs there. Let's insert k four. Oh, but
before we can do that, we've reached the table
threshold, so we have to resize the table
first. Okay, so let's allocate a new block
of memory. And let's double the size of the
table to keep it a power of two. So our new
table size of 16 max load factor doesn't change.
However, a new threshold is six, and the probing
function doesn't change. So we need to place
the entries in the old hash table into the
new hash table. So from before, we know that
k three hashed to five, so we're going to
put it at index five, so we don't have a collision
there. And no element at position 123 or four,
then we could position five and find key two
right there. So we know from before that key
to also hash to five. So we're going to try
a preposition five, there's a hash collision,
so we probe one, and then we get five plus
one equals six, position six, or insert k
two. Now let's try insert k one. And we have
them before k one hash two, six, but we can't
put it there because we have a collision.
So we're going to probe along. So we're going
to put it in position seven. All right, and
that does it for resizing the table. So let's
keep going, we still have a few more elements
to insert inside our table. So suppose that
k four equals 35,410. So when we made that
buy 16 years, this position to, so we're going
to say k four, V four at position two. So
we've already seen k three, and we know its
hash value is equal to five. So since k three
is already in our hash table, we're going
to be performing an update. So k three person
probing functions, zero gives us five. So
let's update value to be V five instead of
v3, which it was before. So suppose that the
key k six hash to minus 6413, so that hashes
to three mod 16. So that's why it's free.
So just insert it. And the last one, case
seven suppose hashes to well, we have a collision
right there. So let's probe along. So when
we probe, our probing function gives us an
offset of one that's also taken, so probing
can so now we are at position five, but that's
also taken. So keep probing again. So we probe
for a fourth time scan offset of six. So that
gives us eight.
That slot is free. We're going to answer that
there. Alright, let's talk about hash tables
and the double hashing, open addressing collision
resolution technique. So just a quick recap,
for those of you who don't know how we do
insertions into hash tables are open addressing,
we start with a variable x initialized to
one, we compute the hash value of the key
We set that to be the first index that we're
going to check in our hash table to see if
it's not now. So the goal is to find an empty
slot. So we're going to loop while we are
still hitting spots where there are already
keys. And every time that happens, we're going
to offset our key hash using a probing function.
In our case, it's going to be the double hashing
probing function. And we're also going to
increment our value of x so that we keep probing
along further and further. Once you find a
free spot, then we can insert our key value
pair into the hash table. Okay, so what's
the deal with double hashing? So double hashing
is just a probing method like any other. But
what's special about it is that we probe according
to a constant multiple of another hash function.
So specifically, our probing function looks
something like this, we give it as input,
the key which is a constant, and the variable
x, and we compute x times h sub two of k,
where h 2k is a secondary hash function. So
here's an important note, H 2k, must hash
the same type of keys as h one, okay. So if
your key is a string, well, h two of K must
hash strings. If h one a K is hashes integers,
the nature of K must also hash integers. So
here's a note I put at the bottom that notice
that double hashing actually reduces to linear
probing, except that the constant is unknown
until runtime, because we dynamically compute
it with h two of K. So since double hashing
reduces to linear probing at runtime, we may
be stuck with the same issue we saw with linear
probing, which is that we get stuck in an
infinite cycle. So if p of x equals 3x, meaning
our secondary hash function at runtime calculate
a value of three for the constant and say,
h1 of K was four, at the table size was nine,
that we might end up with the following cycle
occurring. So the cycle produces values of
four, seven, and one, which makes it impossible
to reach any of the buckets, 02356, and eight.
So if four, seven and one are already occupied,
that means we're stuck in an infinite loop
inside our hash table. And we're not able
to insert our key value pair because we're
not able to go anywhere else. So this is an
issue we have to deal with. So to fix the
issue of cycles, with double hashing, here's
one strategy, we're going to pick our table
size to be a prime number, and we're going
to compute a value called delta. So delta
is just going to be h two of K, my dad. But
occasionally Delta might be zero. And if that's
the case, then we're going to be guaranteed
to be stuck in a cycle because we're not going
to go anywhere when we probe because we're
going to be multiplying by zero. So when this
happens, just set delta to be equal to one.
All right. So here's the justification why
this works. So notice that delta is always
going to be between one inclusive and non
inclusive. So the greatest common denominator
between delta and n is going to be one, since
n is a prime number. So therefore, with these
conditions, we know that the probing sequence
is guaranteed to have order and so we're going
to able to hit every single slot in our hash
table. So given that there's at least one
free slot in the hash table, which there will
be because we're keeping our load factor below
a certain threshold, that we're going to be
able to reach that slot.
Okay, so here's a core question, how do we
construct our secondary hash function? Suppose
the keys we're using have type T, and whenever
we use double hashing, and we need to construct
h 2k, two hash keys that are also of type
T. So it would be really nice if we had a
systematic way of generating these new hash
functions every time we need one, right? Here's
we might be dealing with multiple different
data types of type T. So luckily for us in
computer science, Almost every object we ever
create is constructed of the same fundamental
building blocks, in particular integers, strings,
real numbers, fixed length, vectors, and so
on. So we can use this to our advantage. Luckily,
there are many well known hash functions for
these fundamental data types. And we can combine
them when we want to construct our new hash
function h two of K. Frequently, when we compose
hash functions, we select them from cool hash
functions called Universal hash functions,
which generally operate on these fundamental
data types, which is quite convenient. Alright,
let's have a look at an example with double
hashing. So suppose we have an originally
empty hash table above, and we selected our
probing function to be p of x equals x squared
plus h sub 2k, which is what we needed to
be in our table size v n equals seven. Notice
that that's a prime number. And we set our
max load factor to be alpha equals point seven,
five. So our threshold to resize is five.
So once we hit five elements, we need to grow
the table size. All right, so let's insert
all these key value pairs on the left into
this hash table. So first key value pair is
keyword and v one. Now suppose that the hash
value for the first hash function of k one
is 67, and H 2k. One is 34. And first thing
we do is we compute delta. So we compute h
two of K one modulo seven, which is the table
size, and we obtain six. And then we compute
where this key value pair should go and should
go at position four. So now k two, suppose
h one of K two is two, and H, two of K two
is negative 79. So delta is five. But we're
just going to insert a position two, because
there's no collisions. So h one is k three
is two, and H 2k. Three is 10. These are just
arbitrary numbers I chose for these hash functions.
So then delta would be three in this, in this
case, because 10 mod seven is three. So we
have a hash collision, because we're trying
to insert our K three at index two, but k
two is already there. So what we need to do
is we need to probe, so we're going to compute
the position to be our original hash function
position. So h one of K three a position two
plus one times our delta value, mod seven,
that gives us five, so we're going to hop
to position five right there. Now, right,
now, let's insert k four. So suppose now that
h one of K four is equal to two, and h two
of K four is equal to seven. So let's compute
delta. So h two of K four modulo seven is
equal to zero, because seven months seven
is zero. So when this happens, we know that
we need to set delta equal to one so that
we don't get stuck in an infinite loop. So
now, each one of K four, plus zero times delta
mod seven gives us two. So we have a hash
collision at the backend for index two, so
you keep probing. So now we probed by multiplying
my delta, that gives us index three memory,
we were able to insert.
So now we're going to try insert k three,
which is already in our hash table, actually,
but with a new value. So we're going to be
performing an update this time. So suppose
h 1k three is equal to two. Actually, we should
have known that from before. And HTF k three
is 10. So compute delta. So we have a collision.
And we find k three which was already in there
and update its value. Now suppose the first
hash function for K six is three, and the
secondary hash function of k six is 23. Then
that gives us a delta value of two. So when
we try to insert it, it goes to position So
we need to probe. So we compute one times
delta mod seven, that gives us five. There's
another collisions, and then we compute the
offset at two times delta minus seven, which
gives us zero. And we find a free slot. So
we're able to insert our key value pair there.
So notice that we actually inserted five elements,
so it's time to resize and grow the table,
because we've reached the maximum threshold.
So one strategy when we're trying to resize
the table with double hashing, because we
need to keep our table size to be a prime
number is to double the table size, and then
find the next prime number above this value.
So in our case, when we double, we get 14,
and the next prime number 14 is 17. So 17
is going to be the new table size. So allocate
a new table of size 17, and go through the
elements in the old table and insert them
into the new table. So from before, a 12k,
six is three, and h two of K six is 23. We
compute delta, and we know we're going to
put it at position three, and there's no hash
collision. Next up, and nothing in position
one, position two, we have k two, so the hash
value for K to two and the secondary hash
value of k two is negative 79. from before,
to compute delta to be six. So we're going
to insert that at position two with no collision.
Next 1k four. So we know h one of K four is
two, h two of K four would be seven. So we
compute our delta value. And notice that our
delta value now is not zero, which it was
before, but seven because our mod is a 17
Delta seven. So we have a hash collision here.
But we need to keep probing. So compute the
offset at one times delta, which gives us
nine months 17. Next one, insert k one, suppose
h one of K one is two and H 2k. One is 34,
then compute delta. And that gives us zero.
So when delta is zero set to be one. So now,
h one of K one plus zero times delta gives
us two. So there's a cushion ask need keep
probing. now compute the offset at one times
delta, there's still a collision, keep incrementing,
the x value. So now two times delta t is four,
and we find a free slot so and so that key
value pair there. And the last 1k three. So
from before HR k three is two and h two of
K three is 10. Delta is then 10. And we have
a hash collision. So one times delta now gives
us 12. And that slot is free. And we reached
the end of the new table. So get rid of the
old table and replace it with a new table.
And let's finish inserting our last key value
pair from before which is k seven. Suppose
k of seven is equal to 15 and h two of K seven
is three, then our delta value is three. And
we're able to insert it at position 15. All
right, I know a lot of you have been anticipating
the Remove video for how we remove elements
from a hash table using the open addressing
scheme.
So let's have a look first at what issues
there are when we remove elements, if we do
it naively, I think this is valuable. Because
suppose though we have an originally empty
hash table, and we're using a linear probing
function, so p of x is simply going to be
equal to x. And we want to perform the following
operations we want to insert three keys, k
1k, two and K three, and then remove k two
and then get the value of k three after. And
for the sake of argument, let's assume that
we have a hash collision between K 1k two
and K three, all equal to one. This is a possible
scenario. So let's insert them. So key one
hashes to one. So we're going to insert at
position one. So let's insert k two. So it
has a hash collision with K one which is already
in the table. So we're going to linearly probe,
so insert it in the next slot over, that's
inserted k three, it also hashes to one. So
let's probe Okay, another hash collision.
So let's keep probing, and finally we insert
it in position three.
Now,
we are going to remove k two, and we're going
to use the naive removing method, where we're
just going to clear the contents of the bucket
to find k two, we hash K to get one. But k
was equal to k two. So we haven't found the
element yet. So then we probe and then we
have found k two. So we're just going to remove
it, like so. Alright, now let's query the
table and obtain the value for K three. Let's
see what happens. So when we hash k three,
we get one and K one cycles here three. So
let's continue the search. And then we have
no element. So what does this mean? So since
the value in the bucket at index two is now
we're forced to conclude that he three does
not exist within the hash table, otherwise,
we would have encountered it before reaching
the null position. That's how finding an element
works inside a hash table. So this method
is clearly flawed. The nave removing method
doesn't work. Because k three clearly exists
within hash table, we can see it there in
index three. So here's a solution to the removing.
When we remove
an element, we're going to place a unique
marker called a tombstone, instead of a no
element to indicate that a specific key value
pair has been deleted or removed. And when
we're doing a search, we're just going to
skip over the tombstones. So let's replace
the deleted bucket with a tombstone like we
should have done and see what happens when
we now search for the key k three. Okay, so
hash, three hashes to one. So k one style
equal to k three. So keep probing. Alright,
we hit a tombstone, so we know that that element
was deleted. So keep probing. All right, we
have found k three, and we can return its
value v three as our answer for the search.
Awesome. Okay. So a quick question about tombstones.
I have a lot of tombstones cluttering my hash
table, how do I get rid of them. So the thing
with tombstones is that we're actually going
to count them as filled slots in the hash
table. So they're going to increase the load
factor. And they'll all be removed when we
resize the hash table. But there's also another
way to get rid of them is that when we insert
a new key value pair, then we can replace
the buckets that have tombstones with a new
key value pair. And I want to give you guys
an example of how that is done. All right.
Suppose this is our hash table of size eight,
and we're using the quadratic probing function,
p of x equals x squared plus x divided by
two. And let's see how tombstones come into
play doing this when we want to do a lookup.
So suppose we want to insert the key k seven
inside the hash table and the hash value for
K seven is five. So we're trying to find the
key k seven. So k seven, hash to five. So
we check there first k seven cycle, the K
four. So let's keep probing. So we probe quadratically.
And we're just going to go the next slot over
and that's position six. Now, position six
is special because it's the first position
we encounter which has a tombstone in it.
So we were going to want to store this position
for later to perform an optimization. Okay,
keep probing because we haven't found a case
seven yet. So when we probe at position two,
we go to position one, still no case seven
because we have a tombstone so we have keep
going. Alright, hit and you Another tombstone.
So let's keep probing, and Aha, we have found
our key k seven. So we can return the value
v seven. Now, however, we can do an optimization,
because we don't want to probe an additional
four times to find k seven, because we just
hit a bunch of tombstones along the way. So
an optimization we can do is to relocate the
key value pair k seven v seven to the first
position where there was a tombstone. So that
next time we do a look up, it'll be much faster.
We call this lazy deletion or lazy relocation.
Alright, so we replaced the first tombstone
there with K seven v seven. And now we have
two copies of that key value pair. So we're
going to want to replace the old one with
an old token. Okay. All right, today, we're
going to be having a look at some source code
for a hash table that uses open two addresses
as a collision resolution scheme. And you
can find all the source code on GitHub at
William fiza, slash data dash structures,
and then just go to the hash table folder
to find a whole bunch of hash table implementations.
I have three different open addressing implementations
here. In particular, we are quadratic probing,
linear probing, and double hashing. They're
all very similar to each other. So I will
only be looking at one right now. But if you're
curious, you can go on GitHub and check them
out for yourself. The one that's really different,
or slightly more different is the double hashing.
But other than that, they are really essentially
the same thing. But today, I've decided that
we're going to have a look at the quadratic
probing file. So let's dive into the code.
Alright, here we are inside the code for the
hash table that uses quadratic probing. So
let's dive right in. So I have a class called
hash table quadratic probing and notice that
it takes in two generic types K and V. So
this is the key type, and this is the value
type. So you're gonna have to specify these
when you instantiate an object, which is a
hash table for quadratic probing. So I have
a bunch of instance variables that we're going
to need. The first is the load factor, this
is going to be like the maximum load factor
that we're willing to tolerate the current
capacity of our hash table, the maximum threshold,
we're willing to tolerate the modification
count, this is for the iterator.
Next, I have
two instance variables that keep track of
the total number of buckets being used. And
the key count, which tracks the number of
unique keys are currently inside the hash
table. Now, since we're doing open addressing,
we are storing these key value pairs directly
inside an array. So instead of having one
array with a wrapper class for an entry have
decided just allocate two different arrays,
one for keys, and one for values, it makes
the code a lot easier. And shorter. Actually,
this is just an instance variable we're going
to be using, or rather setting when we call
the get method. So this is the tombstone I
was talking about in the last video. This
is the marker we're going to be using for
deletions. So every time we delete an entry,
we're going to mark it with a tombstone. And
we know this tombstone object is unique. Alright,
so these are just some default constants.
So whenever you want to initialize a hash
table without any parameters, you can use
these constants. So this is a default load
factor, I set it pretty low, but you can change
it up as you like. So you can initialize it
with a default capacity. And this is the designated
constructor. So let's have a look. So the
capacity can't be negative or zero. And I
check if the user pass in some sort of a weird
load factor, because we don't want that. So
then set the max value for the load factor,
then calculate the capacity. And to ensure
that the capacity is a power of two, I need
to essentially round up the capacity. So that's
going to be with this method next to power.
Essentially it it finds the power of two.
That is just Above this current number, or
it'll also take the default capacity, which
itself is a power of two, so we don't have
to worry about that. So either way, it's going
to be a power of two, then we compute the
threshold, which is just load factor times
the capacity and initialize our tables. Alright,
so let's get rolling. So this is the quadratic
probing function I chose. So P of x, so we
give it the variable x, and then we compute
x squared plus x divided by two. So this is
a really important method, the normalize index.
So given a hash value, it essentially strips
the negative sign and mods by the capacity.
So it dumps our hash value inside the domain,
zero to the capacity non inclusive. This is
a clear method. And this is pretty self explanatory.
Just clear the contents of the cat of the
hash table and start fresh. Some helper methods
sighs get the key count and check if our hash
tables empty. And put add an insert or essentially
all the same method. So let's look at the
insert method. This inserts a key value pair
inside the hash table or updates a value if
the key already exists. All right, we don't
want to allow no keys. That happens, we throw
an exception. If the number of buckets use
is greater than or equal to the threshold
we're tolerating, we're going to resize the
table before doing anything else. Otherwise,
we want to calculate the hash value from the
key using the built in hash code method. And
you can override this for your particular
object. Okay, now I need to explain what I
Jane xR. So I is going to be the current index
or at in the hash table, because we're going
to be bouncing around this I value is going
to change a lot. And j is the position of
the first tombstone we encounter if we encounter
one, otherwise, it's minus one. And we're
going to be using this for an optimization
is an axis the probe offset, which I've set
to one, initially. Okay, so this is a do while
loop, it's a little long, but it's pretty
easy to understand.
Alright, so first, we check in the key table,
have we hit a tombstone? If we have and j
is equal to minus one, that means we haven't
hit a tombstone yet. So save where we found
this tombstone. Okay, so this next check checks
F, the key table has an entry that's not null,
meaning there's a key inside of it. So we
have to check if the key our existing hash
table. So that's what this does. It compares
the current key at index i with a key we're
trying to insert this key. And if j is equal
to minus one, meaning we haven't hit a tombstone,
then just update the value. If we've hit a
tombstone, then we want to do a swap with
the tombstone. And at the modification, count,
and always return like the old value that
was there before just just in case why use
it. Alright, next up the current cells now
so we can do an insertion. So j is equal to
minus one means that we haven't seen a tombstone
so far. So increment number of use buckets
and a key count, and then store our key value
pair. Otherwise, we have seen a tombstone
and instead of inserting where I element AI,
where the element is inserted where the deleted
token was found, so we're inserting at j instead
of AI. So here we're inserting an AI, but
stay within sorry, J with tombstone is and
we're gonna return null because there was
nothing there before. Okay, and if if we do
a loop, so we get through all these if statements
and we haven't returned, that means that we
need to keep probing we had a hash collision,
and we saw we landed on or it had something
in it. So we need to probe so we need to offset
where we first originally hash to plus the
probing index or the probe. Addition and increment
x at the same time, so this will just hop
to the next spot. And we'll do this while
we haven't found an empty slot, and we will
find an empty slot.
Alright,
so contains key and has key, just check if
a key exists within the hash table. And to
do this, I'm being pretty lazy. And I'm just
calling the get method. And I'm setting an
instance variable in there called contains
flag, which gets set to true or false whether
key is inside our hash table or not. Because
the Husky in the get method would look would
have essentially the same code. So that's
the bad code smell. Alright, so let's look
at the get method since it's getting used
in the Husky method. So Sinclair set up, find
the original hash index is equal to the hash
set j and X to what they were before. So essentially
do all the same stuff, or mostly except set
the flag, so that's different, we set the
flag to be true, when we identify that the
key is indeed inside the hash table. And here,
our else condition is just shorter, we return
if we hit a null cell, instead of inserting
a new element, and set the contains slide
to be false. Okay, so pretty easy. And the
Remove method is actually quite a bit shorter.
Interestingly. So same setup, check, the key
is now find the hash set x to be equal to
one here, we don't really care about tombstones
too much. So we don't have a j position. So
we're going to start the hash index and quadratically
probe until we find a spot. So for every loop,
we're going to increment i or find a new offset
position if this loop gets completed, so here's
what we do, we ignore tombstones, so just
skip over those. So if this happens, if the
key was not found in the hash table, we can
return now. Otherwise, the key we want to
remove is in the hash table. And we can do
this check, because we check if it's null
before, so we're not going to get a null pointer.
So decrement, the key, count up the modification
count, extract the old value, and dump a tombstone
here, and just wipe whatever value is in there.
So this is where we set this tombstones in
the Remove method, and then just return the
old value for good measure. Alright, and,
okay, these two methods are pretty self explanatory,
they just return the keys and return the values
that are contained within our hash table.
So the next really interesting method is this
resize table method. So this is this gets
called when we are inserting new elements,
I mean, to grow the table size. And remember
that in this particular quadratic probing
implementation, we always need the capacity
to be a power of two. But since we know that
the capacity is already a power of two, multiplying
by two will keep it a power of two. So that's
fine. So we compute the new threshold allocates
new memory for a new table, I call that old
table, but it's actually going to be the new
table shortly. So here, I I perform any kind
of interesting maneuver here, I swap the current
table. That is a smaller table with this new
table, which I call an old table. In order
to be able to call the insert method down
here, we'll get to that. So swap the key tables,
swapped the value tables, or reset the key
count and the bucket count. And the reason
I call it old key table was because since
the swap, well, the then the new table is
actually the current pointer for what was
the old table. That might sound confusing,
but I'm using the table we had before to do
insertions on or the pointer to it. Alright,
so loop through the old table values. And
if we encounter a token or a pointer that's
not know and not a tombstone, then we will
inserted.
So because we're avoiding reinserting tombstones,
we're getting rid of all the tombstones. So
even though our table might have been cluttered
with tombstones, we're just getting rid of
all of them here. Alright, so that's that
the iterator, you can probably have a look
at this yourself. It's just looping through
all the keys and returning them one at a time.
That's a pretty standard to string method.
So that's how you do quadratic probing with
open addressing. Today, I want to talk about
the Fenwick tree, also sometimes called the
binary index tree, and you'll see why very
soon. This is one of my personal favorites,
because it's such a powerful data structure.
And it boosts efficiency. And it's really,
really simple to code. So let's dive right
in. So things my covering the family tree,
video series, and just some standard stuff.
So go over some motivation, why this data
structure exists, analyze the time complexity,
and then go into some implementation details.
So in this video, we'll get to the range query,
and later videos, how to do point updates
and how to construct the Fenwick tree in linear
time. You can also do things like range updates,
but I'm not going to be covering that in this
series. At least not yet. Okay, so what is
the motivation behind the Fenwick tree. So
suppose we have an array of integer values,
and we want to query a range and find the
sum of that range? Well, one thing we can
do would be to start at the position and scan
up to where we want to stop, and then sum
all the individual values between that range.
And that's fine, we can do this. However,
it'll soon get pretty slow, because we're
doing linear queries, which is really bad.
However, if we do something like compute all
the prefix sums for the array, then we can
do queries in constant time, which is really,
really good. So if we set the array p, index
zero to be zero, and then we go in our array
and add that element to the current prefix
sum, we get five and then five, plus or minus
three, give us two, and then six plus two
is eight, and so on. So this is an elementary
form of dynamic programming right here, calculating
out prefix sums. And then if we want to find
the sum, from say, two to seven non inclusive,
then we can get the difference between those
two indices in the PRA. And that's a constant
time thing to compute. The sum of the values
between two and seven are inclusive. So that's
really great. However, there's a slight flaw
in this, which is what happens when we want
to update a value in our original array A,
say, we want to update index four, to be three.
Well, now we have to recompute all the prefix
sums. So this is really bad, because it can
recalculate all those prefix sums. And to
get to linear time. This is why the February
Chu was essentially created. So what is the
fennel trees, the family tree is a data structure
that supports range queries on arrays and
also point updates. Also range queries, but
we won't be covering that in this video. So
it's construction is linear time. Point out
dates are logarithmic. range, some queries
also logarithmic range updates logarithmic,
but you can't say add elements to the array
can't make the array bigger or entirely remove
elements. Okay,
so let's look at how we can do range queries
on this thing. First thing you need to know
is that unlike a regular array, a family tree,
each cell is not responsible for itself but
rather for a range of other cells as well.
So we're going to say that a cell is responsible
for other cells depending on what The value
of its least significant bit is its binary
representation. So on the left, I have a one
based array. Fenwick trees are one base. That's
very important. And I, on the side of that,
I also put the binary representation of each
of the numbers, you can clearly see what they
look like in binary. So if we have, say, the
index 12, its binary representation is 1100.
So the least significant jet is that left
most bit. So that is at position three, and
the binary representation, so that index is
responsible for we're going to say two to
the power of the position minus one, so four
cells below itself. Similarly, 10, has a binary
representation of 1010. And the least the
least significant bit is that position two.
So it's responsible for two cells below itself.
And 11 has this thing fit in there position
one, so solely responsible for oneself, itself.
So here, I've outlined the lease Sydney, leasing
nificant bits, I think, really hard to say,
for all the odd numbers, which are just responsible
for themselves. So that's what the blue bar
indicates, the blue bars don't represent value,
they represent a range of responsibility.
And that's really important for you to keep
in mind. So now, all the cells which have
arranged responsibility to now the cells have
a range of sponsibility to four minutes that
all these ranges of responsibilities or powers
of 2/8, is responsible for eight cells, and
16 for 16 cells. So now, how do we do a range
query on this now that we're not really working
in this standard array, but rather this weird
type of range of responsibilities? And the
answer is, we're going to calculate the prefix
sum up to a certain index. And that's what's
eventually going to allow us to do a range
queries. So let's figure out how to do prefix
sums, just like we did for a regular array,
but on this family tree. So the idea is we're
going to start at some index and cascade downwards
until we reach zero, you'll soon see what
I mean. So for example, let's find the prefix
sum up to index seven. So we're in calculating
the prefix sound from index, one to seven,
inclusive. Usually, everything in a Finnick
tree is inclusive. So if we look at where
we are at seven, so we can get the value in
the array at position seven. And then we want
to cascade downwards. So the next guy below
us is six, and then four. Notice that we were
like hopping down. So we start seven, and
then we move down to six. And then from six,
we go down to levels because six as arranges
responsibility to, and then we're at four
and four is a range responsibility of force,
that brings us all the way down to zero. And
we're always going to be able to go from where
we are all the way down to zero. So the prefix
sum for seven is the array at index seven
plus the array index six plus the array index
four. All right, now to find the prefix sum
for index 11. So we always start at where
we are. So that's 11. And then we're going
to cascade down. So the cell directly below
us, is 10. And 10, is arrangers responsible
to so we're gonna go down to,
so that's eight and an eight brings us all
the way down directly to zero. Okay, cool.
And one last one, let's find the prefix son
of two index four. So four, we searched for
four as arranger responsibility of exactly
four sets already. We're back down to zero
so we can stop. Okay, let's pull this all
together and try to do an interval sum between
i and j. So let's calculate the interval sun
between say 11 and 15. So the idea is we're
going to calculate the prefix sum of 15 and
11. So we're going to calculate prefix sum
of 15. And then we're going to calculate the
prefix sum up to 11. But notice that we're
not going to calculate up to 11. inclusive,
but exclusive because we want the value at
a lot. Okay, so if we start at 15, then we
cascade down until we hit zero. So 15 has
arranger responsibility of one, subtract one
from 15. Now we get to 14. And 14 has arranger
responsibility if two, because the least significant
there on 14 is two, okay, now we go to 12,
and then keep cascading down. So the prefix
sum to 15 is the array at index 15 plus 14
plus 12 plus eight. All right, now the prefix
sum for up to 11 dot inclusive, so we're going
to start at 10. Now we want to cascade down
until we hit zero. So 10 is arranger responsible
to subtract two from 10, we get to eight.
Now from eight has arranger responsibility
of eight, so cascade down, so eight minus
eight is zero. So now, the range sum is the
sum of all the indices of 15 minus those of
10, then that's how we would calculate the
range sum. So notice that in the worst case,
we're querying a cell which has a binary representation,
which is all the ones and these are the numbers
of the form like to the n minus one to a power
of two, minus one. So a power of two has one
bit set and all zeros, but when you subtract
one, then your whole bunch of ones here. So
if you look at 15, almost all of its bits
are ones. And those are the worst cases. So
in the worst case, we might be asked to query
say 15, and seven, both of which have a lot
of ones in them. So we're doing about to log
base two of N operations. But in the average
case, this actually pretty good. And we're
going to implement this in such a way that
it's just going to be bit manipulation. So
this is like super fast. So the range query
algorithm is pretty much this. You see, it's
like literally no code, the range query from
i to j, we have a Fenwick tree of size. And
so I'm going to define a function called prefix
sum, which does that cascade at cascading
down operation. So we started I and while
I is now equal to zero, we're going to sum
up the values in our final tree. And we're
going to remove the value of the least significant
bit. And we're all we're going to keep doing
this until our value is zero. And then we
can return the sum. So the range query manages
a difference between those prefix sums. So
really neat little algorithm. I want to talk
about Fenwick trees and point updates. So
let's dive right in. But before we get to
that, absolutely, make sure you checked out
the Fenwick tree range query video. And I
posted last, just to get the context of how
the Fenwick tree is set up and how we're doing
operations on it. Okay, so just to refresh
your brain on how we actually did a prefix
sum, and how we did those range queries. So
what we did was, we started at a value at
some index doesn't matter which and then we
continuously removed the least significant
bit until we hit zero. That's like cascading
down effect
that gave
so let's say we started at 13 or 13, at least
significant bit was one, so we removed one
and we got 12. And then we found out that
the least that nificant bit of 12 was four
So we remove four and then at least thing,
if you have eight was eight, now we reach
zero. And once we reach zero, we know that
we're done. So doing a point, date is very
analogous to this, instead of removing, we're
going to be adding the least significant bit,
as you'll see. So for instance, if we want
to add a value at index nine, then we have
to find out all the cells which are responsible
for nine, because remember, cells are responsible
for a range of responsibility. So if we start
with nine who find the least significant bit
and add it to nine, and we get 10. So 10,
finally significant bet, is has a value of
two, then we add it to 10, then find the least
significant bit 12 at 12. So it's four. Now
it's 16. And then we would do the same thing,
and then we're out of bounds. So we would
know to stop. So if I draw a line outwards
from nine, all the cells that I hit are the
ones I have to update. So remember, those
lines represent a range of responsibility.
So the lines that I hit are the ones that
I got when I added the least nificant bits.
Okay. So 14, add some constant x, at position
six in the Fenwick tree, which cells do I
need to modify? So we start six, and we find
the leasing of Gambit sex, and ad sex, so
we get eight, find the least significant bit
of eight and that 816. So if I draw a line
out from sex, then indeed the cells that I
do hit r six, eight, and 16. So the required
updates for our Fenwick tree are that we need
to add x to position six, eight, and 16. So
the algorithm is really, really simple. So
if we have a Fenwick tree, stored in their
array of size n, then while I, so I supposition
we originally want to update. So while i is
less than n, we're going to add x to the tree
acquisition I an add on the value of the least
significant bit of AI. And that's it, where
the function LSB is the significant bit of
AI. And there are built in functions to do
that, usually, and we're going to have a look
at some source code. Alright, so that was
point updates. And now we actually need to
construct the Fenwick tree. Let's talk about
Fenwick tree construction. We've already seen
how to do range queries and point updates
in the last two videos. But we haven't even
seen how to construct the Fenwick tree yet.
And the reason I've kept this for last is
you can't understand the Fenwick tree construction
without having previously understood how point
updates work. Alright, so let's dive right
in. So we could do the naive construction
of a Fenwick tree. So if we're given an array
of values, a, and we want to transform this
into a Fenwick tree, what we could do is initialize
our Fenwick tree to be an array containing
all zeros and add the values into the Fenwick
tree one at a time using point updates to
get a total time complexity of order n log
n. However, we can do better, we can actually
do this in linear time. So why bother with
n log n? Alright, so in the linear construction,
we're going to be given an array of values
we wish to convert into the Fenwick tree,
a legitimate Fenwick tree, not just the array
of values themselves. And the idea is we're
going to propagate the values throughout our
Fenwick tree in place.
And we're going to do this by updating the
immediate cell as responsible for us. Eventually,
as we pass through the entire tree, everyone's
going to be updated, and we're going to have
a fully functional Fenwick tree at the end
of the day. So it kind of relies on this cascading
idea. So you You propagate some thing to the
parent who's responsible for you, and then
that parent propagate its value to its parent
and so on. So it's just kind of like
almost delegating the value. So let's see
how this works. Oh, one more thing before
that. So if the current position is position
I, then the immediate cell above us, which
is responsible for us, so
our parent, let's say that is J, and j is
given by I, plus the least significant bit
of AI. Alright, so if we start at one, well,
the least significant bit of one is one, so
the parent is at position two. So notice that
there was a for at position two, but we're
going to add two for the value of i, which
is three. So now position two as a value of
seven. Now, we want a bit position two. So
find out which is responsible for position
two. So two, plus at least significant bit
of two is four. So four is actually responsible
for two are immediately responsible for two.
So go to index four and add the seven. Then
who is responsible for three? Well, that's
four. So go to position four, and add the
value at index three. Now, who's responsible
for four? Well, eight is responsible for four.
So go to position eight, and add the value
four. So now in position eight, we have four.
So in our five, and then you see how we keep
doing this, updating our parent, the immediate
cell responsible for us, now seven is updating
eight.
But
now, nobody, oh, eight doesn't have a parent.
Because our Fenwick tree is too small, it
only has 12 cells, but the parent that would
be responsible for eight is 16. And 16, is
out of bounds. So we just ignore it. It's
not irrelevant. So now, we keep going. So
I is nine nines, least significant bit is
one, so j is 10. That's where the parent is.
So keep propagating that value 10s, parent
12, lemons parent also 12. And now we are
the same sort of situation we had with eight
where we have an out of band situation, so
we ignore it. So the values that are there
right now are the values of the Fenwick tree.
And with these values, we can do range queries
and point updates, not with the original array
that we had. So let's look at the construction
algorithm itself. In case you want to implement
this, we will have a look at some source code
in the next video. But if you're using another
language that I'm not using, this can be helpful.
So given an array of values, you want to turn
into a Fenwick tree. Let's get it's about
the length, which is n. And I recommend you
actually clone or make a deep copy of the
values, just so that you don't accidentally
manipulate the values array while you're constructing
your Fenwick tree. That could be problematic,
because we're doing all this stuff in place.
So clone the values array, and then start
I at one and go up to n and then compute j
so the parent. So we just i plus the least
significant bit of I do an if statement to
check if j is less than n, that might actually
be less than or equal to and actually not
thinking about it because everything is one
based and in a Fenwick tree. Yeah, I'm pretty
sure it should be less than or equal to. Alright,
let's have a look at some Fenwick tree source
code. I'm here in my GitHub repository. You
can find it at this link which I'll put in
the description below. William fees, slash
data dash structures, and the Fenwick trees
source code is right here under the Fenwick
tree folder. So let's dive right in. I have
it here local on my computer and my text editor.
Alright, so this source code is provided to
you in Java, but it's really easy to train
layer two, any language you're working. So
create a Fenwick tree class which has two
constructors. One, they'll create an empty
family tree for a given size and then you
populate yourself. And another one, which
you give it an array of values, like we saw
in the last video, and constructs the Fenwick
tree in a linear time. So this is probably
the constructor you want to use, and not the
other one. But I give you the option to use
either or. So one thing that you guys should
know is that the values array pass in this
thing needs to be one based. In the last video,
I was hesitant on whether or not to actually
go less than or less than or equal to the
length of the array. And that's going to depend
on whether your array is one based or zero
based. Usually everything a family tree is
one based in which case, it would be less
than if you're using this as the length. All
right. But other than that, so this is just
the construction algorithm we saw. So just
propagate the value to the parent. So that's
right here, and ignore it if it's out of bounds.
So pretty simple stuff. So this is probably
one of the most interesting methods is the
least significant bit method. And it's going
to return the value of the least significant
bit for some integer i. So this bit magic
right here, essentially isolates and returns
the least significant bit value. Something
that's a bit more readable, is this right
here, which uses Java's built in method find
the least significant bit.
However, using a Rob manipulation, like this
without an additional function call will be
faster. Okay, so the prefix sums, this is
something we covered in the first video, which
allows you to compute the prefix sum from
one to I both inclusive. And all this is being
done one based. So this would do the cascading
down, they were talking about. So start with
a sum equal to zero, and add the values of
the indices you hit along the way while you
cascading down. And this line line 55 is equivalent
to i minus equal the least significant bit
of I, which is a lot more readable than this
crazy manipulation, which essentially just
clears that bit. But you want to use as much
bit manipulation as you can keep your Fenwick
tree fast, even though it's already really,
really fast. But the More button manipulation
you use, the less operation or machine level
operations you're going to do. And so your
program is going to be so much faster. Okay,
if you want to find the sum between IMG inclusive,
then we can call the prefix some methods right
here, and just essentially get the differences.
So that's easy. So adding, so this is from
a point update, at position, I add K to it.
So we k can be positive or negative, that
doesn't really matter. So what are you going
to do as for AI, you're going to update everyone
who's responsible for you. So all the ranges
that are responsible for you. And for each
of those, you're going to add the constant
K. And then you're going to propagate up to
your parent, my thing i equals i plus the
least significant bit, and you're going to
do that, until you're still within the tree
at some valent index. And this additional
method added for fun is that you want to set
the index is equal to k, this might sometimes
be useful, so just get the value at I so II,
and then call the Add method. So pretty simple
stuff. As you see this is what 8080 ish lines
and half of it is comments. So this is a really
simple and yet extremely fast the structure.
And interesting topic I want to talk about
today is the suffix array. This is an incredibly
powerful data structure to have in your toolbox
when you're doing some string processing.
Stuff like arrays are a relatively new data
structure appearing around the early 90s.
due to the heavy memory consumption needs
of suffix trees. Let's start with the basics
and talk about just what a suffix is. For
our purposes, a suffix is a non empty substring
at the end of a string. For example, if we
ask ourselves, what all the possible suffixes
of the string horse are, we are able to come
up with five unique suffixes. And they are
e, s, e, r, s, e, and so on. Now we can answer
the question what is a suffix array? The answer
is a suffix array is the array containing
all the sorted suffixes of a string. Let's
see an example of this. Suppose, you want
to find the suffix array for the word camel.
On the left, I constructed a table with all
the suffixes of camel and the indices of where
that particular suffix started in a string
camel. Then, on the right hand side, I sorted
all the suffixes in lexicographic order in
a table.
The actual suffix array is the array of sorted
indices highlighted in orange, we do not need
to actually store the suffixes themselves
if we know where the suffix begins in the
original string. This is an ingenious idea,
and it provides us with a compressed representation
of the sort of suffixes without actually needing
to physically store the suffixes themselves.
All we need is the original string and the
array of associated indices. In summary, a
suffix array is an array of indices which
store the sorted suffixes of a string. Furthermore,
for a bit of history on the suffix array,
it is a data structure originally designed
to be a space efficient alternative to a suffix
tree, which in turn is itself meant to be
a compressed version of another data structure
called a try. As a side note, even though
the suffix array is a very different from
the suffix treat suffix arrays can do just
about virtually anything, the suffix tree
can with some additional auxiliary information
such as a longest common prefix array, which
will be the topic of our next video. In this
video, we're going to talk about perhaps the
most important piece of information associated
with the suffix array. And that is the longest
common prefix array, also known as the LCP
array. The LCP array is an array where each
index stores how many characters two sorted
suffixes have in common with each other. Let's
have a closer look. Perhaps the best way to
show what the LCP array is, is to do an example.
In the following example, we'll find what
the LCP array is, for the string, A, B, A,
B, B, A, B. The first thing we'll want to
do is construct the suffix array for our string
to find out what all the sorted suffixes are.
Notice that the very first entry that we placed
in our LCP array, that is the middle column
is zero. This is because this index is undefined,
so we'll ignore it now. To begin constructing
our LCP array, let's begin by looking at the
first two suffixes and seeing how many characters
they have in common with each other. We noticed
that this is two so we placed two in the first
index of our LCP array. Now we move on to
the next two suffixes. Notice that they also
have an LCP value of two and the next two
don't have anything in common. So we placed
zero and the next to only have one character
in common, then three characters in common
and lastly, only one character in common.
So the result is the following LCP array,
highlighted in purple. In summary, the LCP
array is an array which tracks how many characters
To sort of suffixes have in common with each
other. Although very simple, you'd be surprised
how much information can be derived from such
a simple construction. Another thing worth
noting is that the very first index in our
LCP array was undefined. Since we store the
LCP array as an integer array, by convention,
we usually set this first index to be zero.
So that doesn't interfere with any operations
we might want to perform on the LCP array.
And this is fine for most purposes. Lastly,
we saw what the LCP array was, but not how
to construct it very efficiently. There are
other algorithms than the one I showed you
how to construct the LCP array, which run
in a much better time complexity, that is
in n log n time, and even in linear time.
In this video, I want to discuss a new application
of suffix arrays and LCP arrays, and that
is finding and counting unique substrings.
There are a variety of interesting problems
in computer science, especially bioinformatics
that require you to find all the unique substrings
of a string. The naive algorithm has a terrible
time complexity of n squared, which requires
a lot of space. The idea is to generate all
the substrings of the string and dump them
inside a set. A superior approach is to use
the information stored inside the LCP array.
This provides not only a quick but also a
space efficient solution. I'm not saying that
this is the canonical way of finding all unique
substrings because there exists Other notable
algorithms such as Robin carp in combination
with Bloom filters. Let's now look at an example
of how to find unique substrings. Let's now
look at an example of how to find all the
unique substrings of the string, a z A z A,
A for every string there are exactly n times
n plus one over two substrings. The proof
of this I will leave as an exercise so listener,
but it's really not that hard to derive. Now
notice that all the substrings here, there
are a few duplicate ones. I have highlighted
the repeated substrings there are exactly
six of them, and nine unique ones. Now let's
use the information inside the LCP array to
figure out which of those substrings really
were the duplicate once in the table on the
right I generate the LCP array for the string
AZ az a. Remember what the LCP array represents,
it represents that two adjacent suffixes of
the original string share a certain amount
of characters with each other. So if the LCP
value at a certain index is say five, and
there are five characters in common between
those two suffixes, in other words, there
are five repeated substrings between those
two suffixes, since they come from the same
larger string. So if we inspect the first
LCP position at index one, we see that has
a value of one. We know that the repeated
string is the first character in a so we know
that A is a repeated substring the next LCP
values three, so there are three repeated
substring between ACA and AZ ACA, namely Ay,
ay z,
and
ACA, the next interesting LCP values to for
the last two suffixes, so there are two repeated
substrings. Here we can eliminate z, and z
A, we can then come up with an interesting
way of counting all unique substrings. We
know how many substrings there are, and that
is n times n plus one over two. And we also
know the number of duplicate strings that
is the sum of all the LCP values. If this
doesn't make immediate sense, try out a few
examples and play around with it. If we go
back to the example we just did with a string
az, az a and we set n equal to five, which
is the length of the string, then we can get
the correct answer. have nine by punching
n equals five and then removing all the repeated
substring values summed up in the LCP array.
Alright, so if you're looking for a programming
challenge concerning counting substrings,
like I mentioned here, check out the link
to the Caris online judge for some practice.
I also included some source code for suffix
array and LCP array available on GitHub github.com
slash William fees slash dia dash structures.
There is a really neat problem called longest
common substring problem, or it's generalization,
the K common substring problem, which is really
what I want to focus on today. First, let's
state the problem and then discuss multiple
ways of solving it. Suppose we have n strings.
How do we find the longest common substring
shared between at least k of them, with K
being anywhere from two to n, the number of
strings. As an example, consider the three
strings, s one, s two, and s three, with the
value of k equal to two, meaning that we want
a minimum of two strings from our pool of
three strings to share the longest common
substring between them. In this situation,
the longest common substring is B, CA. But
know that the longest common substring is
not required to be unique, because there can
be multiple. The traditional approach to solving
this problem is to employ a technique called
dynamic programming, which can solve the problem
and a time complexity equal to the product
of the string lengths. Obviously, this method
can get unwieldy very quickly. And you should
avoid using it whenever possible, a far superior
approach. And the way to solve this problem
is to use a suffix array, which can find the
solution in linear time proportional to the
sum of the string lines. So how do we do this?
How do we use a suffix array to solve the
longest common substring problem? Let's consider
the three strings we saw earlier, s one, s
two and s three. What we will first want to
do is concatenate them all together into a
larger string, which I will call t, which
is short for text. However, when doing this,
we must be careful and place unique Sentinel
values between our strings. We need to do
this for multiple reasons. But the main one
being that we must avoid any intermingling
of suffixes when we construct the suffix array.
Additionally, I would like to know that these
settle values need to be lexicographically
less than any of the characters contained
in any of our strings. So in the ASCII table,
the pound sign, the dollar sign and the percent
sign are all less than any alphabetic character
contained within s one, s two and s three,
so we're good in doing the concatenation.
Once we have the string T, we are able to
construct the suffix array for tea. This procedure
can be accomplished in linear time with a
linear suffix array construction algorithm.
You will notice that on this slide, I am displaying
both the LCP array values on the leftmost
column and the sorted suffixes of t as they
would appear in the suffix array on the right
column. I also gave each suffix a certain
color to match it with the original string
it belongs to.
In this slide, you can see that the suffixes
starting with Sentinel values got sorted to
the top because they were lexicographically
less than all the characters in the string.
And this is to be expected. For our purposes,
we want to ignore them because we injected
them into the string t ourselves. So back
to the central problem. How do we find the
longest common substring of K strings? Given
that we now have the suffix array and the
LCP array constructed? The answer is, we're
going to look for K strings, each have different
colors whom share the largest LCP value. Let's
do an example with K equals three. Since k
equals three We have three strings, this means
that we need one string of each color, we
can achieve a maximum of two, if we sell the
following three adjacent suffixes. Notice
that each of them is a different color, meaning
that they came from different original strings.
And that the minimum LCP value in the selected
window is to note that we must ignore the
first entry in the window. This means that
the longest common substring solution is the
string ca of length two, which is shared amongst
all three of s one, s two and s three. Let's
do another example. But this time, let's change
the value of K to be equal to two. Since k
equals two, we want to have two suffixes of
different colors and the maximum longest common
prefix value between them. In this case, there
is a unique solution, which is the string
B CA, with a length of three shared between
s one and s two, but not s three. So far,
we've covered only some trivial cases, things
get much Messier. When not all the different
colors you need are exactly adjacent with
each other. A trick we will use to overcome
this will be to use a sliding window technique
to capture the correct amount suffix colors.
Here's what we'll do at each step, we'll adjust
the bottom or the top end point so that the
window contains exactly k suffixes of different
colors. Once we have a valid window with the
correct amount of colors, we'll want to query
the minimum LCP value for that window range.
In the picture below, you can see that this
value is two, here's the minimum value and
the LCP array for that window is two, again,
ignore the first entry which is five. Since
the minimum value for that window is two,
all the suffixes in that window, do share
the prefix a G, which has length of two, as
we would expect, here are some more details
on how we are actually going to perform the
query to obtain the minimum LCP value on the
current window we are considering. Turns out
that this is a really popular problem, and
it can be solved in a variety of ways. Since
we're dealing with a sliding window and not
just any arbitrary range query, we can use
a linear solution from the minimum sliding
range query problem to obtain the value we
want. Alternatively, I would recommend using
a minimum range query data structure such
as a segment tree to perform logarithmic range
queries on the LCP array. This is theoretically
a little slower, but it is much easier to
implement in my opinion. So to implement the
sliding window, we will also need an additional
data structure to keep track of
the colors in our window, I recommend using
a hash table for this task. On the bottom
left, I drew a table to indicate how much
of each color we are capturing and the current
window, a valid window will require at least
K or more columns to have a value greater
than zero. In the example that we'll follow,
let's suppose that k equals three, meaning
all three colors will need to be present in
our window for a valid query to occur. By
query I mean, querying the LCP array for the
minimum value in the current window, and then
possibly updating the best longest common
substring value found so far. Right now you
can see that our window is missing some blue.
So our rule when we're missing a certain color
is to expand the window down. And when we
already meet the criteria, we shrink the window
down. So let's expand our window downwards
to capture some blue. Now we have enough blue
and enough of each color to do a valid query.
When we perform the query, we would see that
the longest common substring for the window
we're in will have length three representing
the string a G. Now since we have enough features
We can then reduce the window size, I removed
one green suffix, and we still have at least
one of each color. So we can again perform
a query to find out that we get the same result
as last time. Now I shrink the window even
more. And now we don't have enough green.
So we cannot perform a valid query here. What
we need to do is expand the window downwards
until we hit a green suffix. Luckily, there
was a green suffix right there. And we can
perform a query to attempt to update the best
longest common substring value found so far.
In this window, the longest common substring
is only of length one. So the longest common
substring for this window is the string a,
which is not as long as the longest common
substring we found before, which was a G of
length three, so we can ignore this one and
keep searching. Now we shrink the interval,
and we're short one color, and that is red.
Let's expand downwards until we reach a red
suffix. So we expand and find a blue suffix.
This is not what we wanted. So let's keep
searching the expand Finally, green suffix,
and keep doing this until a red suffix is
reached. This video is getting a little long,
so I'm going to break it up here. And in the
next video, we'll look at a full example of
this method being applied. However, in the
meantime, if you're looking for a challenge
regarding the longest common substring problem,
make sure to check out the life forms problem
on the cast website. And if you're looking
for an implementation of longest common substring
algorithm, as I just described, make sure
to check out my algorithms repository@github.com
slash William fiza slash algorithms, we're
going to finish where we left off in the last
video. In this video, I want to do a full
example solving the longest common substring
problem with a suffix array.
For this example, we're going to have four
strings, s one, s two s three and s four.
I have also selected the value of K to be
equal to two, meaning that we want a minimum
of two strings of our pool of four to share
the longest common substring. And between
them. I have also provided you with a concatenated
text we'll be working with as well as the
solution at the bottom of the screen. In case
you want to pause the video and figure it
out for yourself. The first step in finding
the longest common substring between a set
of our four strings is to build the suffix
array and the LCP array, which I have displayed
on the right side and the left side, respectively.
While I will be conducting the longest common
substring algorithm, notice the variables
on the left as they change. The window LCP
and a window LCS values will track the longest
common prefix and the longest common substring
values for the current window. And the LCS
length, and the LCS set will track the best
values so far. So let's get started. Initially,
our window starts at the top, and we want
the window to contain two different colors.
So our rule is to expand downwards when we
do not meet this criteria. As I expand down,
the suffix is green, so we still only have
one color, I expand on again and still one
more green suffix. I expand downwards again
and now we arrive at a blue suffix. And here
we are able to perform a range query for our
window. However, our query isn't fruitful
because the window longest common prefix value
is zero. So there's no longest common substring
here. When we satisfy the window color criteria
like we do now, we decrease the window size
and decrease the window size by one and still
nothing interesting. Decrease the window size
again. And this time, look what we found.
The current window contains a longest common
prefix length of two. So we obtained the longest
common substring BC and added to our solution
set. Now we keep shrinking the interval size
because we meet the color requirement. Our
window size is now too small All because K
is two, so we need two different color strings.
So we expand once more. Now something interesting
has happened because we find an LCP value
of three, which is larger than our current
best value. So we update the solution set
to have the string B, C, D, instead of just
BC, which is one character longer. Now we
get to shrink the window size, the window
was now too small, so we expand the LCP value
of zero here, so that is no good. So shrink
the window size. Now expand to meet the color
requirement, we get an LCP value of one, but
that doesn't beat our current best, which
is three. So shrink the window. Now we need
to meet the core requirements, so expand,
we have only blue strings, so keep expanding
and LCP value of one for this window range.
So that's no good, so shrink. Now we have
an LCP value of two we're getting closer to
our best, but still not good enough. So we
have to shrink and like let go. Now expand.
Now something interesting is going on here.
We have a window RCP value of three which
is equal to our best so far. So instead of
saying that, the CDE our newfound, longest
common substring value beats BCD, which is
of the same length, we keep both in the solution
set. Alright, so now, let's shrink our window
interval because we meet the color requirement.
Now expand it, we still need one more color
expand again, our LCP window value is zero.
So shrink and shrink again. Now expand LCP
value of one here, that's not good enough.
So smaller, expand, we'll see p value of two.
Okay, we might be getting closer, but we meet
color requirements. So shrink. Now expand
to meet the color requirement. These two strings
have Nelson p values, zero, shrink. Now expand,
now shrink. Now we've reached the end and
found our solution to the longest common substring
problem with a four strings and a k value
of two. As I was doing the window expanding
and shrinking, I want you to notice that each
time the window either expanded or shrank,
I only ever moved one of the endpoints downwards.
And they were always going downwards. So we
know that the number of Windows has to be
linear in proportion to the number of suffixes
that we have. And the number of suffixes that
we have is the length of our text, T. So we
come to the conclusion that there must be
a linear amount of windows that we must consider,
which is really good. Because we want our
time complexity. Be quick, today's topic is
going to be on an efficient way to solve the
longest repeated substring problem.
The longest repeated substring problem is
another one of these fairly common problems
in computer science, lots of problems can
actually be reduced to this problem, so it's
important that we have an efficient way of
solving it. The naive approach requires n
squared time and lots of space. What we want
to do instead is use the information stored
inside the longest common prefix array to
yield a faster and also space efficient solution.
Let's do an example what is the longest repeated
substring of the string abracadabra? Feel
free to pause the video and figure it out
yourself. The answer is the substring Abra,
which is the longest substring that appears
at least twice in the string. So we call it
the longest repeated substring. Here you can
see the first instance of Abra on the left.
And now you can see the second repeated instance
of Abra on the right, although these substrings
are disjoint and do not overlap. In general,
this is permitted for the longest repeated
substring. Now let's solve the problem using
a suffix array and an LCP array which I have
generated on the right hand side. I'll give
you a moment to pause the video and inspect
the LCP array in case you notice anything
special in relation to the longest repeated
substring. Now that you already know what
the answer is, effectively, what we're looking
for in the LCP array is the maximum value.
Intuitively we want to do this because we
know that the suffixes are already sorted.
So if two adjacent suffixes have a large,
longest common prefix value, then they share
a good amount of characters with each other.
We also know that if the LCP value at a certain
index is greater than zero, then the string
shared between the two adjacent suffixes is
guaranteed to be repeated, because it is common
between two suffixes, each of which start
at different locations in the string. So here,
again, is Abracadabra. Since our LCP value
was four, we know that the first four characters
from the suffix abracadabra forms one part
of the repeated substring. Next, we know that
the suffix above it which shares the LCP value
of four also shares four characters present
in that longest repeated substring. Now, I
want you to look at another interesting case,
can you find the longest repeated substring
of the string, a ba, ba, ba, ba? Well, if
you did, you will find out that you not only
got one longest repeated substring, but two
longest repeated substrings. Since there can
be ties. In a case like this, you're not looking
for a single largest value, but all largest
values that might exist. For the first maximum,
you can see that we'll want the first three
characters from the suffix, a ba, ba, ba,
ba, and for the second maximum, we'll want
the first three characters from the suffix
ba, ba. Visually, for this first, longest
repeated substring, we have a BA, which appears
at the start, and then a BA again, closer
to the end. The other repeated substring is
found using the second largest common prefix
value, and its first occurrence is found here,
and the second one just next to it. That is
all for repeated substrings pretty easy once
the suffix array and the LCP array have already
been constructed. Here is a practice problem
on campus if you want to tackle a longest
repeated substantive problem which requires
you to have an efficient solution. Today,
I'm going to introduce probably one of the
most important types of trees in computer
science, which are balanced binary search
trees. Balanced Binary search trees are very
different from the traditional binary search
tree because they not only conform to the
binary search tree in variant, but they are
also balanced. What I mean by balanced is
that they're self adjusting to maintain a
logarithmic height in proportion to the number
of nodes they hold. This is very important
because it keeps operations such as insertion
and deletion extremely fast, because the tree
is much more squashed. In terms of complexity,
a binary search tree has averaged logarithmic
operations, which is quite good. However,
the worst case still remains linear, because
the tree could degrade into a chain for some
inputs. One such input is a sequence of increasing
numbers. To avoid this linear complexity,
we've invented balanced binary search trees
in which the worst case is logarithmic for
all operations, which makes them very appealing.
Central to how nearly all Balanced Binary
Search Tree implementations keep themselves
balanced is the concept of tree rotations,
which is going to be the main topic of this
video. Later, we'll actually look at some
specific types of balanced binary search trees
to see how these rotations come into play.
So the secret ingredient to most advanced
binary search tree implementations is the
combination Have two things. One a clever
tree invariant and tree rotations. A tree
invariant is simply a property or a rule that
you impose on your tree, such that it must
be met at the end of every operation. To ensure
that the invariant is always satisfied a series
of tree rotations are normally applied. We'll
get back to this concept and fitting variants
in a later video. So don't worry about them
so much for now. Right now we're going to
look at how tree rotations work. Suppose our
invariant is not satisfied. And to fix it,
we need to do a right rotation about node
A. Assuming node A has a left child B, we
can perform a right rotation to put B where
node A was and push node A down to become
B's right child. When I first learned about
this, in my undergrad, I was Mind blown. Literally,
I thought it was absurd, or even to the point
of being illegal that we should be allowed
to do this and just move around nodes in a
tree. But what I've realized since is that
a transformation like this is totally legitimate.
Since we're not breaking the binary search
tree invariant in any way. If you inspect
the left tree, you'll discover that in terms
of ordering and placement, node D is less
than node B is less than E is less than a
is less than c, then you inspect the right
tree and remark that well, this is also true.
A bit more detail on why performing tree rotations
is a valid operation. First, you have to remember
that all balanced binary search trees are
binary search trees, meaning that the binary
search tree invariant holds. So for every
node and the values in the left subtree are
less than the value of n and the values in
the right subtree are all greater than the
value of n. So in this sense, it doesn't matter
what the tree structure itself looks like.
All that fundamentally matters is that the
binary search tree invariant holds. This means
we are free to shuffle, transform, or even
rotate the values and nodes in our tree as
we please as long as the binary search tree
environment remains satisfied.
Now let's look at how these rotations are
done in great detail. For simplicity, since
the rotations are symmetric, or will only
do the right rotation, and you should be able
to figure out the left rotation on your own.
first have a look at the tree on the right.
Notice that there are directed edges pointing
downwards and another node p above a, which
may or may not exist. This is why there is
a dotted line on that edge. If a note a does
have a parent node p, then it is important
that we take it into account when doing the
rotation. In either case, we start with a
pointer reference to note a, this is the orange
arrow, then we'll want a pointer to node B.
After that set, a is left a pointer to point
to B's right child, then change B's right
pointer to point to node A and we've successfully
done a right rotation. If we rearrange the
nodes, this is what we would end up with.
However, notice that there's a slight problem.
If node A had a parent node, then either the
parents left or right pointer would still
be referencing a. This is problematic since
B is A's successor after the rotation. So
we change the link to now point to B. This
step is usually done on the recursive call
back using the return value of the right rotate
function. We just finished looking at the
case where each node has a reference the left
and the right child nodes. But in some Balanced
Binary Search Tree implementations, it's more
convenient for nodes to also have a reference
to the parent node. This complicates tree
rotations because now instead of updating
three pointers, we need to update six pointers.
Let's have a look. In this case, where we
also have a parent link, every node is in
a sense, doubly linked. We start off with
a pointer or referencing a and the first thing
we'll want to do is also reference node B
And node p, so we don't lose them as we shuffle
around pointers. Next we'll adjust the left
subtree of a to make A's left pointer reference
B's right subtree. Of course, throughout this
example, assume B is not know, if you're paranoid,
you can add an extra if statement to check
for this condition. However, it would be a
mistake to assume B is right subtree is not
null, we actually have to check against this
before setting B's right child's parent to
reference a. Next let's make a the right subtree
of me. So set meas right pointer to reference
a. Now make A's parent pointer or reference
be the last thing we need to do is adjust
the reference to the parent node P. So make
these parent pointer a reference P. And now
the very last thing I promise is to make peas
left or right pointer reference the successor
node B. Notice that we need to check if p
is not now because it might not exist. This
will be the case for the root node. If we
readjust the tree, you will see that we correctly
did a right rotation. There are a lot of steps
in doing this right rotation. And it's a very
error prone process, which is why I wanted
to do it in such detail. Today we're going
to look at how to insert nodes into an avielle
tree in great detail. We'll be making use
of the tree rotation technique we looked at
in the last video. So if you didn't watch
that, simply roll back one video. Alright,
before we get too far, I shouldn't mention
what an avielle tree is. An EDL tree is one
of many types of balanced binary search trees,
which allow for logarithmic insertion, deletion
and search operations. something really special
about avielle tree is that it was the first
type of Balanced Binary Search Tree to be
discovered.
Then, soon after a whole bunch of other types
of balanced binary search trees started to
emerge, including the two three tree, the
HV the scapegoat tree, and the avielle trees
main rival the red black tree, what you need
to know about Next is the property that keeps
the avielle tree balanced. And this is the
balance factor. Simply put, the bounce factor
of a node is the difference between the height
of the right subtree and the left subtree.
I'm pretty sure the bounce factor can also
be defined as the left subtree height minus
the right subtree height. But don't quote
me on this, it would also screw up a lot of
what I'm about to say, and may also be the
reason why you find many inconsistent ideas
about what way to do tree rotations on various
Google search results pages. So for consistency,
let's keep the bounce factor right subtree
height minus left subtree height for clarity
because people get this wrong or define it
differently. The height of node x is calculated
as the number of edges between x and the furthest
leaf. So if your tree only has one note, the
tree has height zero, not height one because
there are no edges, that invariant on the
avielle tree that keeps it balanced is forcing
the balance factor of every node to be either
minus one zero or plus one. If the balance
factor of a node is anything else, we need
to resolve that with tree rotations. In terms
of information, we just store in each node
to actually make the avielle tree work. What
we'll need is the actual value of the node
stores. This value must be comparable. So
we know how to insert it and in what position
it goes to the tree. Then we'll also need
the bounce factor and the height of the node
as well as the left and the right child pointers.
As the algorithm executes, we'll need to update
these values. So keep that in mind. So a slider
so Mac I said that the balance factor of a
node must always be minus zero or plus one.
A natural question to ask is how do we handle
the case where this is not true? The answer
is that if this is not true, then the nonce
factor must be either be plus two or minus
two, which we can easily handle with tree
rotations. The rotations we need to perform
depending on the structure of the tree can
be broken down into four distinct cases. The
first such case is when the tree is what we
call left heavy, and there are two left child
nodes. This is an easy case to fix, because
all we need to do is perform a right rotation
about the yellow node to balance. The next
case is the left right case where you have
a left child, but then that node has a right
child. To fix this, you do a left rotation
about the left child. So the green one on
the left most image, what happens then is
that this transforms into the left left case
we just saw, which we can resolve with a right
rotation balance. The third case is the right
right case, which is symmetric to the left
left case. So instead of doing a right rotation,
we do a left rotation about the green note.
Last but not least, is the right left case,
which is symmetric to the left right case.
For this case, you would perform a right rotation
about the yellow node on the left most image
to transform this case into the right right
case, and then do a left rotation about the
green note in the middle image.
Next, I want to show you some pseudocode for
inserting nodes into an ACL tree because it's
not all that obvious or easy. This first method
is the public facing method for the insert
method, which returns true or false depending
on whether the value was successfully inserted
or not. For simplicity, we're going to ban
duplicate values in our ACL tree. So if the
value already exists, or the value is no,
this method would return false. If the node
does not know, and it doesn't already exist
in the tree, we call our private recursive
insert method, where we pass in a pointer
to the root node and the value we want to
insert. The private recursive method is also
simple. If we hit the base case a null node,
we simply return a new instance of the node
with the value we want to insert. Otherwise,
we get to compare to a value with the value
we're trying to insert against the current
node to determine if we should go on the left
or the right subtree. After that, on the recursive
call back, we call the update method which
updates the bounce factor and height values
for this note, and lastly, we rebounds the
tree with a bounce method. Now let's take
a look at the update enhance method. And what
they're actually doing. The update method
updates the bounce factor and height values
of our node. So to calculate the height of
the node, we get the maximum height of the
left and the right subtrees and then add one.
Notice that I initialize the left and the
right subtree heights to be minus one. But
this is because it will cancel out with a
plus one with a max function in the case where
the node has no sub trees giving the correct
height of zero for leaf nodes. Lastly, I update
the balance factor for this node. By finding
the difference between the right subtree and
the left subtree heights,
the
balanced method is slightly more involved
but not too crazy. Here we check if our bounds
factor has an illegal value of minus two or
a plus two. If the bounce factor is a minus
two, then we know that the node is left heavy,
then we dig further into the left subtree.
To determine if we're dealing with a left
left case or a left right case, we do a similar
thing if the balance factor is plus two, except
we're dealing with the right right or the
right left case. If the bounce factor is not
plus two or minus two, then we know that the
bounce factor is going to be either plus one,
zero or minus one. And in either of those
cases, we don't need to do anything inside
the four cases we might run into. Notice that
all we do here are calls to the left rotation
and right rotation methods that we saw in
the last video. Also notice that the left
right and right left cases, call the left
left and right Right right case methods respectively,
since they reduce to those cases after a first
rotation. In the last video, we looked at
this right rotation method. But since we're
dealing with any vl tree In this video, we
actually need to augment that method to update
the height and bounce rate values for the
nodes, we're moving around. When we do rotations,
this is a subtle detail you must not forget,
otherwise, your height and bounce factor values
will be inconsistent with the left rotation
cases metric to this one, so you should be
able to figure it out pretty easily. In this
video, we're going to look at how to remove
elements from an avielle tree. And what you'll
discover is that removing elements from an
avielle tree is almost identical to removing
elements from a regular binary search tree.
So for the majority of this video, we're going
to actually be looking at how to remove elements
from a binary search tree in the very end
argument, that algorithm for ADL trees specifically.
So let's get started. So just for review,
I want to look at how to remove nodes in a
binary search tree in detail. So we can generally
break it up into two steps finding and replacing.
In the find phase, you find the element you
want to remove from the tree, if it exists,
and then replace it with a successor node,
the successor node is necessary for us to
maintain the binary search tree invariant.
More details on the Find phase. This is when
we're searching for the element in the tree
to see if it exists. And basically four things
in happen. First is we hit a null node, in
which case we know that the value we're looking
for doesn't exist. Our comparateur returns
a value of zero, meaning we found the node
we want to remove, the comparative value is
less than zero. so the value we're looking
for, if it exists, is going to be found in
the left subtree, or the comparative value
is greater than zero, in which case the value
if it exists, is in the right subtree. So
let's do an example of finding nodes in a
binary search tree. Suppose we're looking
for a 14, well, we should have a reference
to the root node. So this is where we start.
So we compare 20 and 14, and we know 14 is
less than 20. So we go on the left subtree.
We know 14 is greater than 10. So we go on
the right subtree. We know 14 is less than
15. So you're on the left subtree. 14 is greater
than 12. So the right subtree. And finally,
there we found it, the node we were looking
for. Now let's see what happens with a node
that doesn't exist. So let's try and find
26. So again, we start at the root node, then
we go to the right subtree, because 26 is
greater than 20, then we go the left subtree,
because 26 is less than 31. And once we're
at 25, we would go to the right subtree. And
then discovered that 26 does not exist in
the tree. So once we find the node, assuming
it exists, we need to replace that node with
its successor. The motivation for this is
that if we just remove the node without finding
a successor, then there'd be a gap in the
tree. And when we're looking for a successor
node, one of four cases
will happen. Either were a leaf node, in which
case there are no sub trees, the node to remove
has no left subtree the node to remove has
no right subtree or the node to remove has
both the left subtree and right subtree. We'll
see how to handle all these cases. In the
first case where the node to remove is a leaf
node, we can simply remove it without any
side effects. The successor node in this case
would be simply a null node. So suppose was
a remove node eight from this tree, the first
thing we do is find out where eight is in
the tree. So we'd go down the tree and then
we'd found node eight, then we discover that
Oh, it's a leaf node, so we can just remove
it like Alright, now for cases two and three,
where there's only a left or a right subtree.
In these cases, the successor node is the
immediate child of that left or right subtree.
The reason the successor is the immediate
node down from the node we're removing is
that it is the next node which is either greater
than it the case right subtree or less than
net, and the case of a left subtree. Let's
do an example, suppose we want to remove node
nine, the first thing we do is find when no
nine is in the tree. So start the route and
go to the right subtree, find the node we
want to remove, which is nine. And then we
inspect nine and discover that it only has
a left subtree. So the successor node is its
immediate child on the left,
so seven. So what we do is we get a reference
to seven,
and then get ready to remove nine. And then
we remove nine and then make seven, the successor
by linking it back up to five. And if we rebalance
the tree, that's what it looks like. And no
nine has been removed. So the last case, is
when the node we're trying to remove has both
a left subtree and a right subtree. So the
question in this case is in which subtree,
will we find the successor of the node we're
trying to remove? And surprisingly, or not
surprisingly, the answer is both. The successor
can either be the largest value in the left
subtree, or the smallest value in the right
subtree. Once the successor node has been
found in either left or right subtree, we
replace the value of the node to remove with
a value in the successor node. However, the
story doesn't end there, we must not forget
to remove the duplicate value of the successor
node that still exists in the tree. One common
strategy to resolve this is to recursively
call the function again, but with the value
to remove as the value in the successor node.
Let's see an example because this isn't completely
trivial. Let's remove node seven from this
tree, which is the root node. So we would
start at the root node and discover that in
fact, this is the node we want to remove and
notice that it has two non empty sub trees,
so we must choose a successor. To choose a
successor we either pick the smallest value
in the right subtree, or the largest value
in the left subtree. Let's find the smallest
value in the right subtree. And to do this,
you will go to the right ones, and then dig
as far left as possible. So now that we found
the successor node 11, we will copy its value
into the node we're trying to remove, which
is the root node seven. Notice that now there
are two instances of 11 in our tree, and we
want unique values in our tree. So to remove
the 11 that is currently highlighted, we would
recursively call our remove method, but on
11 this time, and luckily for us, this will
always result in a case one two or three removal.
So to remove 11 we notice that it only has
a right subtree. So its successor is its immediate
right child. So we restage the removal and
get ready to remove 11. So we remove 11 and
then hook 14 back up to 18. And if we rebalance
the tree, then we can see that the duplicate
11 value is gone. All right at the moment
we've been waiting for how do we augment the
binary search tree removal algorithm for avielle
trees. The solution is simple, you only need
to add two lines of code to ensure that the
tree remains balanced and that the bounce
factor and height values remain up to date.
On the recursive callback, you invoke the
update and balance methods you saw in the
insert video, which ensure that when the node
is removed from the avielle tree, that the
tree remains balanced. It's as easy as that.
Today what we're going to have a look at some
of the source code for the avielle tree. The
link to the source code I'm going to present
in this video can be found on GitHub github.com
slash emphysema slash data dash structures.
Make sure you have watched the last three
videos on the avielle tree about tree rotations,
insertions and removals in avielle trees before
continuing so you can understand the source
code I'm presenting. I don't normally do this,
but I'm going to present a live demo of the
avielle tree in action. So I'm here in my
GitHub repository. I'm just compiling some
of the Java code with avielle tree and then
I'm going to run it and you see It generated
a random tree with some values and notice
that the tree is relatively well balanced
for the number of nodes that are in it. So
I randomly inserted some notes. And you might
expect the tree to be a bit more sloppy if
it were just a simple binary search tree.
But the avielle tree really keeps the tree
quite rigid.
So I think we're ready to dive into the source
code. Now. Here we are, in the source code
of a recursive avielle tree implementation
and the Java programming language. So let's
get started. If you look at the class definition
for the avielle tree, you will notice that
this class takes a generic type argument,
which is of type t, which extends comparable.
And this generic type I'm defining, basically
says that the types of values we're going
to be inserting inside the tree need to be
comparable in a sentence, meaning we need
to be able to insert them and know how to
insert them. So if you look inside the subclass
node, which I've created, you can see that
the value we're actually storing inside the
node is of type T. So it's a comparable. And
that's very important. The other instance
variables I'm storing inside the, the node
subclass for the save your tree is, of course,
the bounce factor as an integer, the height
of the node, because we want to be able to
query the height of a node in constant time,
so I'm storing it inside every node. And then
of course, there's going to be the left and
the right child pointers, right here. And
notice that this, this node class implements
the tree printer, printable note interface.
And that's just an interface I have somewhere
in this folder that allows me to display the
tree I did on the terminal. So this isn't
quite a requirement if you're actually building
an ACL tree. And nor are these overrides,
those are also for being able to display the
tree in the terminal, which is really handy
for debugging actually. Alright, so instance
variables at the avielle tree class level,
we have the root node, this should really
be private, although I'm using it for testing,
so I'm leaving it package private. I'm also
keeping track of the number of nodes inside
the tree inside this node count variable.
Something else I'm also using for testing
is this height function. Although it's really
good to just saying you check yourself to
make sure that your avielle tree height is
relatively low. Then there are these methods
like size and is empty, which are pretty self
explanatory. This the display method I call
to actually print the tree in the terminal.
The set contains method to check if a certain
value already exists inside the tree. So this
is the public facing method, which calls the
private method, and I give it the route as
the initial node to start off with. So to
check if a node exists inside a tree, if we
hit the base case, then we know that that
value does not exist. Otherwise, we compare
the current value to the value inside the
node. So that returns a comparative value
of either a value less than zero, which means
that if the value does exist, it'll be found
in the left subtree or comparateur is greater
than zero, meaning the value if it exists,
is in the right subtree. Otherwise, the means
that the comparative value is equal to zero.
And that means we found the node inside the
tree so we can return true. So we're trying
to insert this value variable, if it's no,
we don't want anything to do with it. So we
just return false. And we return a Boolean
for the insert method to indicate whether
an insertion was successful or not. So if
the value If not already exists inside the
tree, then we're going to call the private
insert, method and then assign its value to
the root. And also increment the node count,
because we know we're going to successfully
insert something if we're inside this block,
and at the same time, we're going to return
true.
Alright, let's have a look at the private
insert method. So if we reach the base case,
meaning we traverse all the way down our tree,
and the value of node is null, then we know
this is the position where we need to insert
that new node, so create a new node and give
it the value. Otherwise, we're searching for
the insertion position. So again, invoke the
comparator function, then do value compared
to no dot value. This dot compare two comes
from the comparable interface at the class
level. So that's why we're allowed to invoke
dot compare to on a generic type here and
another generic type there. So again, if comparateur
is less than zero, then insert in left subtree.
Otherwise, insert in the right subtree. And
here is the extra two lines, you need to add
for the avielle tree, which is calling the
update method to update the bounce factor
and the height value for this node and also
rebalance the tree if necessary. Well rebalance
the tree at this node. All right, so let's
look at the update method. So this is to update
the balance factor and height of a node. So
here are two variables that grab the height
of the left subtree and the right subtree.
Then I update the height for this note. So
that's always one plus the maximum of either
the left subtree or the right subtree height.
Then once we have the appropriate values for
left and right, we can of course update the
bounce factor, which is the difference between
the right and the left subtree heights. Okay,
so we've done the update, now we can call
the balance method. And inside the balance
method, we're looking to readjust nodes whose
balance factors are either minus two or plus
two. In the case of a minus two, this means
that our tree is left heavy. And inside the
left heavy case, we can run into the left
left case or the left right case. And inside
the right heavy case, we have the right right
case and the right left case. And to identify
those sub cases, you just check the balance
factor, but on either no dot left or no dot
right respectively. And if if the balance
factor of the node is not minus two or plus
two, then we know that the balance factor
is either zero plus one or minus one, which
is fine, and we don't have to touch anything.
We don't have to rebalance the tree if either
one of these is true. So we just simply return
the note. So now we can look at the individual
cases themselves. So like the left left case,
we'll just perform a right rotation. The left
right case, we'll do an initial left rotation,
and then call the left left case. So we're
reusing methods we already wrote here, since
this case degrades to that case, after one
rotation, and a similar thing happens for
the right right case and the right left case,
we get to call the right right case after
one right rotation over here. then here are
the notorious left rotation and right rotation
methods. For the avielle tree. It's very important
that we call these two update methods to update
the height and balance factor values after
that we've rotated about this node, because
those values will undoubtedly change. And
it's also important that this is the order
you do them and you can't Do them in inverse
order because you have to update the the child
node first to get the correct balance factor
and height values for the parent.
Okay,
now we're at the Remove method. So in this
remove method, we want to remove this element,
or I should have called it value rather. But
still, so if the element is no, well, we know
it doesn't exist in the tree. So just return
false. Otherwise, make sure that value exists
in the tree, and then remove it by calling
the private remove method, then decrease the
node count and simply return true on the Remove
method to indicate that the removal was successful.
So let's look at this private remove method
where all the action is happening. So if we
had the base case, and just return null,
then we get our comparative value. And we
do what we always do, we check if the comparator
is less than zero. And if so we dig into the
left sub tree. And we know that the value
we're looking for is smaller than the current
value. And then we recursively call the Remove
method. But passing down no dot left, so we're
just decreasing the region or searching and
passing the element as well. Otherwise do
the same thing. But for the right. So recurse
down the right subtree. Otherwise, if this
is not true, and that is not true, then we
know that the comparative value is equal to
zero, meaning we found the node we wanted
to remove. And we know from the slides that
this is where the four cases come up. If no
dot left is equal to null, then we know that
we want to return no dot right. Or if no dot
right is null, meaning the right subtree is
null, then return no dot left. Okay, and then
the final tricky case, where we're trying
to remove a node, who still has both sub trees,
so the left subtree is there and the right
subtree is there. But we still want to remove
that node. And we can either pick the smallest
value, while the successor can either be the
smallest value in the right subtree of the
largest value in the left subtree. And I'm
using a heuristic right here to actually determine
which one I want to do, just because I think
it's a good heuristic. And here's what it
is, if the height of the left subtree is greater,
I want to remove nodes from that subtree.
But otherwise, if the right subtree has a
larger height, than I want to remove nodes
from that subtree. So that's the heuristic
I'm using to choose which subtree I remove
from. And I just made up this heuristic. But
I think in general, it'll work pretty well.
So what we do, let's say there are are or
the left subtree has larger height, than what
I'm going to do is I'm going to find the successor
value by going down the left subtree once
and then digging all the way to the right
to find the max value, and then swapping that
value into the current node. And then this
is the recursive part, we recurse. on removing
the successor value instead of the element
we passed in, or rather the element we passed
in becomes the successor value. So we've removed
the element, but now we also have to remove
the successor value because we don't want
duplicate values in our tree, then we basically
do the same thing. But on the other side.
If the condition goes the other way. Here's
what I was mentioning in the last video, where
you want to call the update and rebalance
method on the call back of this remove method
so that the tree remains balanced even though
we're removing nodes and these are the Find
men and find max method I was calling right
appear, which just digs left or digs, right
depending on the case. And here's just an
iterator to traverse the tree, I don't think
I need to go over this. And here's another
method for testing which validates the binary
search tree invariant, also not particularly
important. And this is what I was calling
in the main function that will just randomly
insert values inside the tree and then display
it. So when I invoked this file on the terminal,
this is what executed. So that is an ACL tree.
It's pretty cool data structure, and I quite
enjoyed writing it up. Today's data structure
is the index the priority queue. This is going
to prove to be a very useful data structure
that you wish you would have known a long
time ago. So just before we get started, this
video builds off concepts from the previous
priority queue videos, which simply go over
the basics. Strictly speaking, you can probably
get by without watching all those videos,
as I will be doing a quick recap. But for
those of you who want to know, priority queues
and full detail, please check out the description
for links to those. So what exactly is an
indexed party queue? Well, it's a traditional
priority queue variant, which on top of having
all the regular priority queue operations,
also supports quick updates and deletions
of key value pairs. One of the big problems
that the index party queue solves is being
able to quickly look up and dynamically change
the values in your priority queue on the fly,
which is often very useful. Let's look at
an example. Suppose a hospital has a waiting
room with n people, which need different levels
of attention. Each person in the waiting room
has a certain condition that needs to be dealt
with. For instance, Mary is in labor. So she
has a priority of nine a car she has a paper
cut, he has a priority of one. James has an
arrow in his leg, he has a priority of seven
Naija stomach hurts, she gets priority of
three. Richard has a fractured wrist, so his
priority is five. And lastly, Leah also has
a stomach hurts, we want to process these
patients by highest priority first. This means
the hospital would serve Mary first followed
by James. However, then something happens
suppose nyda stomach condition worsens, and
she starts vomiting. Her priority needs to
get updated to six. Because of this Neda gets
served next once they're finished with James.
During this time, Richard gets impatient and
leaves he goes to another clinic down the
street so he no longer needs to be accounted
for. Further suppose that a car wash goes
to take a drink of water slips on the floor
and as a result cracks his head and needs
immediate attention. So we increase his priority
to 10. Once the EDA is dealt with a karsch
shouldn't be next. And lastly, this is followed
by layer. As we saw in the hospital example,
it is very important to be able to dynamically
update the priority of certain people. The
index priority queue is a data structure which
lets us do this efficiently. The first step
two using an index party queue is to assign
index values to all the keys thus forming
a bi directional mapping. We use an index
persecute to track who should get served next
in our hospital, we need to assign each person
a unique key index value between zero and
n non inclusive. Note that this mapping is
intended to be bi directional. So I would
advise using a bi directional hash table to
be able to flip back and forth between the
key and its key index. Basically, any operation
on the index party q will require the associated
key index of a particular key. So you're probably
wondering why I'm saying that we need to map
keys to indices in the domain zero to n nine
inclusive. The reason for this is that typically
part of queues are implemented as heaps, which
under the hood are actually arrays. So we
want to facilitate being able to index into
those arrays this will become apparent shortly.
I will say though that often and I mean very
often, the keys themselves are already integers
in the range zero to n. So there's no need
to actually construct this bi directional
mapping. It's already there implicitly. However,
it is handy to be able to support any type
of key such as names or general objects, we
can think of an index party queue As an abstract
data type with certain operations we want
it to support here are about a dozen or so
operations, we want our index particules support.
These are deleting keys, getting the value
associated with a key, checking if a key exists
in the priority queue, getting the key index
with the smallest value, getting smallest
value in the index Burcu, being able to insert
and update key value pairs. And finally, the
specialized update operations increase in
decrease key which I'll talk about at the
end. For all these operations, you need the
key index associated with a particular key
that you're dealing with. Throughout these
slides, I will be denoting the key index simply
as the variable KPI to distinguish it from
other index values, so keep your eye out for
that. And index party queue can be implemented
in several ways. Some ways with really good
time complexity is using specialized heap
structures. However, we're going to cover
the binary heap implementation for simplicity,
you will notice that the time complexity for
all these operations are either constant or
logarithmic, which is really good. In a traditional
party queue. The remove and update operations
are linear because we are not maintaining
a mapping to the position of where our values
exist within the heap. Before we dive into
the index party queue per se, I want to spend
a few slides giving a refresher on the traditional
priority queue data structure which only supports
values not key value pairs like the index
barbecue. Still, both data structures are
very similar, and most people would consider
them the same. Although there are key differences
in my opinion, recall that a very common way
to represent a binary heap is within array
since every node is indexed sequentially.
If we were to represent the following binary
heap as an array, we would get this array
of values. If we know the index of node i,
we can figure out what its left and right
child nodes are by using simple formulas,
the left child is two times i plus one and
the right child is two times i plus two, assuming
Zero Based indices. As an example, what are
the children of the node at index four? Well,
we can just plug in AI into the two formulas
I just gave you to obtain the indices, nine
and 10. Of course, you can always run the
math backwards and figure out with a parent
of given notice. Both of these are especially
useful if you're either walking up or down
the tree. Whenever you want to insert a new
value into the priority queue, you insert
the new value at the insertion position at
the bottom right of the binary tree. Suppose
we want to insert the value eight, this would
violate the heap invariant, so we need to
bubble up the value until the invariant is
met. So swap nodes five and 12. The heap invariant
is still not satisfied. So swap again, swap
nodes two and five, and now the tree is balanced.
Now let's review how removals are done in
a traditional priority queue. To remove items
search for the element you want to remove
and then swap it with the last node, perform
the removal and finally bubble up or down
the swapped value. For this example, suppose
we want to remove the node that has the value
five, we don't know where the node value five
is within the priority queue. So we have to
search for it. This is one of the major differences
between the priority queue and the index priority
queue. So start at node zero and process each
node sequentially until a node with a value
of five is found, if any.
So we found a node with a value five to actually
remove it from the heap, swap it with the
right most bottom node. Once this is done,
remove node five from the tree. Now the purple
node we swapped into five spoon position may
not satisfy the heap invariant, so we need
to either move it up or down the tree. In
this case, since the purple node has the value
of one, which is smaller than its children,
and we're dealing with a max heap, we'll want
to move the node down. That was a quick recap
on just about everything you need to know
about a traditional party queue. Now let's
talk about implementing an indexed priority
queue with a binary heap. For the following
examples, suppose we're dealing with n people
with different priorities that we need to
serve. Perhaps we're prioritizing people for
a queue at a hospital, a waiting line at a
restaurant or who knows what the main thing
is, we'll assume that the values can dynamically
change and that we always want to serve the
person with the lowest priority to figure
out who to serve. Next, we'll use a min indexed
priority queue to sort by lowest value first.
The first step as mentioned before, is to
assign each person a unique index value. between
zero and N, non inclusive. These are the key
index values in the second column beside each
person's name, then I'm going to give each
person an initial value to place inside the
index party queue. These values will be maintained
by the index priority queue once inserted,
note that the values can be any comparable
value, you want not only integers as shown
here, this means we can have strings, objects,
or whatever type of data we want. If I was
to build a min indexed priority queue, out
of the key value pairs I have in the last
slide, this is the heap I would get. Remember
that unlike the previous example, we're sorting
by smallest value first, since we're dealing
with a min heap. If I want to access the value
for a given key K, First, you need to figure
out what its key indexes. And then you will
look up in the values array maintained by
the index priority queue. Here's a good question,
What value does the key Bella have in the
index priority queue? Well, first, find Bella's
key index value, which is one, then index
into the values array at position one to find
the corresponding value for the key in the
index partner queue. So Bella has a value
of 15. Awesome, now we know how to get the
value for a particular key in the index priority
queue. But how do we get the index of the
node for a particular key? To do that, we'll
need to maintain some additional information,
namely a position map we can use to tell us
the index of a node in the heap for any given
key index. For convenience, I will store the
position map as an array called p n inside
the priority queue. As an example, let's find
out which node represents the key Dylan. First
find the key index for Dylan, which happens
to be three, then look up index three in the
position map to tell you where Dylan is in
the heap. It looks like Dylan is at the node
and the index seven highlighted in orange.
Now here's a follow up question. Where is
George in the heap? I'll give you a quick
moment to figure that out before I give you
the answer.
All right, so with just about every operation,
the first step is to find the key index for
the key we care about, which is George, then
use the key index to do a lookup inside the
position map and find out the node for George,
which happens to be node one. Great, now we
know how to look up the node for a given key.
But how do we find the key for a given node.
This inverse lookup will prove to be a very
useful operation. Say you want to know which
key is associated with the root node at index
zero? Well, you need to be able to do an inverse
lookup to figure that out. To do the inverse
lookup from node indices, and D keys will
need to maintain an inverse lookup table.
I will denote this lookup table as I am short
for inverse map. Let's see if we can figure
out which person is represented in the node
at index two. To do that, simply do a lookup
in the inverse map at index two. This gives
us information about which key index is associated
with that node. Knowing the key index enables
us to retrieve the actual key by doing a lookup
in our bi directional hash table. In this
case, the node at position two represents
the key Ana, here's a follow up question to
make sure you're still paying attention. Which
key is being represented in the node at index
position three. Same as before, find the key
index through the inverse map, then with the
key next, figure out the actual key from the
bi directional hash table, we can then conclude
that the node at position three represents
the key Isaac. What we just covered was how
an index party Q is structured internally
and what all the moving parts are. Now we
want to actually do some useful operations
with this index party queue, such as inserting
new key value pairs, removing key value pairs
based on a key and also updating the value
associated with a key. These are all possible
and are actually very similar to how you would
do it with a regular priority queue insertion
is nearly the same except that we have to
update the position map pm and the inverse
map I am to reflect the movement of key value
pairs. Suppose we want to insert the key marry
with a value of two into the priority queue.
What we first have to do is assign marry a
unique key index value, then we're going to
insert the new key value pair at the insertion
position. Notice that upon insertion, we updated
our arrays at index 12. To reflect that the
new value was in fact inserted. Currently,
the heap invariant is not satisfied since
the new node at index 12 has a value less
than the one at node five. To resolve this,
we're going to swap the newly inserted value
upwards until the heap invariant is satisfied
swapping nodes, we need to update the position
map and the inverse map. by swapping the values
of the two nodes we're exchanging the values
array does not need to be touched since it
gets indexed by the key index value that we
get from the map and not the node index per
se. It turns out that the heap invariant is
still not satisfied, so we need to keep swapping
upwards.
Let's have a look at some pseudocode for insertions
and this snippet, the user calling this function
needs to provide a valid key index k II, as
well as a non null value they want to insert.
The first thing I do is store the value associated
with a key inside the values array. Then I
update the position map and the inverse map
to reflect the fact that a new key value pair
has been inserted into the priority queue.
Finally, I move the node up the heap until
the heap invariant is satisfied. Let's take
a closer look at this swim method to see how
that happens. Here we are looking at the swim
method, you'll notice that it has two supporting
functions swap, and let's swap is simply exchanges
to nodes based on index and last determines
if no AI has a value less than node j. The
logic for the swim function is fairly simple.
It begins by finding the index of the parent
node and walking up the tree. For every iteration,
we walk up one layer in the tree. If the index
of the current node is not the root node and
the value of the current node is less than
the parent node, remember that we're dealing
with a min heap, and want small values to
be as high up as possible in our heap to actually
issue a node exchange simply call the swap
function and provide the index of the current
node and the parent node, and then update
the current node and the parent node index
values. I also want to talk about swapping
and how that actually occurs. Because it's
slightly different than a traditional party
queue. And this swap method, we're not actually
moving around the values in the array, we're
only swapping around index values. Remember
that the values array is indexed by the key
index, not the node index. So effectively,
the values array can remain constant while
we update the inverse map and the position
map. First, we update the positions of where
key index values are found in the index party
queue. Remember what the position map is,
it is the position of which node index a given
key index is found at. So we can do a straightforward
swap by indexing into the inverse map to find
the key index values and swap indices i and
j. Followed by this simply update the key
index values associated with nodes iMj and
the inverse map. To do this, this is just
a simple straightforward exchange. Next up,
I want to talk about polling and removing
elements from an indexed priority queue. Polling
is still a logarithmic operation. However,
removing is improved from a linear time complexity
to a logarithmic time complexity. Since node
position lookups are now constant time but
repositioning the nodes after removal This
is why the heap invariant is still logarithmic.
So let's jump into an example. Suppose we
want to pull the root node This is something
we often want to do since it'll give us the
key value pair with the lowest value in the
heap. The first step is to exchange the root
node with the bottom right node. As we do
that, remember to swap the index values. Now
we can remove the read node from the tree.
As we remove the value, let's make sure we
store the key value pair we're removing so
we can return it from our function later.
Then clean up the Remove node. Finally, restore
the heap invariant by moving the swapped purple
node down. Since the left and the right child
nodes have an equal value of two, let's default
to selecting the left one.
Let's do a slightly more involved removal
by removing a specific key from the index
party Q. And this example, let's remove the
key Laura. The first thing we want to do is
get the key index for Laura, which is the
key we're working with. So in this case, the
key index is equal to 11. Once we know the
key index, we can use that information to
locate the node within the heap by looking
inside the position map, then swap the node
we want to remove that is the node which contains
the key value pair for Laura and exchange
it with the bottom rightmost node. store the
key value pair before the actual removal,
clean up the Remove node. And finally restore
the heap invariant by moving the swapped purple
node up or down, we're going to make the purple
node move down because it has a large value.
Alright, let's look at some pseudocode. for
removing key value pairs. The code is also
very short only five lines of implementation
and three lines of cleanup. The first thing
to do is exchange the position of the node
we want to remove. And the bottom right most
node, which is always at index position as
Zed short for size of the heap. Once we've
exchanged the nodes, the rightmost node is
now in the position where the node we want
to remove was. So we need to move it either
up or down the heap to satisfy the heap invariant,
we don't know which it will be so we try to
move the node up and down. Hence sink and
swim. Lastly, I just clean up the values associated
with node we want to remove, you can also
return the key value pair being removed. But
I didn't do that here. Let's take a quick
look at the sync method. So we understand
how that works. to sync a node, we want to
select the child with the smallest value and
defaulting to the left child if there's a
tie. In this next block, I tried to update
the smallest child to be the right child.
But first I need to check if the right child
node index is within the size of the heap,
and its value is actually less than the one
of the left node. The stopping condition is
if we're outside the size of the heap, or
we cannot sync the current node any further.
Lastly, we want to make sure we swap the current
node with whatever was the node with the smallest
value. Lastly, we want to make sure we swap
the current node with whichever was the node
with the smallest value. The last core operation
we want to do on an index priority queue is
key value pair updates similar to remove those
updates in a min index binary heap also take
logarithmic time due to the constant time
lookup to find out where the node is and the
logarithmic time to adjust where the key value
pair should appear in the heap. Suppose we
want to update the value of the key Carly
to now have a value of one, like every operation,
find the key index of the key we want to work
with the key index for Carly happens to be
two, then we can use that key index value
to update the values array with the new value.
Of course, the heap invariant may not be satisfied,
so we need to move the node either up or down
until it is
the pseudocode for updating the value of a
key is super simple. Simply update the value
in the values array and move the node either
up or down the heap. It's that easy. Alright,
so there was nothing too special about updates,
but the part I really wanted to get to was
increase and decrease key. In many applications
such as dextrous or prims algorithm, it's
often useful to be able to update a given
key to make its value either always smaller
or always larger. In the event that a worse
value is given to the index party here it
should not be updated. In such situations,
it is often useful to define the more restrictive
form of update operation called increased
key or a decrease key respectively, depending
on whether you want to increase the value
associated with a key or always try and decrease
the value associated with the key. Both of
these operations are very simple. They simply
consist of doing an if statement before performing
an update operation which either increases
or decreases the value associated with the
key So bottom line, these two functions are
just convenience methods that wrap a get operation
with an if statement to update a value. Today,
we're going to look at some source code for
an indexed priority queue. So just before
we get started, make sure you watch my video
on the index priority queue, where I go over
the implementation details and why an index
priority queue is an important data structure.
All the source code for this video can be
found on my data structures repository@github.com
slash wm fuzzer slash data structures, the
link can be found in the description below.
Here we are in the source code for a min indexed
binary heap. This source code is presented
in the Java programming language. To get started,
notice that our min index binary heap requires
that we pass in a type of object which is
comparable This is so we can order our key
value pairs within the heap. You'll also notice
that I'm extending a min indexed dear heap.
This is just to be more generic. And all I
do in the constructor is simply initialize
this heap to have at most two children for
each and node while idea heap supports in
general and teach children. So let's look
at the D air heap implementation where all
the fun stuff is happening. So let's go over
I guess all the instance variables. So s Zed
is just the number of elements in the heap,
n is a constant, representing the maximum
number of elements in the heap, D is the degree
of each node. So for the binary heap, this
number is two. The two arrays, child and parent
track the child and parent indices for each
node, so we don't have to compute them dynamically.
pm and I am or the position map and the inverse
maps, which we're going to use to track the
key indices for our keys. And lastly is the
values array, which is the array that contains
the values associated with a certain keys.
Note that it's very important to notice that
this array is indexed by the key indices and
not by the nodes, indices, per se. So in the
constructor, we give a degree and a certain
maximum size for our heap. Then we just initialize
whatever value for the degree and the maximum
size of the heap, then I initialize all our
arrays, and I compute what the child and the
parent indices should be. And I also initialize
the position map and inverse map to have all
negative one values, then we have a few straightforward
methods such as size, is and key contains.
So you'll notice that for contains, we don't
pass in the key for our key value pair, instead,
we pass in the key index. And we're going
to do this for all our methods. So I just
have a few convenience bounds checking methods
that you'll see again, throughout these videos,
such as key has to be in the bounds or throw.
So this just makes sure that the key index
is valid. And after this check is done, we
can check does that he exist within our heap
by looking inside the position map and checking
that the value is not equal to negative one.
Then we have things like peak min key index,
which gets the key index for the node at top
of the heap. And similarly, Paul min key index,
and also peak min value and pull min value.
The reason these are separate is because sometimes
we want to just look at the value at the top
of the heap but not necessarily remove it,
the pole version will actually remove it.
Now let's look at insert. So to insert a key
value pair, we need to make sure that that
key value pair does not already exist in the
heap. Otherwise, we're going to throw an exception
that I simply validate if the value is not
null. And if it is we throw an exception.
Otherwise, we simply update our indices for
the position map and inverse map. Then we
assign the values array to have the value
we passed in. And then we swim up that node
which we know will be at position size, and
we also increment the size variable so that
our heap is one element larger than value
of pretty straightforward, just do a look
up inside the values array. then delete is
slightly more interesting. We make sure the
key exists. Then we get the index of where
that key exists within the heap. we swap the
index of the node and the last node in the
heap. Then we reposition the new node we swapped
into ies position To go either up the heap
or down the heap, we capture the value in
the position for the key index so that we
can return it later, we clean up the node
we want to delete. And finally we return that
value. update is also pretty easy. Just make
sure that the key exists and the value is
not no, then we get the index for the node,
then we capture the old value, update the
new value, then move it within the heap. And
finally return the old value. So increase
and decrease are just short for decrease key
and increase key we're dealing with a min
dr heap here. So make sure you take that into
account when looking at the logic. So we make
sure the key exists and it's not know then
if the value is less than the value already
in the heap, the values array at the key index,
we can update it and also swim it down. Notice
that I didn't call the update method here,
because we know we're going to swim down in
the update method, we sink and we swim. So
we do both operations, we don't know which
way the node will go whether it's going to
bubble up or bubble down. But in the decrease
key method, we do. Same thing for the increased
key method, except I switched the order for
the less competitor so that the values array
x and the first position and the value being
passed in is on the right. These are just
the sink and swim methods I talked about in
the slides, we can go over quickly. So to
sync node i, we get the minimum child of node
i since we're working with a D reheat, we
need to search all the children of node, find
the one with the least value, this is going
to be node j and then we swap i and j make
sure that i is equal to the value of j and
then we find the minimum child again and then
repeat this until we can't sink the node anymore.
Same thing for swim, except that we need to
find the parent of note I which we can just
do a look up in the parents array at index
I swap with the parent and keep doing this
until i is less than the parent min child
just looks at all the children of Note II
and finds the one with a minimum value and
returns its index. Also pretty straightforward.
Swap we covered this and slides basically
swapped the indices and the position map and
the inverse map for nodes i and j. Then we
have the last function which simply compares
values, the values for nodes i and j and other
convenience methods just because I didn't
want to include all the logic of throwing
exceptions everywhere. Just kind of wrap them
in helper functions. This is just for tests
to make sure that our heat is in these a min
heap. So that's all there is to an indexed
the air heap. I hope there wasn't too much
to ingest. And thank you for watching. Please
give this video a thumbs up if you learn something
and subscribe for more mathematics and computer
science videos. Thanks